ALL RIGHT
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY WE WILL
BEGIN. THEY'RE BOTH SUPPOSED TO
BE A PART. YEAH WILL BEGIN
TODAY'S HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE AT TODAY'S AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE-
BUDGET RELATED TO TOP NINETY
EIGHT- WE WILL HEAR. ABOUT SOME
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A TWO
. AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
SCHOOL TUITION AND OVERSIGHT
INFRASTRUCTURE LEAD TO THAT THE-
GREEN SCHOOL TECHNOLOGY
TRANSPORTATION AND THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY MAINTENANCE AS
WELL AS FOR LITERACY PROPOSALS
AND CURRICULA DEVELOPMENT
OVERSIGHT. OF THE WILL BEGIN BY
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO FOCUS ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THANK YOU. MORNING CARE MEMBERS
LENA GRANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'M ALL TALK THROUGH
THAT EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM PROPOSAL-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
AN INCREASE OF THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR
THE ELO PROGRAM EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
PROVIDING AN ONGOING TOTAL OF
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS BUILDS UPON THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INVESTMENT
OF ONE BILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. AND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR MILLION. IN ONE TIME
FUNDS ARE WORKING TOWARDS- THE
INTENDED FIVE BILLION BY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. OF PERCENT THE
STATUTE ALL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES REGARDLESS OF COMMUNITY
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
OFFER SUBSIDIZED YELLOW PROGRAMS
PROGRAMMING SERVICES TO ALL
THEIR STUDENTS USING A FEE
SCHEDULE THAT CONSIDERS FAMILY
INCOME AND THE ABILITY TO PAY.
AND GIVEN THE INCREASE TO THE
PROGRAM'S ONGOING BUDGET
BEGINNING AT TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES PROVIDING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WITH 75% OR
ABOVE UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE
PERCENTAGE GPP A RATE OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED. PER AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AND RADIATE WHICH IS
AN INCREASE FROM THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO RATE OF ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PER ADA
. AND FOR ELLIOTT IS BELOW THAT
75% THRESHOLD THE RATE IS
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT UP FROM SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO. I'M CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES A HIGHER RATE TO L. FOR
ELLIE AS- ABOVE A THRESHOLD OF
80% ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF CUSHION FOR THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS PROVIDED IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
THAT WILL ALLOW AT LEAST TO
CONTINUE BUILDING CAPACITY FOR
THEIR ELO PROGRAM OFFERINGS-
ELLIE IS WILL HAVE TO FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
EXPEND FUNDS RECEIVED IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. DURING THE
SIMILAR TREATMENT GIVEN THE
FUNDS RECEIVED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THE CURRENT YEAR.
ALSO AUDIT PENALTIES FOR
NONCOMPLIANCE WILL NOT BE
ENFORCED UNTIL THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FISCAL YEAR. ON THE
AUDIT PIECE- SPECIFICALLY IN
RESPONSE TO MANY OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ELLIE A SINCE
THE ENACTMENT OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE PROGRAM.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES A
PROPORTIONATE AUDIT PENALTY
RELATIVE TO THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS NOT PROVIDED OR OFFERED
ACCESS TO BE A LITTLE PROGRAM
SERVICES. AND THE NUMBER OF DAYS
OR HOURS TO FOUND OUT OF
COMPLIANCE SIMILAR TO THE
EXISTING INSTRUCTIONAL DAY
PENALTIES. THAT ARE USED FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT INSTEAD OF. INSTEAD
OF THE COMPLETE LOSS OF FUNDING
THAT IS THAT IS CURRENTLY IN THE
LAW. LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. TRAILER BILL PROPOSES
SEVERAL TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
FURTHER FACILITATE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
BY ELEAZAR AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ON THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
HELLO. HI GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRUCE MICHAEL FETTERS
WITH A LEO- THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL RAISES SEVERAL
IMPORTANT ISSUES ABOUT DISTRICTS
ABILITY TO AFFORD THE SIGNAL
INCREASE ON FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AS WELL AS HOW THE
EXTRA LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM SOME EFFORTS WAS YELLOW
P. PROGRAM WOULD OFFER A AND B-
LONG TERM WE HAVE PUBLISHED MORE
DETAILED ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE PROPOSAL
BUT WE WILL FOCUS ON A FEW KEY
ISSUES HERE. OF GIVEN THE L. IS
STILL IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION THE EXTENT TO
WHICH DISTRICT THAT BILL CUT
THEIR EXPENDITURE IN PROGRAMS
I'M CLEAR A DISTRICTS THAT FACE
CHALLENGES WITH BUILDING OUT
THEIR ELO P. PROGRAMS MAINLY
BECAUSE- OF THE DIFFICULTY
HIRING STAFF. TO THE EXTENT THAT
STAFFING SHORTAGES CONTINUE TO
BE A CONSTRAINT WRAPPING UP OF
IT'S BEEN A LEARNING PROGRAMS
WILL BE DIFFICULT. THE PROPOSAL
TO DELAY THE AUDITING
REQUIREMENTS THAT MISS GRANT
REFERENCE WITH- GIVE DISTRICTS
INDIVIDUAL YEAR TO BOTH OF THE
PROGRAMS BEFORE THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY HELP THE FUNDING
REDUCED- REGARDING THE LONG TERM
RATE OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR
ENGLISH LEARNER LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
THREE IS LIKELY SUFFICIENT
ENOUGH TO RUN A PROGRAM. SIMILAR
CASES. ASSEMBLY WE HAVE THAT THE
FIVE COMMIT THEO P. IN THE LONG
TERM. WE BE ENOUGH TO FOR ALMOST
PER OF LOS. IN GRADES THREE
THROUGH SIX. OF THIS WITH
SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
PER. ALL OF THE IN THE LEARNER
LOW INCOME THROUGH. ASSEMBLY A
100% FOR. OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS
FOR TO THE- THE TIERED FUNDING
STRUCTURE THAT NOT A LINE WITH
PROGRAMMATIC REQUIRED. THE
IMPLEMENTATION THEY IMPLEMENTING
STATUTE FOR. A EUROPEAN
SPECIFIES AN INTENSE ULTIMATELY
PROVIDE ALL DISTRICTS WITH THE
UNIFORM RATE OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED BRING A STERNER LOW
INCOME STUDENT. HOWEVER
DISTRICTS TO HAVE LOWER SHARES
OF ENGLISH JOURNALISM STUDENTS
HAVE MUCH LOWER EXPECTATIONS.
YOU'RE ONLY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO HALF OF THEIR ENGLISH-
IN LOCUM STUDENTS. WERE AS
DISTRICTS WITH HIGHER SHARES OF
THE STUDENTS MUST PROVIDE ACCESS
TO EVERY STUDENT. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
INTERESTED OUR LOW INCOME-
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM. THIS
MAKES THE FUNDING RATES MORE
GENEROUS FOR DISTRICTS LOWER
SHARES. OF THINGS IN OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. ON THE TRIP TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE A UNIFORM RATE PER
ANDERSON WILL COME STUDENT. WITH
THE SAME REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
DISTRICTS. BEING THAT THEY OFFER
IN PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL ENGLISH
LEARNER IN OAKHAM STUDENTS
INTERESTED IN THE PROGRAM. I
FOCUSING THE REQUIREMENTS AND
FUNDING AROUND EATING LISTENER
LOW INCOME STUDENTS. WE THINK OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ONCE FOR THE
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST NEED
FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT GUARANTEED
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAMS
REGARDLESS. OF WHICH DISTRICT AT
THE AT TEN. NO LONG RUN WE WERE
THAT. HAVE TO A FUN MODEL BAY
FUNDS TO PROTESTS. IN THE
PROGRAM. THIS WILL ENSURE STATE
FOR IS TIED TO DO WOULD DISTRICT
HAVE THE GREATEST FOR THE PRO.
WELL WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
STATE REQUIRED DISTRICTS TO
REPORT THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING. IN NUMBER STAFF
EMPLOYED IN THEIR EXPENDITURE IN
PROGRAMS. THIS INFORMATION COULD
BE USED IN THE FUTURE TO
CONSIDER CHANGES TO RESTRUCTURE
OR STAFFING REQUIREMENTS. LASTLY
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR ARTS AND MUSIC.
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
DISTRICTS CAN ROLL OVER UNSPENT
FUNDING RATE- INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
FLEXIBILITY TO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. GIVEN THE CHALLENGES
BUILDING OUT PROGRAMS WE THINK
THAT IT'S HIGHLY LIKELY
DISTRICTS WILL HAVE UNSPENT
FUNDS FROM THE CURRENT YEAR AND
WAS YEAR. TO THE EXTENT THAT
DISTRICTS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ONE
TIME PURCHASES OF. THE BILL OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT CAN DO SO WITH
THESE EXISTING FUNDS. AT THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING WE
RECOMMEND REMOVING THE
RESTRICTIONS. THAT 75% OF THE
FUNDS BE SPECIFICALLY FOR ARTS
AND MUSIC. BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH EXPERTS WE
THINK THAT. DISTRICTS SHOULD
HAVE LOOKED ABILITY TO SPEND ONE
TIME FUNDING ON A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES. THAT WOULD HELP THEM
DEVELOP A QUALITY PROGRAM. SUCH
AS STAFF TRAINING FACILITY
MOTHER MODIFICATIONS AND SCIENCE
EQUIPMENT- THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOT
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FUNK ON THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EXPANDED LEARNING DIVISION
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TESTIFIED TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. THIS
ONE BEFORE I START THANK OF THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
PARTY GOING SUPPORT. FOR THE
NURTURING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
EXPANDED LEARNING AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
PROBABLY THE G. CATION IS
GRATEFUL. FOR THE ADDITIONAL
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION IT FOR
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. OR AOKI.
EXHILARATING TO THE FIVE BILLION
GOAL THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE PAST YEAR'S BUDGET. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOTTED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. OR PUBLICLY
FUNDED SCHOOL BASED AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SEEN AS THE INNOVATOR. AND
LEADER FOR MENTIONING HOW
LEARNING CAN BE ENHANCED AND
EXPANDED THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS. THUS THE NAME
CHANGE FROM AFTER SCHOOL TO
EXPAND OF LEARNINGS IN. TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WHILE THE PLO P.
FUNDING. WITH THE L. P. FUNDING
. K. TWELVE EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY EDUCATORS FROM
COMMITTEE ORGANIZATIONS FAITH
BASED ALL TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS
. WILL COLLABORATE IN A WAY THAT
WAS ONLY DREAMED OF BEFORE.
STUDENTS THAT HAVE EXISTED IN
THE MARGINS. WILL BE SEEN
SUPPORTED. NO ONE EVER PREPARED
. OUR FULL. L. E. LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA. MUST RESIST STARTING
FIRST TO THINK ABOUT THE RULES
AND THE COMPLIANCE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THIS PROGRAM. FOR L. A.
LEADERS TO START. WITH FIRST
CONSIDERING WHAT THEIR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES NEED AND DESERVE.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
TO THE TRAILER BILL THAT WILL
FACILITATE JUST THAT. THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IS THE
PROPORTIONAL WITHHOLDING THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES ALREADY
MENTIONED. THIS ALLOWS LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES A WAY TO DO
THEIR BEST WITHOUT HIGH RISK OF
LOSING EVERYTHING IF THEY FAIL
IN ONE COMPONENT. WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATORS SUPERINTENDENTS.
OTHER LEADERS THAT THE STAKES
WERE TOO HIGH BEFORE THIS
PROPORTIONAL METHOD WAS ADDED
AND SO THIS REALLY NEEDS TO BE
TO STAY IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. AS WILL NOW HAVE THE
INCENTIVE TO DO THE BEST.
BEATLES CREATIVE AT INNOVATIVE
AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT FEAR OF
BEING OVERLY PENALIZED. WE ARE
STILL REVIEWING THE FULL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WILL BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO REFINE THE
PROPOSAL IN THE WEEKS AHEAD. AND
THE CITY HAS BEEN PROVIDED MANY
VERY. OPPORTUNITIES FOR ELEAZAR
TO RECEIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND COACHING. WE ARE APPEARING
BEFOR MANY OF THEM ARE
EDUCATIONAL STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY
GROUPS OR MEMBERSHIP GROUPS TO
PRESENT DETAILS AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THIS
PROGRAM WE ARE HOSTING WEEKLY
OFFICE HOURS WHERE ELLIE A
LEADERS JOINING THEM FOR AN HOUR
AND A HALF ON FRIDAYS FROM NOON
TO ONE THIRTY. TO ADDRESS
QUESTIONS TO TALK THROUGH IDEAS
AND TO MATCH THEM WITH PEERS WE
HAVE FIGURED OUT A WAY FOR THIS
TO WORK. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST. OF COURSE
WILL REMAIN ONAND ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION ANSWER QUESTIONS.
I'LL TAKE ONE MOMENT OF- WE ARE
SEEN- MY PERSONAL CRUSADE IS TO
THIS PROGRAM NOT TO BE CALLED A
LOT OF IT REMINDS ME OF SOME
KIND OF A CYCLOPS MOVIE- SO I'VE
TIMED IT IT DOESN'T TAKE ANY
LONGER TO SAY YELLOW P. OR
YELLOW PROGRAM THANK YOU LOP SO
THAT'S MY. THE LIGHT HEARTED ON
THE SIDE. ASSIDUOUS FOR THIS FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY YOU NOW WILL HE FIRST FROM
AN ENTITY. IN THE GROUND OUT
THERE THROUGHOUT. FOR THE MINOR
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU MICHAEL THANKS FOR REMINDING
US TO CALL IT YELLOW P. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF. MY COLLEAGUES WITHIN
THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING AS WELL AS THE
GRANTEES THAT I SUPPORT MY NAME
AGAIN IS MARBLED I AM THE
REGIONAL THE PER REGION FIVE X.
EARNING AND BASTYR MONTEREY
COUNTY OFFICE EDUCATION. I
SUPPORT TWO HUNDRED FORTY
EXISTING AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
AND SAFETY A SENSE AND TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY COMMUNITY LEARNING
CENTER T. K. THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE PROGRAMS. IN A FOUR COUNTY
SERVICE AREA SO I REPRESENT
MODERATE AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SAN BENITO AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY HERE TODAY AS WELL AS- MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE
AGAIN YOU I PROVIDE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT I WERE ON THE BOOTS AND
YOU KNOW ON THE GROUNDS
PROVIDING. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
MEANING I'M COACHING A
CONSULTATION FACILITATION AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY BROKERING
RESOURCES AT A LOCAL LEVEL TO
ENSURE THE QUALITY. OF OUR
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS I'M I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE GRANTEES THAT I SUPPORT
TODAY- I'M THE EXCITEMENT THAT
WE HAVE IN THE FIELD AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS LIKE NONE OTHER
ANYTHING FOR MANY MANY YEARS
I'VE BEEN IN THE FIELD NOW FOR A
COUPLE OF DECADES. AND WE HAVE
OFTENTIMES BEEN ADVOCATING FOR A
RATE INCREASE WHICH WE RECENTLY
RECEIVED FOR A SYSTEM TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY UP TO. TEN DOLLARS
AN EIGHTEEN CENTS WHICH WAS A
BLESSING I'M FOR MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS- WE CANNOT SURVIVE OF
COURSE WITHOUT OUR COMMUNITY
BASED PARTNERS AND- I'M-
REPRESENTING THE REGION THAT I
DO AND THAT THE HIGHEST QUALITY-
COST OF LIVING AREA- THERE ARE
MANY OF COURSE AND STATE GOT.
I'M SANTA AND SAN CLARA BEING OF
THEM. THAT WAS AN INITIAL OPERA
. TO PER US RATE. TO HELP WITH.
AT THE- AND RETENTION OF QUALITY
STAFF TOWARD FIELD. AND WITH THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY AB
PROGRAM WE HAVE AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO PERHAPS GET EVEN
CLOSER TO A LIVING WAGE. AND
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT-
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS WHO. ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW TO
FIND. AT TO FIND QUALITY STAFF
TO RETAIN QUALITY STAFF- THIS IS
REALLY REALLY INSTRUMENTAL- TO
THEIR SUCCESS AND- SO I JUST
WANNA. THANK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS ALL THE
ADVOCACY THAT HAS BEEN- GOING ON
OVER THE AIR TO. TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE- AN INCREASE THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HAPPEN. AND WITHOUT SAID- I MOST
RECENTLY SPOKE WITH THE DISTRICT
TO IS REALLY THINKING OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX THEY'RE VERY EXCITED TO.
NOT ONLY SERVE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS- BUT TO ALSO PROVIDE
INNOVATIVE AND- INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMMING RELATIVE TO SCHEME
ON MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
MEETING. THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITY
AND WITH THE FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT WE HAD WITH THE EAST SAYS
EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC. A LOT
OF OUR PROGRAMS WERE ABLE TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN
WAYS THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO IN THE PAST. AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS- HAVING OUR STAFF- OUR
FRONTLINE. STAFF AGE STUDENTS-
WHO ARE IN. TO RUNNING PROGRAM
AN AFFRONT LINE LEVEL WHO BUILT
THE RELATIONS WITH THE STUDENTS
THEY WERE MAKING CALLS HOME TO
THE FAMILIES. I'M MAKING SURE
THAT THEY WERE REALLY LISTENING
TO THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE NEEDS WERE
BEING MAC. THIS IS WHERE WE SAW
A LOT OF INCREASE IN- SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT- MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'M
CONNECTION TO- DIFFERENT TYPES
OF OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE. AND SO I THINK MANY
OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE L. O. P. FUNDING
AS A WAY TO CONTINUE THOSE
SUPPORTS. I'M HAVING THE
FLEXIBILITY HOPEFULLY TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT PERHAPS EVEN ON A
FULL TIME BASIS OUR MOST OF OUR
STAFF RIGHT NOW OR PART TIME.
AND BUT IT DOES RAISE THE OF
COURSE QUESTION- ANNA CONCERNED
THAT HAS COME UP FOR MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS REGARDING THE NINE
HOUR REQUIREMENT IN PARTICULAR.
AND MOST ESPECIALLY DURING
SUPPLEMENTAL AND MOST ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR WORLD DISTRICTS. I'M THE
MINIMUM BASE MINIMUM FUNDING AT
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR ONLINE OUR PROGRAM
IS- YOU'RE GOING POSSIBLE. FOR
MANY OF OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND OUR RURAL SMALL- CHECKER
SITES. IT'S ESTIMATED IT TAKES
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO RUN A QUALITY PROGRAM- THAT
INCLUDES ALL OF THE THAT CRAP
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUPPLIES TO CREATE AND- I REALLY
AND REGIONAL PROGRAM. I'M ALSO
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO- CONTRACT
WAS WITH HER PARTNERS YOU MIGHT
BRING IN SOME OF THOSE
ENRICHMENT COMPONENTS THAT STAFF
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO. A RALLY
IN PROGRAM THEMSELVES. SO IT
DOES TAKE A COMMUNITY EFFORT- I
WOULD URGE US ALL TO TAKE A
LOOK- MARC CLOSELY AND DEEPLY.
AT AS THE CHALLENGES THAT MAY
OCCUR FOR A ROLES AND SMILES
WITH THE MINIMUM- AS WELL AS THE
INCREASED SUPPORTS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE DO YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. PEOPLE LIKE ME IN MY ROLE-
pHER OUT THERE MAKING THE LOCAL
CONNECTIONS AND BUILDING THE
LOCAL RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR.
VENDOR PARTNERS I'M- YOU REALLY
ARE MORE THAN. THEY REALLY BE.
COLLABORATIVE CLOUD. WITH SB
PART OF OUR LEARNING. AND
THEY'RE REALLY IN CALLED OF.
MAKING OUR- AS THE HIGH QUALITY
IS THE CAN BE. I'M I MAY STOP
THEIR- AND THEN ENTERED CLASS-
AS THEY OCCUR. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE FIELD THAT I'M WE ARE WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING BACK SCHEME BRING BACK-
ALL OF THE- M. OUTDOOR LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND FIELD TRIPS IN
PARTICULAR. I HEAR THAT A LOT WE
WANT TO GET OUR KIDS OUT THERE
AND EXPERIENCING NATURE WE WANT
TO GET THEM OUT THERE AND
EXPERIENCING OUR MUSEUMS AGAIN-
AND REALLY PARTAKING IN
OPPORTUNITIES THAT. REALLY
EXPAND THEIR HORIZONS AND BUILT
IT THAT QUALITY AND SKILLS THAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO SURVIVE
NOT ONLY ACADEMICALLY BUT
SOCIALLY- DURING THEIR ACADEMIC
CAREERS AND OF COURSE IN LIFE.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW GO TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS ITEM WHO CAN
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL START
THIS MORNING- I WILL SAY THAT
THIS IS A BUDGET PROPOSAL OF
COURSE BUT THIS REALLY. IS A
IMPLEMENTATION FROM LAST YEAR'S.
A BUDGET AND WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
HOW. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS LIKE
NO BUDGET EVER BEFORE WITH- YOU
KNOW IT EXTENSIVE PROPOSAL AFTER
PROPOSAL I'M NOT PROPOSAL BUT
BUT- BASICALLY ACTIONS THAT- WE
LOOK AT THE LIST YOU KNOW YOU
FOCUS ON THE TOTALITY BUT ALL
EVERYONE OF THEM COULD HAVE BEEN
A ONCE IN A. GENERATION THING
AND THIS IS ONE- UNIVERSAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WHICH WE NOW
WILL. NOT JUST HELP. KEEP KIDS
SAFE AFTER SCHOOL BUT- WE FOCUS
ON EXPANDED LEARNING I WILL NOTE
THAT THAT MR FONG HI. I DO NOT
WANT TO CALL IT ET L'APPAREIL
ILIO WHATEVER LET'S JUST BE
SIMPLE ITS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT THE PARENTS KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO WHY WEEK COMPLICATING THINGS
LIKE GOVERNMENT PEOPLE LIKE WE
ARE SO WE SHOULD JUST GO BACK-
TO THE FUTURE AND FOCUS ON
CALLING IT WHAT IT REALLY IS
IT'S AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
SO- I REALLY APPRECIATE THE-
UNIVERSAL ASPECT OF THIS TOO. I
THINK TO MANY- MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES GET SQUEEZED OUT AND
IT'S TOUGH PAYING THE BILLS AND
THE RENT AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO
HAVING A UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. IS A BIG BIG
WIN AND WE KNOW THAT IT'LL PAY
DIVIDENDS FOR THAT- I CAN I
SUCCESS OF OUR- AND SELL- BIG
BIG SO. OF THE AND I WAS ONE OF
OUR MOST POPULAR. ACTION ITEMS
IN THIS IS OF COURSE
IMPLEMENTATION SO I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I WANT TO.
DEPOSE ONE IS FOR THE-
ADMINISTRATION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
THE QUESTIONS. IN THE AGENDA
THERE'S A FEW OF THEM BUT THEY
BUT RELATED TO THE OVERALL- AND
RATES. AND WE HAVE SOME FOR- THE
ASUS PROGRAM AND SOME FOR THE
NEW PROGRAM AND- AND THERE'S
JUST NOT- YOU KNOW. THE SECRET
IS THE AND ALL THAT SO- WHY ARE
WE COMPLICATING THINGS AND HAVE
IT HAVING THESE- DIFFERENT RATES. WHEN I GRANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- RATES WE WERE LOOKING
AT WHAT THE STATUTE SAYS THE CAP
AT JUST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PER
ADA- AND THAT'S WHAT. WAS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUT AT TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET ACTING MANY YEARS
COMPUTERS- AND SO THE WAY THAT
THE FUNDING WHEN OUT IN HERE ONE
WITH IT WAS APPROXIMATELY A
SIXTY FORTY SPLIT- SO 60% OF THE
FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE PROGRAM WENT TO ELEAZAR
ABOVE BATTER ABOVE 80% UCBCP.
AND THE RED THE REMAINING FUNDS
WENT TO THOSE BELOW AND IN THE
END THAT WE YOU KNOW WE MODELED-
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT I'M KIND
OF IN FUNDING RATES PER ADA- AND
WE ENDED UP IN. VARIOUS OPTIONS
FOR DIFFERENT UNDUPLICATED
PEOPLE PERCENTILE CUT OFF AS
WELL SO- WHAT WE LANDED AT IS
THAT KEEPING IT KEEPING THE RATE
ONE THE TIER ONE- AT TWENTY
FIVE. HUNDRED AND PROVIDING A
SIXTY FORTY SPLIT IN YEAR TWO OF
THE PROGRAM- IF WE SHIFTED THAT
80% U. P. P. 275% THE FUNDING
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED. D. FORTY
SPLIT THAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
IT BUT IT ALSO ALLOWED US WITH
THE BIGGER BUCKET OF MONEY SORRY
THERE'S AN AIRPLANE GOING BY.
ABOUT WITH THE WITH A FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION ONGOING VERSUS THE
ONE BILLION. I'M GOING- THE
FUNDING RATE EIGHTY FOUR THE
TIER ONE AS A FIVE PER OR ABOVE
WOULD BE A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
AND A MUCH HIGHER FUNDING RATE.
FOR THE TIER TWO- ORDER WAS
BELOW SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE PERCENTAGE-
THEY WOULD RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY
TWO THOUSAND THAT EXACT. THAT
EXACT NUMBER- WILL BE SUBJECT TO
CHANGE THE BIRTH THE TWO
THOUSAND THE SECOND NUMBER ONCE-
ONCE THE CITY EVEN ACTUAL
NUMBERS ARE REPORTED FOR
ATTENDANCE- FROM CD BUT- THAT IS
OUR ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW. AND THEN
HOW DOES THIS RELATE TO WHAT
THE- THAT SO THIS IS THE RIGHT
THIS ISN'T A TOLERATE SO THIS IS
THE RATE. THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
FROM THE STATE PERSON STATE AND
THEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
PARENT FEES I GUESS MATCH WOULD
BE. BUT BUT THE WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO FILL. THE FELLOW
BACK ENTIRELY IS THIS AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE. YOU KNOW BURDENSOME
FEES- ESPECIALLY WHEN WE KNOW
THAT. WE HAVE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES AND POTENTIAL ANOTHER
ONE LOOMING. SO IN A MAKE SURE
THESE PENCIL OUT AND ANSWERED OF
FAMILIES. YEAH THE WAY THAT THE
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY- STRUCTURED
WAY WE ENVISION IT IN THE
STATUTE IS THAT IT IS- PROVIDED
REGARDLESS- REGARDLESS OF
COMMUNITY DEMOGRAPHICS ALL
PARENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
LOW COST IT'LL BE ANOTHER
SLIDING FEE SCALE SIMILAR TO THE
WAY A SENSE AND- TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY IS STRUCTURED. TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PROGRAMMING
INSTRUCTOR. AND THE DIFFERENCE
WITH THAT YELLOW P. PROGRAM. I'M
GETTING BETTER AT SAYING NOT
SAYING YOU OP- SO THE DIFFERENCE
AT THAT IS THAT- THIS PROGRAM IS
FUNDED- BASED ON YOU PP
ATTENDANCE AT THE L. EA. SO IT'S
AT BUT IT'S NOT. THE FUNDING OF
THE PROVIDING FOR PARTICIPATION
IN THE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY SO
YOU GET A HIGHER FUNDING RATE
SINCE THE FUNDING IS BASED ON
THAT ELEAZAR YOU PP. OKAY AND
THEN LET'S LET'S GO ON TO THE
UNIVERSAL ASPECT OF IT I THINK
THAT'S ONE THING THAT THE
MEMBERS REALLY APPRECIATE
WHETHER IT'S BEST. FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IS
HAVING A PROGRAM THAT'S FOR
EVERYBODY- SO YOU DON'T SQUEEZE
OUT. MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES WHO
YOU KNOW ARE JUST TOO RICH TO
QUALIFY FOR FREE BUT DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY FOR IT THEY
THE PROGRAM THEMSELVES. SO
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING IS
VERY ATTRACTIVE TO US SO HOW DO
WE ANTICIPATE. THAT THIS REVIEW-
BEING IMPLEMENTED TO MAKE TO
MAKE SURE IT'S UNIVERSAL FOR ALL
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA. I THINK THE
QUESTION IS FOR ME AGAIN YOU'RE
GONNA. AT- SO. THE WAY THAT THE
WE ENVISION THIS PROGRAM WORKING
WE SEE IT AS A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM THAT IS THAT BRAIDS KIND
OF THE ASUS PROGRAM THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FUNDS THAT- ELLIE
IS RECEIVED AND BECAUSE FIVE YOU
KNOW AT LEAST RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THEY CAN
LEVERAGE. OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING TO SUPPLEMENT- THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROGRAMMING FOR
EXTENDED LEARNING SERVICES-
BECAUSE LIKE I LIKE I SAID AT
THE BECAUSE THE PROGRAM IS IT
FUNDED BASED ON STUDENT
PARTICIPATION. THE EFFECTIVE
FUNDING RATE PER STUDENT WAS
REALLY GONNA DEPEND ON THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT RECEIVE
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM- AND I
THINK OUR ESTIMATES AND ELLY
ELLS ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT A
LIKELY BE ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
PROVIDE ACCESS. 62% OF ALL KIDS
T. THREE T. K. THREE SIX UP ON
GLOBAL IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT
WOULD COVER ALL- AND DUPLICATED
PEOPLE PEOPLE'S. ALL RIGHT CAN I
GET A MISTER FUNK ON THE ON THE
- UP HERE. AND I CALL. I'M HERE
IS YES- MAY YOU COULD ADDRESS
THE TO TWO ISSUES THAT FIRST ONE
IS- THE UNIVERSAL PERSPECTIVE.
FOR ALL KIDS IN CALIFORNIA HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DELIVERED THE
PROMISE FROM. OUR LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ACTION. IT'S A IT'S- AS
WE'VE GOT- A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF LIAISE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THAT HAVE NEVER
OPERATED AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
BEFORE THEY HAVEN'T HAD ANY
SINCE OUR TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
FUNDING. AND QUITE FRANKLY OF
MANY OF THEM ARE ASKING IF THEY
HAVE TO DO THIS THEY HAVE TO
TAKE THE BODY AND SO ARE BIG
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN. TO MATCH UP
THESE NEW LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WHICH QUITE FRANKLY
HAVE A LOT OF THINGS ON THEIR
PLATE RIGHT NOW WITH ALL THE
CHALLENGES OF STAFF IN SCHOOLS
IN KEEPING SCHOOLS OPEN AND THE
OVERCROWDED AND THE CHALLENGES
AND TO GET THEM TO THINK OF AN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE. BUT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
TRYING TO MATCH. DISTRICTS WHO
ARE RELUCTANT. OR HESITANT.
PASSED WITH DISTRICTS YOU REALLY
HAVE A VISION FOR OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS. CAN BE A
CRITICAL ELEMENT TO SUPPORT
EQUITY TO SUPPORT- OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE NOT HAVE
THE UP THE ADVANTAGES. SO- THE
AND THIS DOES DOES BLEED INTO
THE- THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
RATES. BECAUSE OF IS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO GET STUDENT
ENOUGH TO MAKE THIS UNIVERSAL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN TIER ONE
THE PROPOSAL A 5% AND ABOVE AND
TO PUT IT. THE CLEANER FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WAS
ACCURATE. THAT IT ALL DEPENDS ON
HOW MANY STUDENTS COME AND RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. WHO ARE MODELING
THINGS OUT. AND SOMEONE JUST
THROWING UP THEIR HANDS AND SAY
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY IT'S
NOT GOING TO WORK. BECAUSE THEY
ARE CALCULATING- THEY'RE
CALCULATING IF EVERY STUDENT
THAT CAN COME WILL COME WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S NOT
LIKELY TO HAPPEN I MEAN I'VE
BEEN IN THIS WORK. AS YOU KNOW
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR ABOUT THIRTY
YEARS TWENTY YEARS IN THE BAY
AREA ENGINEERS HERE AT CD. AND-
UNIVERSAL DOES NOT BE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS DOES NOT MEAN THAT EVERY
STUDENT CAN COME WILL IT JUST
DOESN'T DOESN'T MEET THE NEEDS
FOR SOME FAMILIES. SO RIGHT NOW-
I THINK THE WAY TO GET TO
UNIVERSAL. IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE DISTRICTS HAVE COACHING.
UNDERSTAND HOW TO DEVELOP A HIGH
QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT KIDS WILL WANT TO ATTEND
AND PARENTS WILL WANT THEIR
CHILDREN TO EXPAND ITS- THAT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN THROUGH AN
OCCASIONAL WEAPON. IS NOT GONNA
HAPPEN THROUGH A TOOL KIT. IT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN THROUGH- ONE
VISIT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
COACHING IT'S GONNA TAKE
RELATIONSHIPS IT'S GONNA TAKE
MENTORING. MARVELED ON THE LINE
HERE FROM THE OFFICE OF MAURY
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IS
PART OF OUR SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
FOR EXPANDED LEARNING- WE
BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT NETWORK
COVERAGE IN ALL THE SYSTEMS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- WITH CC EAGER
PARTNERSHIP WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NETWORK COMMUTER WELL.
AND WE'RE LEVERAGING ALL THE
SYSTEMS THE SMALL THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT ASSOCIATE. AXTA
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS- WE'RE PRESENTING
A CONFERENCE AT THE CURRICULUM
INSTRUCTION SYMPOSIUM THIS WEEK.
TO DO COACHING AND MENTORING.
BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ROBUST EFFORT OF
SUPPORTING COACHING. TO MAKE
THIS UNIVERSAL IT'S JUST NOT
GONNA HAPPEN BECAUSE WE M
DGET. YEAH YOU YOU BROUGHT UP
A POINT I WANNA FOCUS ON A BIT
AND THIS IS REALLY TOWARDS THE
RATE STRUCTURE- AND I COMPLETELY
AGREE YEAH. ALL THESE THINGS
WERE DOING IN THIS IN THIS
BUDGET FRANKLY IT'S- IT'S NOT
THE MONEY IT'S IMPLEMENTATION
PUT THIS IN CHILDCARE AND T. K.
AND- A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS WE HAVEMONEY'S NOT THE
ISSUE IT'S MAKING SURE WE
IMPLEMENT THEM RIGHTS YOU COULD
OPEN A BUNCH OF AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND- YOU DOORS WIDE
OPEN SAY COME ON IN IF IT'S A-
IF IT'S A CRUMMY PROGRAM. PEOPLE
ARE GONNA WALK WITH OUR FEET AND
NOT PARTICIPATE. AND ONE THING
IS THE IS THE- THE SALARIES AND
WAGES FOR THE WORKERS WE SEE
THIS WITH- EARLY AT THE END OF
THE SUMMER RACE AND I WORKING ON
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR EARLY
AND FOR AFTER SCHOOL. I KNOW
JUST FOR MY OWN KIDS. THEIR NON
. GRADE WHEN THEY'RE IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THEY HAD AT.
THEIR PROGRAM HERE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEY WENT THROUGH
A LOT OF STAFF HERE IN THERE
BECAUSE THAT THE- WORKERS. YOU
KNOW IF PRODUCTION- LEAGUE
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE YOU KNOW.
LATE TEENS EARLY TWENTIES. THEY
COULD MAKE MORE GOING AND
WORKING AT STARBUCKS OR YOU KNOW
SOMEWHERE ELSE. THAN THEY COULD.
IN THIS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
AND THE CDVA UTILIZZARE YOUR
PAST ASSET WHICH IS YOUR
WORKFORCE. SO DO YOU DO YOU
THINK. THAT THEIR RATES WE HAVE
HERE. ARE SUFFICIENT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE. HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS WE CAN BRING IN THE
COACHING OTHERS TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE- STABILIZED AND VALUABLE
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THEY THEY'RE
THEY'RE TEND TO SERVE. I'LL TAKE
THAT A TUTOR FOR WAYS MISTER.
FIRST OF ALL AS LEADER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED
IT IS THE INTENT. THAT ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. M. THE
EXPELLER IN OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM IS ONE COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM THIS IS TAKEN A BIT FOR.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
GET THEIR HEAD AROUND- BUT
INSTEAD OF THINKING OF BASIS
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND ELO P.
EVEN IF THEY'RE STRUCTURED
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENTLY. I SEE A
CLEAR WAY THE DATES CAN BE
CONSIDERED. THREE DIFFERENT
FUNDING STREAMS FOR ONE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM AND IN SO
DOING- WE CAN INCREASE. THE
AMOUNT OF THE WAGES AB AND PAY
PEOPLE MORE AT THE SENATE
HEARING- ANY READING FROM YOUR
UNIFIED HAVE TALKED ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE GOING USE THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE GIVING OUT RATE
INCREASES FOR PAY FOR STAFF AND
FOR SITE COORDINATORS- SOME
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOW
CONSIDERING CAN WE BRING OUR
CYCLE COORDINATORS ON AS A FULL
TIME. POSITION MAYBE EVEN WITH
BENEFITS SO THIS BECOMES MORE OF
A CAREER PATH. I THINK THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THESE.
STREAMS BLEND TOGETHER- IS WORTH
A LOT OF CONVERSATION MAYBE NOT
FOR THIS HEARING BUT WE'RE AS WE
WORK WITH- FINANCE AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS OF MAYBE SOME TWEAKS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN IN THE ACES AND
CODE IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE CAN BE MORE
COMPATIBLE THERE FUNDAMENTALLY
STRUCTURED IN DIFFERENT FUNDING
MODELS WERE WITH ACES IT'S VERY
CLEAR YOU'VE GOT A DAILY RATE
PER CHILD YOU'VE GOT ATTENDANCE.
GOALS THAT ARE SET BY STATE YOU
YOUR TARGET GOALS ARE FOR
ATTENDANCE AND YELLOW PIAS VERY
MUCH ABOUT OCT- ACCESS AND-
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES BUT
ATTENDANCE IS LEFT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE FAMILY. THE
SECOND POINT THOUGH I THINK THAT
. WE NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS IN
TERMS OF WORK FORCE BECAUSE THAT
IS THE ISSUE THAT IS THE
UNIVERSAL. CHALLENGE WE'RE
HEARING FROM SMALLER DISTRICTS
RURAL LARGE DISTRICTS IS
WORKFORCE AND THAT'S NOT
DISSIMILAR TO IN THE INDUSTRY.
IN IN OUR COUNTRY. OR THE WORLD
- MY CONTENTION IS IF WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MATCH WHAT IS YOUR
HOURLY RAGE IN COMPETITION WITH
STARBUCKS. OR SOME OTHER-
BUSINESS NOT TO PLUG ANYONE
BUSINESS BUT- ALL BUSINESSES
PULLING OUT THE STOPS TO MAKE
THEIR BUSINESS MORE ATTRACTIVE
HIGHER WAGE MORE BENEFITS. WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE THAT COMPETITION.
BUT IF WE FRAME THIS. AS NOT
JUST. A LIVABLE AND MORE THAN
LIVABLE WAGE. BUT AS A ENTRY
POINT AND GATEWAY TO A CAREER IN
EDUCATION. THAT WE CAN MAKE
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME COUNT FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION HOURS- WE'VE
BEEN DOING SOME WORK WITH. THE
CREDENTIALING FOLKS IN WITH
HIGHER EDUCATION. SO THE STAFF
PERSON CAN GET CREDIT TOWARDS
THEIR TEACHER PREPARATION FOR
THE TIME THEY SPEND. IT WORKING
EXPAND AS OUR NEEDS- EXPANDED
LEARNING ACTUALLY COURSE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. ARE NOT JUST
AFTER SCHOOL THEY ARE PART OF
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. L. FOR.
YOUR ADULTS OLDER ADULTS ALL
TYPES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSIDERING SOME TYPE OF CRUDE
EDUCATION THIS BECOMES THE
PORTAL THROUGH WHICH THEY CAN
NOT ONLY LIVE AND GET A
MEANINGFUL WAGE I HAVE
EXPERIENCED TAKEN TOWARDS THEIR
CAREER PATH. THANK YOU THEN THE
LAST QUESTION IS- I THINK IT IS
A BIT CONFUSING WITH ALL OF OUR
AFTER SCHOOL INVESTMENTS AND
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO SIMPLIFY AND
CALL IT AFTER SCHOOL. PROGRAMS
THAT'S WHAT IT IS THAT'S WHAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOTED THAT'S
WHAT PARENTS NOWADAYS. BUT ALL
THESE FUNDING STREAMS WE HAVE WE
HAVE. A SAYS THROUGH PROP FORTY
NINE AND TOWARDS THEIR GRIP ON
THE BALLOT IN TWO THOUSAND
JEWISH I GUESS- THEN WE HAVE THE
FEDERAL MONEY FROM THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND THEN WE HAVE
THE EXPANDED LEARNING GRANTS. IT
WOULD BE A DISASTER IF THESE GO
OUT AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
YOU KNOW- BASICALLY- OFFERING
THESE AND ALL THESE DIFFERENT
ACRONYMS AND I THINK IT'S SUPER
CONFUSING SO WHAT ARE WE DOING
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF AD AND
LEVEL I KNOW I LEGISLATION ON
THIS BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK AS
FAR AS JUST STREAMLINING AND
HAVING. WHAT THREE POTS OF MONEY
GO AND HAVE ONE SIMPLIFIED.
OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO OFFER AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
BUT A VERY BASIC LEVEL BECAUSE
IN THIS CURRENT MOMENT IN TIME
WE STILL HAVE THE DIFFERENT
FUNDING STREAMS WITH DIFFERENT
SECTIONS OF THE CODE OF COURSE
THERE'S A CORRELATION WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. WE ARE DOING A FINE.
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS WHO HAVE
FIGURED OUT HOW TO LAND THE
STREAMS TOGETHER AND BRING THEM
TOGETHER INTO ONE COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM. AND WERE ELEVATED THAT
WERE INTERVIEWING THEM ONLINE
WERE WERE. PRODUCING VIDEO BLOGS
WHERE THEY'RE TELLING THEIR
STORY WE'RE PROVIDING PLACES.
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GATHER AND
GOING TO BREAK OUT GROUPS
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING MATCHING THEM
WITH DISTRICS WHO HAVE FIGURED
THIS OUT- AND THERE ARE SOME
TWEAKS WE NEED TO MAKE UP. IN
TERMS OF BUT I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
REALLY ASKING MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
LIKE. WHAT IS THE FUTURE OF THIS
IS A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY OF
COURSE TWENTY FOR CENTURIES A
FEDERAL PROGRAM. AND THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS TO WHAT CHANGES WE
CANMAKE THERE SOME SOME STATE
IMPLEMENTATION FLEXIBILITY AS
WELL. AND MANY IN THE- AFTER
SCHOOL UNIVERSE. HAVE RAISE THE
CONCERN THAT BECAUSE THE EVIL
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON T. K.
THREE SIX. THAT ARE OLDER YOUTH
MIGHT BE GETTING- DOCUMENTS THEY
NEED OUR MIDDLE SCHOOL PROGRAM
USE THAT ARE HIGH SCHOOL HOUSTON
SO. WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW. TO WORK
WITH THESE FUNDING STREAMS IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE I THINK- YOUR
INSTINCTS ARE CORRECT. THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE THREE DIFFERENT
FUNDING STREAMS THREE ACRONYMS
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN TRAINING IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOR A LONG
TIME. TO KEEP THINGS SEPARATE
DON'T MIX THINGS UP KEEP THINGS
IN SILOS THAT WAY YOU'RE GONNA
FOLLOW ALL THE RULES YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET IN TROUBLE. AND THAT'S
NOT GOOD FOR KIDS IT'S NOT GOOD
FOR FAMILIES IN IS CONFUSING FOR
PARENTS. SO WE'RE VERY OPEN TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW.
TO MAKE SURE. THAT YOU KNOW I
I'M ALWAYS. I'M ALWAYS GONNA SAY
WHAT OUR PARENTS AND STUDENTS
NEED AND WHAT'S GOING TO BE MOST
BENEFICIAL FOR THAT IS WHERE WE
SHOULD FOCUS AND OF CREATING
SOMETHING THAT'S LESS CONFUSING
AND WHEN THEY LOOK AT THEIR
SCHOOL THEY SEE. ONE THE HIGH
QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL SUMMER
PROGRAM YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE ACRONYMS WHAT IS
CALLED- I SUPPORT SLIDING FEES
ARE NOT A BIG PROPONENT OF
SOMETHING THAT'S HEAVILY BASED
ON SLIDING FEES BECAUSE OUR
FAMILIES AS YOU'VE SAID OR
STRESSED ENOUGH. SO WE'RE OPEN
TO THIS CONVERSATION AND HOW TO
WORK TOGETHER SO OUR FAMILIES
CAN SEE. I QUALITY AFTER SCHOOL
SOMETHING THAT'S PART OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. OKAY THANK
YOU THAT THAT'S IT FOR ME-
MISTER O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- LISTEN I LOVE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS I DON'T
LOVE THIS PROPOSAL. AND I CAN
EXPLAIN WHY- THIS IS AN AWFULLY
EXPENSIVE PROGRAM. THAT WE ARE
SEEKING TO CREATE. OUR
CLASSROOMS ARE ALREADY UNDER
FUNDED. UNDER THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE STILL BE MORE UNDERFUNDED
IF YOU WILL- BUT WE'RE CREATING
NEW PROGRAMS IT'S LIKE THE
KITCHENS ON FIRE. BUT WORRIED
ABOUT THE DRAPES IN THE LIVING
ROOM- AGAIN LOVE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS BUT THIS IS A VERY
EXPENSIVE PROGRAM WITH ONGOING
MONEY. THAT DRIVES DOLLARS AWAY
FROM THE CLASSROOM. I SAY THIS
IS A PARENT A TEACHER CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
I JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THIS IS
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING- AND I CAN
EXPLAIN WHY LET'S FIRST GO TO
THE DOLLARS THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. HAS
A FIVE POINT 33% COHEN. YET
ONGOING EXPENDITURES TO
DISTRICTS. ARE ABOUT THIRTEEN
POINT 85% WHEN YOU TAKE IN THE
CPI OF SEVEN POINT FIVE K.
INCREASES TO STIRS AND PURSE
RATES OF THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WILL BE BURDENED WITH NEXT YEAR
AT ABOUT 4% OF OTHER COSTS WHICH
ARE A MIX AND DON'T APPLY TO ALL
DISTRICTS EVENLY DECLINING
ENROLLMENT CODE RELATED
INTERRUPT IN ATTENDANCE. THE
SPECIAL ITEM- HUMAN RESOURCES
ISSUES- EXTENDED SICK LEAVE PAY
EXCEPT RENDON OTHER COSTS AS
WELL SO AGAIN FIVE POINT THREE
THREE IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET YEAH THE
ACTUALLY PROBABLY CLOSER TO
THIRTEEN POINT 8% AND WHAT WE
WANT TO GO OUT AND DO. WHAT I'M
HEARING TODAY SOME TO DO IS GO
OUT CREATE VERY EXPENSIVE NEW
PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
BE. YOU KNOW. THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF ON
GOING MONEY. ON AND THEN WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THE QUALITY VARIES
QUITE FRANKLY THESE ARE OFTEN
COLLEGE KIDS. GREAT KIDS GETTING
EXPERIENCE- WITH OTHER KIDS AND
THE YOUNGER KIDS THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT AGAIN WE I THINK THE
QUALITIES- WE DON'T KNOW THE
QUALITY QUITE FRANKLY THE
QUALITY CONTROL ISSUES ARE
THERE- I DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW
SOMETHING LIKE THIS COULD JUST
END UP BEING BABYSITTING AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS RIGHT CAN BE
THAT THEY AREN'T ALWAYS THAT BUT
THEY CAN BE THAT. AND AGAIN WHEN
WE DRIVE MONEY AWAY FROM
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM I
THINK THAT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
THING I DON'T THINK THIS IS
TOTALLY. BEEN THOUGHT THROUGH.
SO QUESTION FOR FINANCE- WHY-
FIRST QUESTION IS THIS A- IS
THIS A LOT PROGRAM IS THIS
PERMISSIVE OR. IS IT A MANDATE
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS. LENA GRANT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S NO OPT OUT
OPTION FOR THIS PROGRAM. BUT
THERE IS THERE'S NOT I'M SORRY.
THERE IS NOT THERE WILL BE AN OP
OPT OUT OPTION FOR THESE
PROGRAMS BUT I WANT TO JUST
CLARIFY THAT THERE ARE. THERE
ARE. OFFERING REQUIREMENTS AND
THERE'S PROVIDING ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS IN EITHER OF THOSE.
KICK IN UNTIL. AT LEAST TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WE PUSH IT OUT
A YEARS TO PROVIDE SOME
IMPLEMENTATION TIME FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. SO THERE
WILL BE THE REQUIREMENT IF
YOU'RE A FUNDED AT THE HIGHER
RATE TO. PROVIDE ACCESS TO
PROVIDE OFFER AND PROVIDE ACCESS
TO ALL ON A DUPLICATED PEOPLE'S
. AND FOR HER THE FLOOR FUNDING
RATE. IT WILL BE TO OFFER TO ALL
AND PROVIDE ACCESS 250% LOOKING
AT PEOPLE'S. GREAT THANK YOU
WILL THIS AGAIN SHOWS THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE CLASSROOM
. AND SACRAMENTO RIGHT HERE
LISTEN I'VE BEEN A SCHOOLS I
HAVE A DAUGHTER. THAT'S IN HIGH
SCHOOL I SUB IN THE FALL I SAW
WHAT WAS GOING ON OUR SCHOOLS
THEY CAN GET PEOPLE IN THE DOOR.
STUDENTS OR STAFF. AND YET WE'RE
GOING TO TELL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HERE. HERE'S ANOTHER MANDATE FOR
YOU GLAD CREATE THIS HOPE THIS
HUGE PROGRAM. AND DISTRICTS
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THE
CAPACITY. TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW.
YEAH I SPEAK FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND I SPEAK FROM WHAT
I'M HEARING ON THE GROUND FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. PLEASE DON'T
GIVE US NEW PROGRAMS NEXT YEAR
WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE. CONDUCTING
OUR CORE MISSION NOW. AND SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO- IS IT. THAT WAY.
THIS DOES NOT RE BENCH NINETY
EIGHT. EITHER DOES IT THIS THIS
NEW PROGRAM WE'RE NOT
REINVENTING NINETY EIGHT TO ADD
IN THIS PROGRAM CORRECT. FOR
FINANCE. NO I'M SORRY MY
COLLEAGUE ERIN HER IDEA I THINK
WE'LL ANSWER. OKAY THE ANSWER
WAS NO CORRECT. YES ERIN YOUR
CURRENT CREDIT LIMIT AB RIGHT
AFTER YEAH NOW WE'RE NOT OKAY
THANK YOU DOCTOR AND I THOUGHT
IF I FIND THAT UNFORTUNATE- AND
AGAIN I THINK THERE'S A QUESTION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THIS USE OF
THE MONEY IS EVEN LEGAL. IF IT
IS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE AGAIN IT IS
BEING SPENT OUT OF THE DAY OUT
OF THE SCHOOL DAY AND OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM LISTEN I GET WHY
NONPROFIT TO LOVE THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS PROBABLY A LOT OF MONEY
FOR THEM. RIGHT A LOT OF THESE-
PROGRAMS WE CONDUCTED I'D MAYBE
EVEN ALL WITH TIME- AND IT WITH
WITH PERSONAL OTHER THAN SCHOOL
SITE PERSONAL- BUT AGAIN I GOT A
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S EVEN AN APPROPRIATE AND
EVEN LEGAL USE OF THE MONEY-
WITH THAT. I WILL TURN IT BACK
TO YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY THANK
YOU I. JUST WANT YOU. ALL LEGIT
. I'M A MISTER DI WILL KNOW THAT
THIS IS LAST A PART AS
IMPLEMENTING YEAR'S LAST YEAR I
DON'T SEE IT THAT WAY SIR THE
FIRM HAS. I MEAN I'M LOOKING AT
WHAT THE SITUATION WE'RE FACING
TODAY IN THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SYSTEM NOT NOT. THE SITUATIONS
WE'VE FACED IN THE PAST. YEAH
WE'RE JUST TO REPEAT THAT THIS
LAST YEAR'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT BOTH BUT IT'S THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THAT IS THE MONEY
IS BUT WE SET WE PUT IN STATUTE
AGAIN AT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. AND
ARE WE ARE NOT BOUND BY ANY
PASSED ACTION EVERY YEAR IS A
ONE YEAR CONTRACT OR BUDGET YEAH
THAT'S TRUE. OKAY. FURTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY SEEING NINE WE
WILL CIRCLE MISTER TANK. THANKS
MATURE APPRECIATED PROPITIATE MA
ARE EDUCATION CHAIRS. COMMENTS
AND THOUGHTS I HAVE I HAVE A
LITTLE BIT- DIFFERENT- FOUR OF-
VANTAGE POINT GUARDS TWENTY
DIFFERENT MINDSET- I REALLY LOOK
AT NOW SCHOOLS WERE DESIGNED AT
A TIME- IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE YOU KNOW WE TAKE SUMMERS
OFF SCHOOLS WERE DESIGNED WE GO
TO SCHOOL BETWEEN NINETY TWO-
FAMILIES WERE DIFFERENT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
WORK SCHEDULES NOW- MOST
FAMILIES. WHO HAVE CHILDREN YOU
HAVE TO WORKING PARENTS THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO COME PICK UP
THEIR KIDS AT TWO O'CLOCK- THEY
HAVE DIFFICULTY WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WITH OUR
KIDS ALL SUMMER BECAUSE WE
EVERYONE'S WORKING SO THE VISION
I THINK THAT MR FONG CLEAN AND
YOU KNOW I HAD THE DISTINCT
HONOR OF- KNOWING HIM WHEN HE
RAN ARE GREAT- BEACON PROGRAM IN
MY DISTRICT. MANY MANY YEARS AGO
BUT- YOU KNOW REALLY THE VISION
THAT HE LAID OUT WHICH IS YOU
HAVE A SCHOOL DAY THAT IS REALLY
FROM NINE O'CLOCK UNTIL FIVE
O'CLOCK AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY WHAT FAMILIES NEED AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT FAMILIES WANT
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WORKING
FAMILIES ARE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES OR FAMILIES WHO HAVE
TO. WORKING PARENTS THAT REALLY
IS THE LONG TERM VISION I THINK
OF WHERE WE HAVE TO GO SO IT'S
REALLY NOT ABOUT- THIS NOT ABOUT
- THE MONEY ONLY IN THE CLASS
WAS RELEASED THE MONEY AT THE
SCHOOL. AND WHETHER IT IS- AFTER
THE BELL RINGS OR BEFORE THE
BELL RINGS IT'S REALLY ALL
ABOUT. MAKING SURE THAT FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN ARE REALLY GETTING
THAT SUPPORT SO JUST A COUPLE
COUPLE QUESTIONS- STARTING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OBVIOUSLY
I THINK OUR OUR SUB CHAIR. ON
REITERATED THIS POINT- THAT THIS
IS JUST REITERATE THIS IS JUST
A- IMPLEMENTATION OF LAST
YEAR'S- BUDGET AGREEMENT. BUT IT
IS A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT OF-
FINANCES VANTAGE POINT WITH THE
INCREASED TO FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION OBVIOUSLY WITH THE GOAL
OF. FIVE BILLION- WHAT'S THE
EXPECTATION THAT THAT THE YOUR
EXPECTING. IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT YOU'D LIKE
TO SEE THIS YEAR. LENA GRANT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE BASING IT
BUT YOU'RE ASKING IF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IF THAT WAS
GONNA BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED BY
THE END OF THIS BUDGET YEAR. I
THINK OUR VISION AS- PER STATUTE
IT'S TO RAMP UP TO THE FIVE
BILLION ONGOING- RIGHT NOW WE'RE
AT FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION I'M
GOING- WE HAVE INCREASED THE PER
ADA RATE TO REFLECT THIS
INCREASE AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE PROVIDING SOME BUFFER TIME
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO BE ABLE TO RAMP UP THEIR
OFFERINGS- SO WE SEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION HAPPENING OVER A
FEW YEARS- AND- THE AUDIT. YOU
KNOW BEING PUSHED OUT- TO KIND
OF REFLECT THAT. WHAT ARE THE
MASKING MORE FROM A LADY- LEE
PERSONS- WE ARE WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO SEE. ON SITE AT THE
SCHOOL LEVEL. WE'RE PUTTING ALL
THIS MONEY INTO THE STATE INTO
THIS- PROGRAM WHAT ARE WE WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO SEE WHAT OUR
FAMILIES ARE SAFE. I DON'T ARE
YOU AT AND I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION EXACTLY
WHERE WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING TO
GO. HOW TO BE SPENT. ABOUT THE-
YES SIR SO I THINK. WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING IS HOW HOUSE HOW SCHOOLS
WILL USE THE FUNDING TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS AND HOW
PARENTS ARE GONNA SEE THIS
PROGRAM. CORRECT WHAT'S WHAT'S
DEPARTMENT FRANCES EXPECTATION
FROM THAT IS. WELL OUR INTENT IS
THAT IS THAT SCHOOLS- THAT
RECEIVE THE FUNDS ARE ABLE TO
RAMP UP OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS-
TO IMPLEMENT THEIR OFFERINGS FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING- AND BUT THERE
IS NO THERE WILL BE KIND OF- YOU
KNOW THE REQUIREMENT WILL STAND
BUT THERE WILL BE AN AUDIT TO
CHECK THAT THIS IS HAPPENING BUT
THE FUNDING WILL BE AVAILABLE.
ANY ANY UNSPENT FUNDS FROM
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THEY WILL
HAVE UNTIL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO USE THOSE AND SIMILAR
422-232-2320 FOUR- BUT I I'M NOT
SURE OF ANSWERING QUESTION I
DON'T THINK IT IS THE QUESTION.
SO LET ME JUST REPEAT IT AGAIN-
EUROPE WHAT I THINK OF RAMP UP I
GUESS WE'RE- FOR TALKING A SLICK
I THINK THE SKATEBOARD PARK BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO SO WHEN YOU SAY
RAMP UP WHAT DO YOU. YOUR YOUR
THE ANALYSTS WHERE WOULD YOU CAN
LOOK FOR. DID AND IT. WILL TO
GIVE GRANT WILL HELP HER. EIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF YEAH SO I THINK
THE QUESTION AND- CERTAINLY
WARRANT- OF COURSE RIGHT A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THROUGHOUT
THIS AND I THINK- A CALL TO YOU
NEED SPOKE TO THAT QUITE A PER.
WHERE AND HAVE YOU HEARD ARE OUR
PANEL AT- I BELIEVE FROM FOR
MODERATE AREA EARLIER WELL AS
YOU TO- THERE'S DIFFERENT RIGHT
CALIFORNIA'S VERY DIVERSE WELL
THAT AND SO- DIFFERENT LEDS ARE
GOING TO HAVE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES- SOME OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BE ALREADY
PARTICIPATING IN THE ASUS
PROGRAMS YOU CAN PUNK THERE
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE A EASIER TIME
PERHAPS BREEDING FONG FROM
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS GRADING ONE
COHESIVE. AS WE MISS MCCARTY
SAID AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM RIGHT
THAT PARENTS WOULD KNOW THAT-
EVEN THOUGH THE FUNDING FROM A
STATE PERSPECTIVE COMING FROM
DIFFERENT PARTS MAYBE EVEN
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL. SO THAT'S
REALITY AND SO IT'S HARD FOR US
TO FIND IN THE EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING TO LOOK INTO YOU KNOW YOUR
DISTRICT NUMBER CISCO UNIFIED
VERSUS SOMEWHERE IN MONTEREY OR
WHATEVER- SO THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT PRESS REALLY GIVE US
THE GAS I THINK OUR VISION OUR
HOLD RIGHT IS THAT- WITH A LOT
WORK THAT MEANT MR FONG AND HIS
- STAFF TO MAKE MEMBERS BUT ARE
DOING AND SEE. OPERA MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE LIAISON- RIGHT BASIS
THAT BY THE END OF THIS CURRENT
YEAR AND CERTAIN IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WITH THE ADDITION
THE IN OF- THE L. YOU COULD GET
TO A- WHERE THEY DO HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UP AND
RUNNING- BUT OF COURSE THAT'S
PREDICATED ON A LOT OF THESE
WRITERS THAT THERE'S THE-
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE
HOPING COMES TO AN END SOON BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW-
CERTAINLY WE'VE HAD UP ON FOR
THINGS. UNFORESEEN HAPPEN WITH
AND TO MAKE I OUR PERSPECTIVE OF
THE POINT IS ASSUMING THAT THOSE
THINGS PROGRESS IN A IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION. NONE BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE MOST
OF THE AS- BETTER CAN HELP THEY
NEED GUIDANCE FROM DVD WHAT HAVE
YOU THAT THEY'D BE ABLE TO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IF NOT 1100%
UP TO SPEED AT LEAST MAKING. IN
THAT DIRECTION SO THAT WHEN WE
GET THE- THREE. FOUR AS MY
COLLEAGUE MS GRAHAM. TO WITH
REGARD TO THE ALL. KICKING IN
THAT WE- HAVE- ELLIE A UP AND
DOWN ECOR. BE WORRY ABOUT YOU
KNOW. PENALTIES NOT A PROBLEM WE
WANT WE DON'T WANT. SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE DISCONTENT- THAT IT
PRECLUDES THEM FROM. ALL IN GOOD
PROGRAMS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO
WHAT WE BETTER I ANSWERED YOUR.
WHAT ARE YOU AGREE WITH YOU THE
OFFICE PENALTY WHAT WHAT I WANT
AS A- PARENT AS I WANT. TO KNOW
MORE MORE SERVICE MORE BRIDGEMAN
MORE EDUCATION- I'M TRYING UNDER
. FROM YOU KNOW YOUR- JOB IS
ENSURE. THAT THE MONEY'S SPENT
PROPERLY. SO HOW YOU. JUDGE OF
THAT WHAT YOU JUST SAID IS. WE
HAVE. YEAR OLD DISTRICTS ALL
OVER THE STATE ARE GONNA SPEND
IT DIFFERENTLY- AND SO WE'LL
SEE. BUT YOUR YOUR JOB IS TO
DETERMINE THAT BUT MONEY IS
ACTUALLY BEING SPENT PROPERLY.
SO YOU DIDN'T GET ME- I WOULD
ACTUALLY SAY THAT THAT. IF YOU
COULD LET ME. BEFORE YOU
INTERRUPT ME AND APPRECIATED. SO
I GOT THIS QUESTION TWICE YOU
HAVEN'T GIVEN ME ANY KIND OF
BENCHMARK YOU GONNA SAY HEY.
IT'S JUST GOOD PANDA WHEN THE
AUDITS DONE IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WE'RE GONNA SEE HOW IT IS.
SO HOW ARE YOU GONNA BE DOING
YOUR JOB IT OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS TO ENSURE THAT THIS MONEY.
IS REACHING. THE KIDS AND THE
FAMILIES WE ARE WE'RE ALL
INTENDING TO HELP WHICH IS ALL
WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL WANT. AND I
DIDN'T GET GOT INTO ANY CLEAR
INDICATION THAT YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA OF HOW THAT WAS GOING TO BE
HOW YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. BUT THE JOINT EFFORT.
RIGHT SO THE WORK THAT MR FONG.
AND HIS FOLKS LIKE IF THAT DOING
IT EITHER DOING THEIR BEST TO
GET A- FOLKS IN THE FIELD BEST
ADVICE THAT THEY CAN PERCENT OF
STATUTE. RIGHT ALLOWABLE THERE
IF. I PRESUME FROM CONVERSATION
. I'VE HAD WITH MISTER HAWKINS.
THAT ITALIAN COME FOR THEM. AND
IS TALKING ABOUT USING THE FUNDS
IN A WAY THAT YOU KNOW WOULDN'T
BE ALLOWABLE WOULDN'T BE UP TO.
THE EXPECTATION OF THE PROGRAM
HERE SO WE'RE GOING TO LET THEM
KNOW. RIGHT THAT THAT'S- NOT
SOMETHING THEY SHOULD PROBABLY
BE DOING. OR THEY WILL SUFFER
SOME KIND OF AUDIT. AND IF
YOU'RE OTHERWISE- THE WAY THAT
THIS PROGRAM THOUGH AND SEVERAL
PROGRAMS IN IN THAT CODE WORK-
OFTEN IS THAT THE ACCOUNTABILITY
IS AT THE YOU KNOW MORE OR LESS-
AT THE BACK INTO THE AUDIT
PROCESS RIGHT- IN FACT YOU THERE
ISN'T NECESSARILY A WAY FOR
FINANCE. TO GO IN AND- MONITOR
EVERY ELEAZAR. SPENDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN A REAL TIME BASIS
THAT'S JUST NOT HOW IT WORKS-
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL-
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS THAT NEED
CERTAINLY NOT THE CONVERSATION I
COULD BE HAPPY. IN THE SHORT
TERM. BUT FOR US WE HEARD A LOT
OF WE WANT TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
WHAT ELEAZAR TELLING US OVER
THIS WHOLE LAST YEAR. THAT THEY
WERE HAVING A REALLY REALLY HARD
I AM WORRIED ABOUT GETTING OVER
PENALIZED- WHEN EVEN WHEN THEY-WERE MAKING A GOOD FAITH EFFORT-
TO OFFER THE PROGRAM. SO AND
FINANCES GOAL IS A TYPICALLY TO
JUST BE YOU KNOW. CHECKING IN ON
WHAT DISTRICTS ARE DOING ON THE
MONEY ON A WEEKLY OR MONTHLY
BASIS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT
REALLY IS KIND OF MORE. HERE'S
THE REQUIREMENT. AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A CONVERSATION AT A
TIME CERTAIN CERTAIN STATUTE
ABOUT HOW ABOUT. HOW THAT'S
GOING. OKAY BROWN- MY DO THAT. I
LEAST IN MY MIND I DON'T I DON'T
WORK FOR THE L. A. ASE. I DON'T
THINK YOU DO EITHER. OF WORK FOR
THE FAMILY AND THE- OF THE
STATE. THAT'S WE'RE SETTING UP
FOR. AND WHAT WE SAW. DURING THE
LAST TWO YEARS IS THAT THERE
SEEM TO BE A DISCONNECT. BETWEEN
L. A. A.'S. IN THOSE FAMILIES
AND THOSE KIDS. AND THEN A TIME
WHEN WE HAD A PANDEMIC AT A TIME
WHEN MOST LEDS REFUSED TO OPEN
THEIR SCHOOLS. WHEN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DOCTORS ALL SAID IT WAS
SAFE TO DO SO- ELEAZAR.
CONFIGURED TO DO. SO I WOULD.
YOU KNOW JUST REMIND THE
DEPARTMENT THAT. YOU DON'T WORK
FOR THE A. S. AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS IT I DON'T
AND I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND I
TOTALLY RESPECT HIS JUDGMENT
COMPLETED MISTER FOCUS SOUNDS
LIKE YOUR DEFERRING. TO FUNG'S
JUDGE AS TO WHETHER THE MONEY'S
BEING SPENT APPROPRIATE OR NOT.
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD. ARE YOU
SAYING THAT IT'S A JOINT EFFORT
MR FONG HAS A ROLE FINANCE OF
THE ROLE IN THE AUDIT GUIDE
PROCESS AS I MENTIONED HOW THE
ROLE IN TERMS OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OFF PROGRAM. ONE
CRITICAL TO ME WHAT MR FUNK'S
ROLLINS WITH A LOT OF ROLE AS I
SEE DON'T. THE DEPARTMENT'S ROLE
. WELL I WOULD SAY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CERTAINLY THE- THE-
COMPLIANCE AGENCY- BRITAIN'S OF
THE STATUE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
RIGHT CERTAINLY HAVE A HAND IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM RIGHT IT'S OUR PROPOSAL
TO ADD THE NEW DOLLARS BUT
TYPICALLY FOR A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS. IT REALLY DOES FALL MORE
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE CD
ALCOHOLIC I PROCESS THAT'S JUST
KIND OF HOW A LOT OF EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. WORK IN LESS IF
FINANCES IT WOULD BE WRITTEN
INTO OUR THE MONITORING PROCESS
. BUT BEFORE THIS ISN'T OF MY
WHICH IS UP CRITIC TO ENSURE
THAT THE- AND THE I LOOK AT
FINANCES JOB TO DETERMINE. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY GET INTO THEIR- TO THE
KIDS AND I THINK IF. I REALLY
HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT DOESN'T
JUST TAKE. THE WORDS OF THE L.
D. A.'S. THAT THINGS ARE WORKING
OR NOT WORKING. THAT THEY- THEY
REALLY HAVE A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING WHETHER IT'S
ACTUALLY GETTING TO ATTEND A
PURPOSE. SO- I'D LIKE TO. GO TO
GO TO MISS WORLD FOR THE
MONTEREY COUNTY. IF SHE IS STILL
THERE I AM STILL HERE IT'S
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO LONG. ANY
OFFICER BENT THANK YOU- IF YOU
COULD YOUR WITH WITH THIS NEW
APPROPRIATION- I'D LOVE TO HEAR
SORT OF HOW YOU'RE COUNTIES
PLANNING ON SPENDING AND WHERE
OR WHERE IT'S GONNA GO. I KNOW
THE ROUTE THE EVERY EVERY LEN IS
FACING ENORMOUS CHALLENGES BUT
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND FROM
YOUR SPECIFIC AT THIS POINT
WHERE. YOU INTEND TO. SPEND THE
MONEY. THANK YOU AND- I JUST
HAVE TO SAY OFF THE BAT THAT MY
ROLE IS NOT AS A DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDER- I USED TO PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICE TO STUDENTS- I AM
NOW AND- THE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT THAT CRITICAL SUPPORT TO
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
ANDOTHER PARTNERS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM SO. I DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY OVER AND THE ACTUAL
SPENDING OF THE FUNDS BUT WHAT I
DO PER MONTH AS PART OF THAT
SYSTEM. IS GUIDONS- COACHING I
RESOURCE BROKERING I'M I'M SORT-OF THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT WHO
CHECKS TO MAKE SURE THAT- A
THERE IS A PROGRAM RUNNING AND
THAT IT IS A QUALITY PROGRAM-
PART OF MY DUTY AS- IN MY
CAPACITY IS TO GO OUT. TO DO
SITE VISITS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ARE BEING
SERVED BY THESE PROGRAMS AND-
AND IF NEEDED PROVIDE SOME.
IMPORTANT SUPPORT AND TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR QUALITY AND BASED ON
THE CALIFORNIA QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR EXPANDED LEARNING-
DETERMINES THE NEEDS AND ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS ACCORDINGLY. SO
THAT'S MY ROLE I AM I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTION- BUT I CAN
I CAN DEFINITELY TELL YOU THAT
THERE IS VARIANCE- AND WHAT I'M
HEARING TO OUT THERE YOU
PROBABLY HAVE ALL HEARD THE TERM
PLANS THAT MAKE I THINK A LOT OF
OUR DISTRICTS ARE FEELING. THAT
THEY HAVE A PLAN FOR EVERYTHING-
AND I WILL TELL YOU FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT THAT IS
FRUSTRATING- BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
IT JUST ENCOURAGES. THE SIDELOAD
NATION. OF AT. AND YET I DON'T
THINK THAT IT'S THE INTENT AT
ALL I THINK. WE HAVE AN ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO PARADE FUNDING
AS- MICHAEL FUNK MENTIONED
EARLIER. DO YOU REALLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES- LOOK AT IT AS ONE
UNIVERSAL PROGRAM. AND NOT AS-
SEPARATES AND SILO TO PROGRAMS
AND I WANT TO SPEAK- TO THAT
POINT THAT I HEAR A LOT THAT. IT
AFTER SCHOOL IS A COMPONENT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF A
CHILD'S EDUCATION. WE'RE NOT
MEANT TO BE THAT CHILD'S FIRST
TEACHER BUT WE ARE THERE TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPLEMENT AND TO
PROVIDE THAT ENRICHMENT THAT
REALLY ENHANCES THE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. SO HOW DO WE BREED
ALL OF THESE VARIOUS FUNDING
SOURCES TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING- I'M THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF STUDENTS POSSIBLE YOU
KNOW GETTING TO THE CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMENT ABOUT A
UNIVERSAL SERVICE I HAVE THREE
KIDS MYSELF. I KNOW THAT I HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
UNIVERSAL LANGUAGE PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE AND THAT IS TO HELP MY
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILY TREMENDOUSLY
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE- OF A SERVICE
THAT IS SUPPORTING- MIDDLE
CLASS. WE HAVE A GROWING BODY AS
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHO NEED.
THE SERVICE SAYS AND THIS
BREEDING TOGETHER OF FUNDING IS
GOING TO ALLOW US TO SERVE EVEN
MORESTUDENTS AND I THINK THAT
IS OF CRITICAL CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE. AND I GUESS BIG
BASED ON YOUR VANTAGE POINT
WHERE WOULD YOU YOU MENTIONED
THE AS DIFFERENT CAPACITY ISSUES
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
HAVE DIFFERENT ISSUES WHERE DO
YOU. WHAT WHAT'S YOUR BEST GUESS
OF WHERE. THE MONEY'S GOING TO
BE SPENT- I THINK FOR THOSE WHOHAVE CURRENT ASUS IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FUNDED PROGRAMS
THEY ARE GOING TO LOOK AT THEIR
ELO P. DOLLARS AND- BE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
FULL TIME OPPORTUNITY TO THEIR
STAFF. THEY INCLUDES BY THE WAY
TO THOSE WHO- I THEIR ENTITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED- WE
DON'T NEED TO- AS YOU NO IT'S
WHETHER IT'S THE STARBUCKS OR
AMAZON ALL SHARE STORY DIRECTED
JUST HAPPENED A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO- IN MY WORLD AND WE OPERATE
EAST TEAM HAVE BEEN ISSUED IT
FOR WE PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AROUND STEAM THIS
YEAR'S FOCUSES ON IN QUERY- HAD
A PEER MENTOR WHO IS A- VERY
SEASONED STAFF PERSON- AND QUITE
UNNATURAL AND BEING A LEADER.
AND SOMEBODY THAT I WANTED TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF- TO SEE
HIM GROW WITHIN THE FIELD. AND
HE SAID TO ME TOMORROW I AM
SORRY I CANNOT. DO THIS BECAUSE
I. HI TO FIND A MORE LIQUOR
POSITION AT THIS POINT IN TIME I
HOPE TO COME BACK TO EXPAND
ATTORNEY BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE
MY HEART IS. I LOVE THIS WORK
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT IT BUT
I NEED I NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN MYSELF AT
THIS POINT IN TIME. SO I DO SEE
THAT THOSE WHO HAVE EXISTING
ASUS TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
FUNDING. WILL USE SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS TO SUPPLEMENT TO
PROVIDE- I THINK A PACKAGE FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD- WHETHER
IT'S ADDITIONAL STIPENDS WHETHER
IT'S A FULL TIME OPPORTUNITY. TO
REALLY RETAIN THOSE STAFF AND
RETAIN THEM YEAR ROUND- BECAUSE
REMEMBER THOSE WHO WILL BE FOR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY FUNDING.
WAS THE ONLY SOURCE OF WE HAD
FOR SUMMER PROGRAMMING. AND NOT
ALL DISTRICTS EVERYWHERE HAD
SUMMER PROGRAMMING AND STILL BE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY.
FINING HIM ABOUT. AND WHAT THAT
MEANT AT LEAST IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IS WE WERE HAVING TO
HAVE- SOME OF OUR AGENCIES WHO
WERE RUNNING SUMMER PROGRAM.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY AT TAKING
FUNDING FROM ANOTHER ENTITY YOU
BY THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB FOR
EXAMPLE THEY MAY HAVE SOME
REALLY PHENOMENAL STAFF PEOPLE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO LOSE AND
THERE WAS THIS- SORT OF
RECIPROCAL WORK. OUR
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTED THEN
WITH THE YMCA BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED A LOT OF STUFF AND THAT
WAS A WAY WE WERE ABLE CREATIVE
WAY WE ARE ABLE TO RETAIN. GOOD
STAFF YEAR ROUND AND YELLOW HE
OFFERS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
YEAR ROUND- YOUR MAPS YOUR ROUND
JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR SOME OF
OUR OUR MOST HIGHLY QUALIFIED
STAFF WE WANT TO KEEP THEM IN
THE FIELD AND I KNOW MICHAEL HAD
MENTIONED- PATHWAYS WHICH IS
ANOTHER TOPIC I'M EXTREMELY
PASSIONATE ABOUT- AND CONTINUING
TO TRY TO DO SOME WORK. IN THAT
AREA AS WELL AS- THERE'S A SHORT
TERM SOLUTION AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE LONG TERM SOLUTION.
YEAH COULDN'T I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE OBVIOUS OBVIOUSLY THAT- OF
THIS THE WAGES THAT WERE PAYING-
MOST OF THESE EMPLOYEES THEY'RE
NOT SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM- LIES
YOU MENTIONED THIS DIFFICULTY
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO SEE-
A CAREER TRAJECTORY IN THESE IN
THESE FIELDS RATHER THAN. JUST
AS A JOB TO YOU KNOW GO JUMP
INTO ANOTHER FIELD- IT'S I THINK
THAT DEFINITELY IS THE RIGHT
STRATEGY AND OBVIOUSLY I FULLY
SUPPORT- LOOKING AT WAYS TO
INCREASE COMPETITION I THINK
THAT'S QUITE. OFTEN THE CHAIR
HAVE FOUGHT FOR YEARS TO
INCREASE RATES- BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT FOR SO LONG PEOPLE WERE
JUST UNDERPAID AND IT'S JUST NOT
SUSTAINABLE TO KIND OF TURN YOU
HAVE THE TURN OVER YOU HAVE-
WITH A FEW PEOPLE. OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE LIKE BABYSITTERS AFTER
TOGETHER YOU CAN BET YOU GET
BABYSITTERS BUT IF YOU IF YOU
WANT TO ACCESS YOU ACTUALLY WANT
TO- HAVE. EDUCATORS YOUNG PEOPLE
EDUCATE TO CAN'T PAY PEOPLE LIKE
. MINIMUM WAGE SALARIES AND
EXPECT THEM TO BE EDUCATORS
THAT'S NOT. A FAIR- IS NOT A
FAIR PROPOSAL IT IS NOT FAIR
EXPECTATIONS SO TOTALLY. I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THERE IS
SO SOUNDS LIKE ONE ONE POTENTIAL
THAT YOU SEE IS- PERHAPS- YOU
KNOW OLD WHILE SERVICE PROVIDE
YOU A SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
ALREADY GETTING- ASUS IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY- MANUFACT- FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. TAKE SOME OF THE NEW
FUNDING TO INVEST IN OUR CURRENT
EMPLOYEES. WHETHER IT'S AN
INCREASE COMPENSATION OR REALLY
TRYING TO DO TRAINING AND REALLY
TRYING TO- INSURER ENHANCE-
THEIR COMPETENCY AND THEIR SKILL
AND REALLY HELP BUILDING-
BUILDING THEM UP. I'M ONE ISSUE
WE HEAR LOT ABOUT IS A REALLY
AROUND LEARNING LOSS AS WELL AS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- OBVIOUSLY.
YOU HAVE NEITHER. SOCIAL WORKERS
OR- PSYCHOLOGIST ON STAFF YOUR
GIVE YOU CAN GIVE US A SENSE OF
IN YOUR COUNTY HOW. THOSE
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE. HELPING
TACKLE THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE- IN
IN THEIR PROGRAMS FOR THOSE
ISSUES. YEAH AND THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION I THINK THAT-
WHAT WE FOUND WITH OUR PROGRAMS
WERE REPORTING WITH THE
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY
RECEIVED- EARLY LAST YEAR. ME
THEY FELT VERY FORTUNATE THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO USE THOSE
FUNDING THAT THE EXISTING ASUS
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY FUNDING
DURING THE DAY TO ALLOW THEIR
AFTER SCHOOL STAFF TO ACTUALLY
WORK DURING THE DAY TO SUPPORT
OUR YOUTH AND FAMILIES WE SOUGHT
THE FUNDING BEING USED THAT WAY.
AND HAVING QUITE DRAMATIC-
POSITIVE RESULTS MATTER OF FACT-
KIDS YOU WERE NOT NECESSARILY
SHOWING UP FOR THEIR DISTANCE
LEARNING CLASSES- BLUES AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM STAFF WOULD PLAY
THAT ROLE OF CALLING HOME AND
FINDING OUT WHERE THAT CHILD
WAS- I WOULD SAY- FROM MY
EXPERIENCE ALSO WORKING IN THE
FIELD. WE ARE VERY LUCKY AS
AFTER SCHOOL WORKERS TO HAVE
DEVELOPED VERY DEEP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND I THINK THAT'S
PARTLY HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT.
THAT OUR PARENTS COME TO PICK UP
THEIR CHILDREN THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONVERSE THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AFTER SCHOOL IN A
WAY THAT- YOU KNOW NOT OFTEN AS
POSSIBLE IN THE CLASSROOM- AND
SO DOES AFTER SCHOOL WORKERS
PLAYED SUCH A VITAL ROLE IN
MAKING SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
WERE RE ENGAGING IN SCHOOL
DURING THAT. REALLY AT A TIME OF
GREAT DROP OFF. AND I THINK ALSO
HELPING TO BUILD THE SKILLS- YOU
KNOW I SORT OF WALKED AWAY FROM
THE TERM LEARNING RECOVERY
BECAUSE I THINK WE LEARNED SO.
SO MANY NEW SKILLS AND EVEN MY
OWN DAUGHTER ANNE AND SONS.
LEARNING HOW TO. IT INTERFACE A
THE IT DID. SPACE WAS A NEW
SKILL THAT THEY ALL LEARNED AND
SO WAIT HERE I AM MAYBE WORKING
AT HOME AND HAVE MY TEN YEAR OLD
SAY YOU KNOW I'M NOT.
INTERCONNECT MY CONNECTIVITY IS
DOWN AND THEN HAVING- HER FIGURE
IT OUT ON HER OWN- WE SAW A LOT
OF THESE SKILLS AND A LOT OF-
AND A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR STUDENTS TO. DALY BECAME
VERY SELF RELIANT DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND SO. I SAY ALL THAT
BECAUSE I THINK. WE REALLY ALSO
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
NOT BE PULLED BACK INTO WHAT WE
ARE DEFINING AS NORMAL- AND IN
PERSON IN FACT I'VE HAD SOME
DISTRICTS ASKED ME. IS IT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO DO ANYTHING
ONLINE. IS WE'VE ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME KIDS WHO EXCELLED- DURING
ONLINE AND- YEAH OF COURSE IT
HAD TO ANSWERING STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS POINT NO-
BUT BECAUSE WE'RE ENCOURAGING IN
PERSON AND WE KNOW COURSE KNOW
THE VALUE OF THAT. BUT THERE ARE
ALSO SOME STUDENTS WHO WHO
QUITE. LITERALLY BENEFIT FROM A
NOT AN OPPORTUNITY- AND AGAIN
YOU KNOW. THE MARLBOROUGH WINES
AND THAT MAY BE A RESOURCE THAT
THEY NEED TO TAP INTO. AT SOME
POINT TO MAKE IT WORK. SO GREAT
YOU ARE. J. YOUR COMMENTS ARE
JUST GONNA JUMP MISTER MISTER
FALK. IT JUST ASKING IF YOU IF
YOU COULD EXPAND ON HIS VISION
AROUND THE EXTENSION OF THE
SCHOOL DAY WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY THERE THOUGH THE WAY THAT
PARENTS TO SEE I DON'T THINK THE
PARENTS SEE SORT OF SCHOOL AFTER
SCHOOL AND THIS SORT OF A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE THING THIS
IS JUST ONE ONE DAY BEFORE THEIR
CHILDREN NOT PERHAPS THE SAME
SITE. SO ON THE CLUSTER FROM
COULD JUST KIND OF EXPAND ON HOWHOW WE COULD REACH THAT- MORE
INTEGRATED COHESIVE- SINGLE
EDUCATION TO. THANK YOU MISTER
TAKE IT ALSO THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBERING THE- LOOK DECADES WE
WORK TOGETHER ON THE WEST SIDE
OF. SAN FRANCISCO SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY SCHOOL FAMILIES
WEARING DIFFERENT HATS- I'M
THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS NOT
ONLY TO YOUR QUESTION BUT TO
SOME OTHER COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE. AFTER EVERY DISTRICT
THAT IS. IN FACT IT IT'S
ACTUALLY A FEW DISTRICTS
COMPARED YOU ARE SAYING I DON'T
WANT T USE THIS MONEY IT'S TOO
MUCH I CAN'T HANDLE THIS IT'S-
THERE ARE DISTRICTS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE SMALL BARGE. WHO ARE
SEEKING THIS INVESTMENT. AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REINVENT
EDUCATION. AND TO TRANSFORM
EDUCATION. LET'S FACE IT
EXTENDING THE SCHOOL DAY. ISN'T
GOING TO WORK FOR SOME STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WHERE THE SCHOOL
DAY AS A WORK FOR THEM. I'M WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I'M
SUPPORTER OF K. TWELVE EDUCATION
I'M SUPPORTER OF K. TWELVE
EDUCATORS MY DAUGHTERS IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL HERE IN SACRAMENTO
- SHE HAS BEAUTIFUL EDUCATORS
THAT WORK WITH HER. BUT THE
MAGIC HAPPENS IN TRANSFORMATION
. WHEN THE SCHOOL IS NOT
DISCONNECTED FROM THE COMMUNITY
. MISTER CHANG YOU SAW THAT WITH
THE SUNSET NEIGHBORHOOD BEAON
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
SCHOOLS FUNCTION BEST. WHEN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE SCHOOL IS
WORKING TOGETHER AND THAT'S NOT
ONLY TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN BENEFIT
FROM THIS BUT ALSO OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. SO WE HAVE. SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE ESTABLISHED.
FOR A QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING IN CALIFORNIA
FOR AFTER SCHOOL. AND THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT IN STASHING. IN
EVERY CASE IS A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY PROGRAM. SELECT WORK
WITH THE QUALITY STANDARDS AND.
DEVELOP CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
AWESOMEST SO THE HEAT THE YOUTH
AND STUDENTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE EXPERIENCING. SOMETHING VERY
TRANSFORMATIVE AND IN RICHMOND-
AND THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT MAR
MENTIONED WHERE OUR COMMUNITY
EDUCATORS HAVE CLOSE PROXIMITY
TO THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES SO
THE QUALITY STANDARDS FOR EXPAND
LEARNING. WE'RE ALSO BUILT INTO
THE PROGRAM PLAN. THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
SO THERE'S A LINE THAT THERE.
AND I WOULD I WOULD SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE. THAT YES QUALITY
VARIES ACROSS AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. RIGHT UP I HAVE TEAMS
OF PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE STATE
AND I HAVE BEEN ALL ACROSS THE
STATE INS IN REMOTE AREAS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
DEEPEST URBAN AREAS. AND I SEE.
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS
CONSISTENTLY WHERE CHILDREN ARE
ENGAGED THERE. EXPANDING THEIR
HORIZONS IT MISTER KING YOU
MENTIONED MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT
- WHAT I WOULD SAYFIRST AND
FOREMOST IS THAT THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT AFTER SCHOOL
STAFF HAVE WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
OUR DEEP AND CARING AND THAT IS
ONE OF THE STRONGEST PROTECTIVE
FACTORS AGAINST MENTAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES.
IS WHEN STUDENTS FEEL ISOLATED
AND OUT OF RELATIONSHIPS WITH
STUDENTS. THAT IS THE MOST THE
STRONGEST PROTECTIVE FACTOR
AGAINST MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES. SO MR TANG
IT'S THAT EXPANDED LEARNING IS
NOT OF THAT ON IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
THE BABYSITTING IT'S NOT JUST A
PLACE TO KEEP KIDS SAFE IT'S
WERE CHILDREN AND YOUTHS AND
ADULTS IN FACT CAN. EXPERIENCE
AND EXPAND WHATEVER'S HAPPENING
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY. AND
PARENTS CAN RELY ON THIS AS NOT
ONLY A PLACE WHERE THEIR CHILD
CAN BE SAFE BUT A PLACE WHERE
THEIR CHILD CAN EXPERIENCE.
THINGS THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
EXPERIENCED OTHERWISE LET'S FACE
IT THERE'S A LOT OF. THERE'S A
LOT OF MIDDLE UPPER CLASS
FAMILIES WHO PROVIDE WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. A LOT OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. ARE NOT ABLE TO DO
THAT. BUT IN OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
PROVIDING THE KIND OF
EXPERIENCES. THAT ENHANCE THE
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL DAY AND ARE.
GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE WHAT'S POSSIBLE THEIR LIVES
THEN THAT'S THE VISION IS. A
PLACE FOR THESE CHILDREN TO HAVE
LEARNING THAT IS ACTIVE LEARNING
THAT IS. SUPPORTED BY CARRIED
ADULTS LEARNING THAT EXPANDS
THEIR HORIZONS LEARNING THAT HAS
MANY LEARNING THAT HELPS THEM
CONNECT TO WHAT'S RELEVANT TO
THEM SO THE ACADEMICS THAT THEY
MIGHT RECEIVE DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY HAVE A PLACE TO BE APPLIED I
CAN I CAN YOU KNOW I COULD GO ON
FOR A LONG TIME. NO IT'S SO IT'S
SO THEN JUST TO STIR UP FOR IN A
SORT OF FINAL FOLLOW UP YOU KNOW
TURNBACK OF THE CHURCH. BUT SO
IT INTO OF THE VANISHED- OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SAYING
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE URBAN YOU'VE
RIDER PER. WITHOUT LIKE SOME OF
THE MONEY COULD BE GOING TO
TRAINING SOME OF THE MONEY COULD
BE GOING TO SALARIES- WHERE ELSE
I MEAN THE MONEY CAN BE. GOING
TO HIRING BRING ON GREAT
CAPACITY WELL DO YOU SEE THE RE
. GOING AS YOUR- YOU KNOW AS AS
A TO KIND OF LOOK TALK ABOUT THE
VISION OF THE SIX THAT OF THE-
SCHOOL DAY DISCO. OF THEM THAT
YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS GET A- BY
CONSTITUENTS THAT'S- IN A WAY.
THEY ALWAYS CAN ASK. HAD MICRO.
ARE US WHAT SCRIPTURE SCRATCH
THEIR HEAD AND SAY HEY WE ALL
THIS YOU KNOW THE THIS IS HUGE.
OF YOU KNOW- TO PAY. SEVEN
BILLION. A CERTAIN A LOT OF
MONEY SO WE'RE IS THAT. WARS ARE
GOING. IS SO IT CAN YOU GIVE US
A- OF SORT OF FROM YOUR- VANTAGE
POINT WHERE. WHERE THE- WHERE
THE CBO'S ARE GOING TO BE SOME
ON THAT. WE'RE WORKING. WITH A
LOT OF US. AND BY THE WAY THERE
ARE WHO ARE. DOING SOME
PARTNERING WITH COMMITTEE
SERVICE BUT THERE ARE TWO. WHO
ARE AS- RESOURCE AS- WAIT
SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICT STAFF IS
GREAT A FULL TIME AND ENGAGE
THEM AND AFTER SCHOOLS WELL
WHICH IS A WIN WIN FOR KIDS
RIGHT- AND SO WE HAVE WE HAVE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE SAYING WE'VE
ALWAYS WANTED TO BRING IN. A SHE
CLUBBER WE'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO
BRING IN- SOMETHING WITH-
THEATER ARTS OR WE'VE ALWAYS
WANTED TO BRING IN. SOMETHING
FOR COMPUTER CODING OR VIDEO
PRODUCTION AND WHEN DONE WELL
THOSE THOSE ACTIVITIES THOSE
INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES ARE.
CONNECTING WITH THE ACADEMICS
THE KIDS ARE LEARNING DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY SO. THAT WHEN THEY
ARE WORKING WITH VIDEO
PRODUCTION THEATER THERE'S
SCRIPT WRITING THERE'S
STORYTELLING IT'S CONNECTED TO
LITERACY IT'S APPLYING THE
ACADEMIC CENTER DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY AND THERE ARE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT
WE CAN NOW. PARTNER WITH THIS
THEATER COMPANY IN TOWN TO COME
IN AND WE GOT THE COR STAFF TO
SUPPORT THE KIDS AND NOW WE'VE
GOT THESE. THE THEATER COMPANY
OR THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANY. OR
THE SCIENCE MUSEUM. TO COME IN
AND BRING OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
CHILDREN THEY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
BEFORE FOR SOME- DISTRICTS
THEY'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO JUST
PAY THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR STAFF
WITH ACES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY THEY HAVEN'T HAD THE
MONEY. TO INVEST IN ADDITIONAL
EQUIPMENT FOR THE CHILDREN TO
USE TO EXPLORE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES SOFT ARE THINKING
ABOUT- INVESTING IN CERTAIN
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT TO ALLOW
THESE DIFFERENT ENRICHMENT TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES. AND OF COURSE NOT
TO MENTION. THE MONEY TO GO
PLACES LIKE LESS TAKE THE KIDS.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT MR TANG IS
. MY PROGRAMS IN SAN FRANCISCO
WORD LITERALLY FIVE SIX BLOCKS
FROM OCEAN BEACH. WHERE WE WOULD
TAKE- THE STUDENTS. TO THE BEACH
FOR SOME KIND OF ENVIRONMENTAL
AWARENESS LESSON OR  BEACH
CLEAN UP. WE WOULD HAVE AT LEAST
HALF THE KIDS FROM THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHO SAID THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THEY'VE GONE TO
THE BEACH. SO TO ASSUME THAT OUR
CHILDREN GET TO GO PLACES AND
EXPERIENCE THINGS THIS IS WHERE
A LOT OF THAT MONEY CAN GO SO.
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST I WOULD
SAY QUALITY STAFF PAINS STAFF
YOU SAID IT IF WE PAY MINIMUM
WAGE WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE
TYPE OF IT A STAFF THAT STICK
AROUND. IT CAN REALLY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES INTO
THE DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT
THESE CHILDREN NEED. FIRST AND
FOREMOST SUPPORTING STAFF IN THE
WORLD GETTING THEM CONNECTED
CONNECTING STAFF IN THE SCHOOL
DATE TO THE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
YOU KNOW THE HIGHEST QUALITY
SOME PROGRAMS. FROM THE SUMMER
MATTERS CAMPAIGN WE'RE NOT
PROGRAMS THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RAN THEY WERE
PROGRAMS WHERE. TEACHERS AND
STAFF FROM THE SCHOOL THEY WORK
ALONGSIDE OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS STAFF. TO REALLY
WORK TOGETHER TO SUPPORT.
CHILDREN HOLISTICALLY THROUGHOUT
THE DAY. REALLY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
A- KEY ISSUE NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA AND EDUCATION BUT FOR
. OUR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS PRESS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH EIGHT. WHAT I THINK ONE
OF THE LAST COMMENT YOU MADE I
THINK IS PROBABLY THE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT IS THE LIVABLE
WAGES FOR OUR WORKERS WERE
EXPECTING THEM TO DO SOMETHING
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT AND THAT IS
TEACHING OUR CHILDREN WORKING
WITH OUR CHILDREN- HELPING WITH
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND IF WE
DON'T. PAY THEM WHAT. AND WE
DON'T PAY EVERYBODY EVERYBODY
WITH THEIR WORTH WHEN I GET IT
BUT IF WE DON'T PROVIDE. LIVABLE
WAGES AND BENEFITS WE WON'T HAVE
THE STABILITY THAT WE NEED FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. SO I WANT TO
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO WHO
FEEL THAT THIS I SOMETHING THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I THINK
MAKING SURE THAT THEY THE
PROGRAMS ARE NOT BABY SITTING
AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR FROM
WE'VE SEEN QUALITY PROGRAMS IN
IN MY DISTRICT AND COLTON. I
LOVE GOING TO THEIR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND THE PRODUCTION SAY
PUT ON. MANY OF THE CHILDREN
CAN'T TRAVEL OUT OF THE COUNTRY
BUT THEY GET TO DO PRODUCTIONS
WHERE THEY'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
COUNTRIES. ARE THEY ALSO GET
HELP WITH HOMEWORK THESE ARE THE
SORTS OF THINGS THAT PROVIDE
THAT EXTENSION- THE MENTAL
HEALTH THAT WAS COMMENTED ON BY
. CHAIR TEAM DICK STREAM PORTENT
- EACH WITH THE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN EXTENSION. WE IT'S AN
EXPERT EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY BUT- IT'S AN
EXTENSION OF THE SCHOOL. THE
SCHOOL DAY SO THAT THE CHILDREN
THEN HAVE MORE PROVIDED TO THEM
DURING THIS PERIOD OF TIME. AND
THAT IT IT'S INVALUABLE EVERY
PROGRAM THAT I HAVE SEEN HAS IT
IN MY OPINION HAS PROVEN TO BE A
VERY- SUCCESSFUL ON THE EVE OF
SUBSTANCE PROVED TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL. THE LAST THING THAT
IS. AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I WOULD. SUGGEST THAT.
EIGHT IS MY NUMBER I'M NOT
SAYING YOUR DEFENSIVE BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT INSTEAD OF
HAVING. THE IT IS IT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SO IF WE DO HAVE
THE QUALITY STANDARDS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED EARLIER ON EXTENDED
LEARNING EXPANDED LEARNING THEN
ONCE WE HAVE THOSE STANDARDS AND
WE KNOW WHAT IT IS WE EXPECT FOR
ME TO THE SCHOOLS BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT SOME
SCHOOLS REQUIRE MORE ASSISTANCE.
THEY MAY NOT BE AS CREATIVE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO PAY THE PEOPLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO THE TO
THE TO THE STUDENTS WE NEED TO
PAY SO THAT WE CAN WE CAN
ATTRACT THE VERY PEOPLE WE WANT
AND THAT OUR CHILDREN DESERVE
AND- IT. GO BACK TO HE SAME
THING THAT THE LIVABLE WAGES.
WITH BENEFITS AND DISPATCHER
MCCARTY YOU TALKED ABOUT-
PROVIDING THOSE HOURS FOR THE
FOR THE FOR THE MOST FOR THOSE.
WORKERS SO THEY CAN USE THOSE
TOWARDS TEACHING OR TOWARDS THE-
WITH SOMETHING RELATED TO
TEACHING A RELATED TO. SOMETHING
FURTHER THAN JUST. AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM I THINK THE- WHAT
WE'RE PROVIDING HERE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IT BECOMES.
CRITICAL NOT JUST SOMETHING THAT
IS FUN IT IS CRITICAL FOR SOME
OF THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
FOR SOME OF THOSE STUDENTS AND I
APPLAUD THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS BEING OFFERED BUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MUST BE SOMETHING
THAT WE LOOK AT. SO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY A FEW WORDS MISTER
CHAIRMAN. OKAY THANK YOU BEFORE-
AND- UGANDA YET YOUR- THIS COULD
TAKE ROLE HAVE REQUIREMENTS.
MCCARTY HERE GALLAGHER. PLEASE
MEDINA WHAT DONALD REYES HERE
THANK GODDESS. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR A SEVEN HERE BUT WE'LL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OFTEN IF THE COURSES
A HOT TOPIC I NEXT LET'S GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO SCHOOL
NUTRITION AND MEAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE DIFFERENT
FINANCE ALEJO AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALLEN CHAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- IT IS THE PRIORITY OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AND FOOD AND NUTRITION
SECURITY. ENCOURAGE HEALTHY
DIETS AND ESTABLISHED A CLIMATE
SMART SCHOOL FOOD SUPPLY. THE
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUILD OFF OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INVESTMENTS- A
COMMITMENT TO IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL MALES. SPECIFICALLY
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO IMPLEMENT BE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR- PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. BUT ACT FOR A TOTAL
ADDITIONAL AND YOU'LL UNIVERSAL
MEALS INVESTMENTS OF SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- SO THIS
AMOUNT IS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE FEDERAL
WAIVERS THAT CURRENTLY REIMBURSE
ALL MEALS AT THE FEDERAL THREE
RATE- WILL AND AT THE END OF
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND
AMOUNTS TO A TOTAL STATE
INVESTMENTS. OF ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE PROGRAM-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES COMPLIMENTARY
INVESTMENTS TO THE ROLL OUT OF
UNIVERSAL MALES- THIS INCLUDES
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND- TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS.
TO INCREASE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
FRESH AND NUTRITIOUS SCHOOL
MEALS. IN ANTIGEN ANTICIPATION-
OF UNIVERSAL MEALS
IMPLEMENTATION. ALLOWABLE USES
UNDER THIS PROGRAM INCLUDE
PURCHASE OF COOKING EQUIPMENT
SERVICE APPOINTMENT
REFRIGERATION AND STORAGE
TRANSPORTATION AND- FACILITY
UPGRADES AND TRAINING FOR FOOD
SERVICE STAFF- THE BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL THREE
MILLION- PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
SCHOOL BREAKFAST AND SUMMER
MEALS PROGRAM START UP GRANTS
PROGRAM- FOR A BUDGET YOUR TOTAL
OF FOUR POINT ZERO ONE SEVEN
MILLION. THESE FUNDS- ARE TENDED
TO ALSO REIMBURSE ELIGIBLE COSTS
INCURRED IN THE CURRENT YEAR- TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT
AND EXPAND BREAKFAST PROGRAMS IN
PREPARATION FOR UNIVERSAL MUNIS-
THAT. USE MY COMMENTS AND HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
L. L. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANYWAY WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS MRNING WE
WANTED TO SHARE OUR ASSESSMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON TWO OF
THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROPOSALS SPECIFICALLY THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX MILLION
AUGMENTATION FOR SCHOOL MEALS
ANSWER THE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TRAINING
GRANTS. BURST ON AUGMENTATION
WE'VE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PROPOSED
AUGMENTATION THIS PROPOSAL IS
ALIGNED WITH TRAILER LEGISLATION
FROM THE BACK BUDGET PASSED LAST
YEAR REQUIRING THAT BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ALL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS PROVIDE ONE-
FREE BREAKFAST AND ONE FREE
LUNCH PER SCHOOL DAY TO ANY
STUDENT REQUESTING A MEAL UNDER
UNIVERSAL MEALS. THE REMAINDER
OF MY COMMENTS FOCUS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FIND
ADDITIONAL KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TRAINING
GRANTS WE RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A REDUCED
AMOUNT OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE GRANTS
THIS IS ONE THIRD OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AMOUNT BUT
IT MATCHES THE AMOUNT PROVIDED
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE
PRIMARY REASON WE'RE
RECOMMENDING APPROVING A REDUCED
AMOUNT IS BECAUSE THE STATE DOES
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A CLEAR SENSE
OF THE TOTAL COST OF KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPLEMENTING
UNIVERSAL MEALS AT THIS TIME
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE STATE
ALREADY PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES AND THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO PROJECT. WE DO
EXPECT SOME MORE INFORMATION TO
BE MADE AVAILABLE AFTER JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS WHEN ELOISE MUST REPORT
HOW THE FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING
WAS USED WE ALSO RECOMMEND
PRIORITIZING THIS FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTING UNIVERSAL MEALS
RATHER THAN THE CORPORATION OF
FRESH FOODS THEIR SCRATCH
COOKING SCHOOLS WILL HAVE TO
MANAGE A VARIETY OF CHALLENGES
IN THE NEAR TERM INCLUDING
IMPLEMENTING UNIVERSAL MEALS
STAFFING SHORTAGES AND INCREASED
FOOD AND EQUIPMENT COSTS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE
EDUCATIONAL FUNDING FOR SCRATCH
COOKING TO MEET SOMEONE M.
PREMATURE AT THIS TIME WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT
FUNDING FOR BOTH UNIVERSAL MEALS. AND SCRATCH COOKING IN FUTURE
YEARS ONCE MORE IT. ABOUT DEMAND
AND THE USE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO GRANTS AND- LASTLY THE LEAD
. COULD ALSO CONSIDER MODIFYING
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE GRANTS TO
TARGET DISTRICTS THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY UNIVERSAL MEALS. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALLOCATES A
PORTION OF FUNDING TO DISTRICTS
WITH AT LEAST 30% OF STUDENTS
QUALIFYING FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS. THIS APPROACH
LIKELY EXCLUDES DISTRICTS THAT
NEED TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THEIR CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL MEALS INCLUDING THOSE
NOT CURRENTLY OFFERING SCHOOL
LUNCH OR BREAKFAST. AND THOSE
WITH LOWER SHARES OF STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS. ENSURE SMOOTHER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
ALLOCATING FUNDING BASED ON SOME
MEASURE OF NEEDED CAPACITY SUCH
AS SOME PROJECTION OF HOW MANY
MORE BILLS A DISTRICT WE NEED TO
SERVE. UNDER UNIVERSAL MEALS
COMPARED TO A PRIOR BASELINE
LEVEL. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME RUBIO. THANK YOU AT THE
PARTNER THE CATION. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BIRDS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAMP FRIENDS SELL
DIRECTOR OF NUTRITION SERVICES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TODAY I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
INVESTMENTS AND SCHOOL MEALS AND
ENSURING THAT ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO BOTH A
NUTRITIOUS BREAKFAST. AND THE
LUNCH EACH SCHOOL DAY. THIS
INVESTMENT TRULY ELEVATES THE
IMPORTANCE OF HEALTHY SCHOOL
MEALS AS A VITAL ELEMENT TO A
STUDENT'S OVERALL EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO PROVIDES OUR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ELEAZAR WITH MUCH NEEDED ONGOING
FINANCIAL RESPITE TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. STEADY'S CONFIRM THAT
THERE IS INCREASED PARTICIPATION
SCHOOL MALES FROM ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ECONOMIC
STATUS WHEN MALES ARE MADE
AVAILABLE AT NO COST FOR ALL.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE PANDEMIC
HAS REVEALED JUST HOW TRULY
ESSENTIAL SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS
ARE COMBATING BUILT IN SECURITY
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. NOT
JUST LOW INCOME BUT MODERATE TO
MIDDLE INCOME AS WELL. DECADES
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A NATIONAL
LEADER IN ESTABLISHING GREATER
ACCESS TO HEALTHY MEALS AND
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND L. A. L. THE
OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET AND THE
INVESTMENTS AND UNIVERSAL MALES.
THIS BUDGET REALLY HELPS THAT
OUR SCHOOLS UP FOR GREATER
SUCCESS IN IMPLEMENTING A
SUSTAINABLE UNIVERSAL MALES
PROGRAM. THE DESIGN OF THE
UNIVERSAL MALES PROGRAM IS
INTENTIONAL TO SUPPLEMENT NOT
SUPPLANT THE FEDERAL MAIL
PROGRAMS IN TWO WAYS ONE BY
REQUIRING SCHOOLS IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THE STATE REIMBURSEMENT.
TO BE ON THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
LUNCH AND SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM AND SUDDENLY. TO REALLY
MAXIMIZE THE FULL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING BY REQUIRING
HIGH PRIVATE POVERTY SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY. OR PROVISION AND THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR. CURRENTLY THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED SIX ELEAZAR
AT OVER FORTY TWO HUNDRED SCHOOL
SITES PARTICIPATING AND
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY PROVISION
TO. AND WE ESTIMATE THAT THERE'S
OVER A LEVIN HUNDRED SCHOOL
SITES PARTICIPATING IN NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY SO ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS IMPLEMENTED
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY. THERE
WOULD BE A COST SAVINGS TO THE
STATE UNIVERSAL MALES PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE WOULD BE TOP DRAWING
DOWN MORE FEDERAL FUNDS AT THE
FREE RATE. THE PROPOSED FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION-DOLLARS IN THE KITCHEN AND FOR
STRUCTURE AND TRAINING FUND THAT
FORMULA HONORS THE NEEDS OF OUR
ELEAZAR IT REALLY TRULY
RECOGNIZES THAT NOT ALL SCHOOLS
ARE THE SAME. REGARDLESS OF THE
SCHOOL IS HIGH POVERTY WITH OR
HAS HIGH FREE AND REDUCED OR
MODERATE FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
STUDENT POPULATION THEY EACH
HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS AND SCHOOLS
NEED CHOICE AND OPTIONS AND HOW
TO USE THESE VALUABLE RESOURCES.
THE FUNDING ALLOCATIONS ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT OR EXPAND
SERVICES AND VERY INNOVATIVE
WAYS THAT BEST MEET THEIR NEEDS.
I COULD BE MORE SCRATCH COOKING
IT QUOTE WHICH HAS BEEN A PROVEN%
STRATEGY- WITH THE CURRENT
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES IT COULD BE
CREATING MORE POINT OF SERVICE
OPTIONS. EXTENDING MAIL SERVICE
AND- MEAL TIMES OFFERING NEW
BREAKFAST MODELS DEVELOPING SAP
STAFF SKILLS ARE PURCHASING
EQUIPMENT ARE REPAIRING
EQUIPMENT THAT IS NEEDED. THE
RESPONSE TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING FUND'S
BEEN INCREDIBLY POSITIVE AND
WE'RE HEARING FROM SCHOOLS THAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE ON
GOING ESPECIALLY OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. AS WE COME OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC. SCHOOLS HAVE SEEN
DECREASES BILL PARTICIPATION
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS AS MUCH
AS 11% WHEN WE COMPARE SEPTEMBER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIRTY TRULY STRUGGLING TO
REBOUND- FROM THE PANDEMIC THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CHALLENGES
INFLATION STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
ADDRESSING DECLINING ENROLLMENTS
. SO THIS YEAR WITH- THE KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
ALLEYS ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THESE
BONDS NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
REGISTERED TO RECEIVE THE WAITED
EIGHTY FOUR RESPONSE RATE FOR
THE KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THIS YEAR. AND THERE REALLY ARE
FOOD SERVER STRUCTURES ARE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
REBUILDING THEIR PROGRAMS AND
GETTING BACK TO ME THE FRESH
QUALITY CHOICES THAT EXISTED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS THE USDA FEDERAL
EQUIPMENT GRANT THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO SCHOOLS ON THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM HAS NEVER
BEEN SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED TO
SUPPORT ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
REQUEST IT FALLS. BAR SHORT OF
THE NEEDS OF OUR KITCHEN AND
THEY EQUIPMENT NEEDS OF OUR
ALLEY AS AND FAR TOO MANY ALLEYS
ARE EXCLUDED. AND THIS YEAR IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEDERAL
COMMITMENT GRANT- WE RECEIVED
THREE HUNDRED. AT THE I'M SORRY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING BUT WE RECEIVED OVER
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING REQUEST RALLY AS THIS IS
WHY THE KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TRAINING FUNDS ARE SO
IMPORTANT. WE'RE CURRENTLY
PARTNERING WITH UC BERKELEY
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE TWO A
SURVEY EVALUATE FOOD SERVICE
DIRECTORS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF UNIVERSAL MALES THEIR
CONCERNS THEIR NEEDS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING JUST LAST WEEK WE HAD
OVER THREE IN OUR FORTY FIVE
JUST US- DIRECTORS RESPONDING
AND THERE ARE ABOUT 82% ARE
SAYING INADEQUATE EQUIPMENT LACK
OF SPACE. STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
NEED FOR ONGOING FINDING AS A
COMMON CONCERNS. SO WE DO NOT
KNOW THAT WHEN OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED
THAT THEY ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND MEETING THE DEMANDS OF THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS FUTURE
OUTAGES AND FOOD SUPPLY ISSUES
BUT THEY NEED THAT EQUIPMENT SO
THAT THEY CAN BE NIMBLE AND
THEIR PROCUREMENT THEIR
PRODUCTION AND DELIVERY. METHODS
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
THEY NEED A RELIABLE EQUIPMENT
TO PLAN OUT IN FUTURE YEARS FOR
EQUIPMENT EXPANSION AND ORDERING
. SO WE REALLY DO FEEL THAT-
SCRATCH COOKING IS AN OPTION
FOR. OPTION FOR MANY OF OUR
SCHOOLS BEGAN THEY HAVE SHARE
THAT THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND
ADDRESSING WHEN FOOD HAS NOT
BEEN AVAILABLE QUANTITIES OR THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. THE CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL MILLS PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH. AND WE WANT
THEM TO BE APPEALING AND
SOMETHING OUR STUDENTS LOOK
FORWARD TO EATING SOME CLOSING
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD THE
WAY LONG TERM INVESTMENTS IN OUR
CHILDREN'S OVERALL WELLBEING AND
ACADEMIC SUCCESS BY BREAKING
DOWN FOOD ACCESS TO SCHOOL
MEALS. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE ON GOING
FUNDING OF UNIVERSAL MALES AND
WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE ON THE KITCHEN
BUT TRUCKS ARE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU. THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. I
JUST AS A LEVEL ONE QUESTION AND
THIS WAS SIMILAR TO. WE TALK
ABOUT THE AFTER SCHOOL ONE AND
THAT'S- HOW THIS IS RELATING TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND I COULD
KERR THAT YOU KNOW MR TANGUAY
RAISED EARLIER ARE OUR CLIENT IS
THE COMMUNITY AND THE SIX
MILLION STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
HOW THAT WORKS FOR THEM WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO. FOR FIRST CD II OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- HOW IS
IT- HOW'S IT GOING WORKING WITH
R. KELLY AS AND THIS NEW
UNIVERSAL MANTRA. WELL GOOD CAN
CAMPAIGNS DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
CERTAINLY I'M SCHOOLS AS WE KNOW
COME IN ALL SHAPES AND SIZES AND
SO CONCERNED LEVEL IS ON AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS WE ARE OFFERING
A MONTHLY TOWN HALLS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT RESOURCES TO
HELP WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR THEM TO
MAKE THEM SUCCESSFUL AND- YOU
KNOW WE WILL CONTINUE THAT
THROUGH THE COMING YEAR CHIU AND
PARTNERING THEM WITH BEST
PRACTICES AND RESOURCES FOR
THEIR SUCCESS. OKAY. YOU HAVE A
FURTHER COMMENT THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS. I DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENT I THINK I WAS
JUST GOING TO HIGHLIGHT THE-
SAME THING AS AS- MY COLLEAGUE
KIM DID YOU KNOW THAT THAT THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND-
YOU KNOW POINTS- ALL OF THESE-
YOU KNOW THE TOWN HALL WEAPON
ARMS AND THE- WE UNIVERSAL
MEALS. LISTINGS SESSIONS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN HOLDING. UP WITH
ELLIE ACE. OKAY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN- NEXT ISSUE IS ISSUE NUMBER
THREE THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WAY TO
GREEN SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION AND
CHARTER FACILITY MAINTENANCE.
PLEASE PROCEED BERMAN A FINANCE
ALEJO THE DEPARTMENT OF ED IN
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE. THAT
CLEAN A GRANT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE GOOD MORNING AGAIN-
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM AND THAT'S IT TO FOCUS
ON CREATING SCHOOL BUS FLEETS IN
THE STATE. SPECIFICALLY GRANTS
OF AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOULD BE AVAILABLE WITH
PRIORITY FOR RETIRING OUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES OLDEST
INTERNAL COMBUSTION BUSES-
ELEAZAR THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATIONS OF UNDUPLICATED
PUPILS AS WELL SMALL AND RURAL
AND LIAISE AND IN KEEPING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER
FOCUS ON REDUCING HARMFUL
VEHICLE EMISSIONS- WITH GRANTS
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
ELLIE A WOULD BE ABLE TO.
ACQUIRE AN ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS
PURCHASE AND CONSTRUCT THE BUSES
CHARGING STATION AD SUPPORT
OTHER LOCAL A SCHOOL BUS
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. IS
INVESTMENTS. WILL RESULT IN
ONGOING SAVINGS TO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE USED TO SUPPORT OTHER
ASPECTS OF AN ALLEY AS-
APPROPRIATE STUDENT TRANSPORT-
PROGRAMS- THIS CONCLUDES MY
PREFERMENTS OR- ANY QUESTIONS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A DELL AT THE
CURRENT FINANCE FOR EACH ISSUE
FOR THE CHARTER ISSUE AND YES
OKAY CORRECT. YEAH GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BIRDS JENNIFER TALKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY PROVIDES FACILITIES
AND WORKING CAPITAL FINANCING
JUST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COMMUNICATORS DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND GRANTS TO ASSIST CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH RENT AND LEASE
COSTS. THIS PROGRAM TARGET
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES WITH
SIGNIFICANT POPULATIONS OF
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES AN AUGMENTATION OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT OTHER ELIGIBLE
FACILITIES COST BUT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT AN ADDITIONAL
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR WORKLOAD
ADJUSTMENT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM. I JUST
NEED TO THE AND- INVEST THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO COMPLETE DESIGN OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF
FREMONT CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR
THE BLIND FREMONT STUDENT
HOUSING MODERNIZATION.
CONTINUING UP PROJECT FIRST
FUNDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT. THIS PROJECT
CONSISTS OF THE RENOVATION OF
TWENTY SIX HOUSING BUILDINGS AS
WELL AS IMPROVEMENTS UTILITIES
AND PASS TRAVEL. WITHOUT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AM
I CALLED KALI BARBARA KELLER'S
ONLINE TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE
SPECIAL SCHOOLS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. HELLO YOU KEEP THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN
COUPON WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'LL START WITH THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL. IN JUST
SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND HERE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OWN NEARLY
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES
ONLY TWO THIRDS OF THOSE ARE
DIESEL BUSES AND MANY OF THOSE
DIESEL BUSES ARE OLDER MODELS
THAT WERE MANUFACTURED UNDER
LESS STRINGENT EMISSION
STANDARDS IN THOSE EXISTING
TODAY. A BATTERY ELECTRIC BUSES
ARE RELATIVELY NEW MY CHIN
DISTRICTS BEGAN BUYING THEM
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO AND
CURRENTLY OWNS SEVERAL HUNDRED
STATEWIDE. ELECTED BUSES HOUSE
MENTAL ADVANTAGES DID NOT
PRODUCE DETAILED EMISSIONS THAT
CAN HARM HUMAN HEALTH. THEY
MIGHT SNIFFING LESS GREENHOUSE
GAS AND IT CAN BE LESS EXPENSIVE
TO OPERATE. THE MAIN IMITATION
IS THE RANGE MANY MODELS TODAY
HAVE A MAXIMUM RANGES BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY AND A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES. AND THAT MEANS
NOTHING BE LESSEN STRENUOUS
CONDITIONS LIKE MOUNTAINOUS
TERRAIN OR HOT OR COLD WEATHER.
THEY ALSO THE HIGHER UPFRONT
COST ABOUT TWICE AS MUCH AS A
DIESEL BUS. I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL SO IT
IS ON TOP OF A LARGE FEDERAL
PROGRAM CREATED LAST NOVEMBER.
THE FUND AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS STATE PROGRAM CREATED IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. COUPLE SMALLER STATE
PROGRAMS. AND WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ADVANCED A
PROMISING IDEA USING ONE TIME
FUNDS TO PURCHASE ELECTRIC BUSES
COULD PROVIDE MISSION BENEFITS
THAT WILL LAST FOR MANY YEARS.
AND AGAIN DISTRICTS SOME COST
RELIEF RELATED REPLACING OLDER
BUSES AND PROGESTIN. WOULD
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE PROPOSAL
WITH A COUPLE MODIFICATIONS. ARE
THE FIRST TO BE TO PRIORITIZE
THE PLACEMENT OF THE OLDEST
BUSES I SWEAR AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES THE AGE OF THE BUSES AS
ONE FACTOR WE RECOMMEND MAKING
IT THE MAIN FACTOR. GENERALLY
OLDER BUSES EMIT MORE POLLUTION
SO PLACED IN THE OLDEST ONES
FIRST WOULD MAXIMIZE THE
POTENTIAL AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS. A SECOND WE
RECOMMEND ALLOWING FUNDING FOR
OTHER TYPES OF BUSES ELECTRIC
BUSES ARE NOT FEASIBLE. THIS IS
MAINLY AN ISSUE THAT AFFECTS
REAL DISTRICTS OF LONG STRENUOUS
ROUTE. IN THOSE DISTRICTS
REPLACEMENT THEY'RE NOT ELECTED
BUS WITH THE NEW. BUSQUETS
ACHIEVE. REDUCTIONS IN POLLUTION
. I WE'VE GOT ELIMINATING THE
TEMPERATE ALLOWANCE FOR OTHER
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. ARE THAT
PART OF THE PROPOSAL DOES. NOT
SEEM CLEARLY CONNECTED WITH THE
UNDERLYING BECAUSE IS PRETTY
SIMILAR. BUS FOR RUNNING A
SCHOOL TRUST. PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE SOME KIND THAT IT CA
DISCOURAGE DISTRICTS. FOR PLACE
FUNDING FROM THE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT DON'T OFFER THAT. OF A LOT
. NOT WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND
STARTING WITH A SMALL AND MARK
LEE FOR THE FOR. AND FUTURE FUND
OVER SO YEARS. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THE LATEST NOT BUT TO A
- THE- IN THE FUTURE BASED
DISTRICT IN. IN PROGRESS FOR TO
PLAY SOME THE BUSES. ONE OUT
COULD BE TO WITH THE NEW ON OF
FIVE MILLION. AND AFTER PLACE
THAN I THOUGHT BUSES. LYNCH AND
FIX UP THE CURRENT IN A TWO
YEARS. IF YOU JUST WITH
SOMETHING CLOSE TO THE FULL FIVE
FIVE BILLION. WOULD RECOMMEND
ALLOWING SOME OF IT TO BE TRICKS
DISTRICT. NOT A PLACE BY. THAT
WOULD SAFETY CARE THE FULHAM
INTEREST DESTROY. LASTLY WE SEE
. CAN WHICH AGENCY IS BEST
POSITIONED TO. THE WE CAN PUT A
CREDIT. IS KEEPING OF MAN THE
PROBE. THERE ARE MANY TYPES OF
CONTENT GRANTS. AND THE PREVIOUS
MANAGED DOCTORS PLACEMENT FOR.
FIRST DISTRICTS. ON THE OTHER
HAND THE CAL AREAS BOARD ALREADY
WILL RECEIVE THE BEST OF THE FOR
COULD LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. AND
DIVIDING TO FROM ACROSS THE TWO
H. I WOULDN'T THEM ENGAGE IN
THAT COURTNEY. SINCE NEED LIKE
APPLY BOTH DRUG. FINDING THIS
NEW PROGRAM TO THE YOUR RESEARCH
FOR MY DEVOID SOME OF THAT BACK
AND FORTH. INSTREAM THE FUNDING
OF. PROCESS I SHOULD IN THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AT THE- FOR THE
FACILITY PARK SEEMS WITH
ALLOWABLE. FOR THE PROGRAM
CURRENTLY. AND WE HAVE NO WITH
THAT BEFORE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU NAY OIL. I THANK YOU
MISTER SECOND INCLUDES A
COMMENTS ON THE ON THE APPLE'S
GOT. I HAD TO NEED TO OKAY THANK
YOU BERMAN OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR THERE WAS A
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JUAN
MORALES THE TO. OF THE SCHOOL
ADDRESS. SERVICES DIVISION OF.
AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO HERE WITH
TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU SOME OPEN
REMARKS BEHALF OF STATE SHOULD.
OF PUBLIC AND TO THURMOND. WE
WANT TO START OUT BY. THE
GOVERNOR FOR PAPA SUCH A SIGNAL%
INVEST IS TRANSFER. WE THAT MAY
FAMILY RELY ON SCHOOL BUS TO BE
ABLE TO SCHOOL DAY. IN FACT IT
IS ESTIMATED THAT CLOSED
MILLION. ARE TRANS DAILY. LAST
THERE IS A SCHOOL. ON A SCHOOL
BUS NOT ONLY THIS. WAY TO GET
THE SCHOOL. BUT ALSO HELPS
THROUGH. OTHER CAR FROM THE AS
WELL SCHOOL BUS AND THE- OF A
THIRTY SIX CARS. WE ALSO AGREE
THAT OLDER SCHOOL BUSES NEED TO
BE REPLACED WITH NEWER
TECHNOLOGY. THAT WILL NOT ONLY
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS. BUT
THEY WILL ALSO HELP LOWER THE
OPERATIONAL COST. FOR OUR DAILY
AS IN THE NEAR AND THE LONG TERM
. THAT M. WE ARE VERY PLEASED AT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
INTO INVEST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION. FOR THE CREATION OF THE
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM TO REPLACE OLDER BUSES
AND SOME OF THE- AREAS OF THE
STATE. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE
FUNDING WILL REPLACE
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
OLDER SCHOOL BUSES. SO THE
IMPACT THAT THIS INVESTMENTS
GOING TO HAVE ON OUR SCHOOLS ON
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IN GENERAL IS QUITE
CLEAR. OF COURSE MISTER SUCH A
LARGE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE PROCESS WOULD
REQUIRE DEDICATED RESOURCES TO
ENSURE THE PROGRAM'S SUCCESS. WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. AND WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS ALSO MISS ANNA BORJAS WHO
LEADS OUR OFFICES SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION AND WE CAN BOTH
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. OKAY THAT'S OKAY WE'LL GO
NOW TO THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE. I AM GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ENTER MCCARTY
MY NAME IS KATRINA KAIF HANSHIN
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING- AS YOU KNOW
C. AS THE BASIN MINISTER THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. SINCE THAT TIME WE
HAVE SEEN DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM
GROW AT THE COSTA FACILITIES THE
MAINTENANCE OF THAT FACILITY HAS
OUTPACED AVAILABLE FUNDING TO
THIS PROGRAM. IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE BUSINESS AUGMENTATION IS
NOT A NEW FUNDING CATEGORY THE
PROGRAM GIVES PRIORITY TO RENT
LEASE COST AND IF FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE AFTER READING THESE
COSTS ARE PAID OTHER COSTS ARE
FUNDED. THE LAW STATES THAT
THESE FUNDS MAY BE USED FOR COST
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH REMODELING
BUILDINGS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND STALLING. ORG'S EXTENDING
SERVICE SYSTEMS AND OTHER BUILT
IN EQUIPMENT AND IMPROVING
SITES. THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FUNDING ROUND WITH THE
LAST TIMES YESTERDAY WAS ABLE TO
FIND OTHER COST UNDER THIS
PROGRAM AND DURING THAT FUNDING
ROUND ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
RECEIVED ONLY 46% OF ELIGIBLE
COSTS UNDER THIS CATEGORY. THE
NEW ONE ON THE FUNDING. BEING
PER BY THE- WILL ENSURE THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS. ARE WELL
MAINTAINED AND SAFE FOR STUDENTS
. THIS PROPOSAL IS APPROVED IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SCHOOLS TOTAL AWARD WILL NEVER
EXCEED THE AWARD CAP DETERMINED
BY EACH SCHOOL'S AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE. ADDITIONALLY IF
APPROVED THE USE THAT THEY WILL
WORK TO IMPLEMENT ANY NECESSARY
VERY REGULATORY CHANGES RELATED
TO FUNDING FOR COALBED RELATED
MITIGATION AND PREVENTION. AS
WELL AS WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO ENSURE THAT THE
AUTHORITY HAS ADEQUATE RESOURCES
TO CARRY OUT THIS FUNDING
AUGMENTATION. AND INEFFICIENT
AND PRUDENT MANNER- I ALSO HAVE
MY COLLEAGUES RYAN'S STORY AND
JEFF MARTIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. I WANT TO TALK FIRST
ABOUT THE- THE SCHOOL BUS ISSUE-
I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT WE ARE
ELECTRIFYING OUR OUR SCHOOLS
TRANSPORTATION- FULLY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- ANOTHER ISSUE ABOUT
SCHOOL BUSES THERE'S LEGISLATION
ON WHICH THAT MORE OF THAT ACT I
DON'T I KNOW OUR UTILIZATION OF
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION IS VERY
VERY LOUD IN CALIFORNIA I KNOW
WHEN I SEE IT SCHOOL BUS DRIVING
BY. NEVER SEEN ANYBODY ON THAT
BUS BUT THAT'S ANOTHER STORY- I
DO NOTE THAT WE HAVE A SURGE IN
ONE TIME MONEY I DO- SHARE THE-
YOU KNOW THE QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS THIS YEAR AND OVER TIME
I KNOW MISTER O'DONNELL DOES THE
SAME ABOUT UTILIZING- PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONIES FOR THINGS
OTHER THAN CLASSROOM AND SCHOOL
INFRASTRUCTURE SO YOU KNOW IT
SEEMS THAT WE COULD USE OTHER-
ONE TIME MONIES WHICH WE HAVE
PLENTY OF FOR THIS GREEN. A
SCHOOL BUS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
USE THAT ONE TIME PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS FOR OUR FACILITIES-
I KNOW THIS PROPOSAL FOR MURDER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CHAIR TO IN
OUR SCHOOL BOND IN PAST YEARS
AGO TO LOOK AT AS MUCH AS WE CAN
A ONE TIME NINETY EIGHT MONEY
FOR- FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES
MODERNIZATION OR CONSTRUCTION SO
FORTH SO I WOULD RATHER FOCUS ON
THAT. AND THEN- I THINK IT-
THERE ARE SOME. ON THE ON GOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT. FOR THE-
SCHOOL LEASE FACILITIES
ESPECIALLY- FOR THE CHARTER
FACILITIES ESPECIALLY- PRIVATELY
OWNED- PROPERTY- WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE LEASE IS UP. I MEAN IF
IT'S A GOVERNMENT BUILDING I GET
IT IT'S GOING TO BE IN
GOVERNMENT FOR PERPETUITY- I
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S ITS
CHARTER ENTITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I THINK IT'S CALLED
SABA. AND THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
SITES ONE IS AT A FORMER
COMMUNITY CENTER IN MY DISTRICT
AND A FAKE. RETROFITTED THAT IS
SOMETHING THERE IT'S OWNED BY
THE CITY IT'S A COMMUNITY CENTER
AND OTHER. SITE YOU KNOW A FEW
MILES AWAY IS THAT A STRIP MALL
AND IF THEY- DID SOME- YOU KNOW
UPGRADES THERE AND SO FORTH WHEN
THE LEASE IS UP YOU KNOW ISN'T
THAT A WINDFALL THE PROPERTY
OWNER NOW NOT THE TAXPAYERS SO.
I DO HAVE SOME SOME SOME ISSUES
AND QUESTIONS THAT. YEAH ANY
ISSUES ACROSS HERE MR GOLF. YES-
AMID THANK AND I DO TO HIGHLIGHT
SCHOOL BUS ISSUE THAT SHOULD
COME FOR NON EIGHT DOLLARS-
USING THOSE. USING NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS
THAT COULD GO TO REDUCE CLASS
SIZES FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH IN SCHOOLS
IS A BETTER PLACE. TO PUT THESE
DOLLARS AND WHAT QUITE FRANKLY
WHAT OFTEN ARE EXPERIMENTAL
BUSES- IF YOU JUST LOOK AT. WHAT
WE'RE ENCOURAGING DISTRICTS TO
DO IS PROBABLY SPENT ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO CHARGE
A BUS ALONE. IT IS A HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE OF THE BUS YET. HE
THEN YOU GET WHAT ONE BUS- THERE
ARE WHAT ABOUT THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S NOT REALLY A
REASONABLE APPROACH THOSE
DOLLARS SHOULD BE SPENT IN THE
CLASSROOM LOOK WE HAVE THE
LARGEST CLASS SIZES. IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE
AND TO SPEND THE MONEY ON
LECTURED. FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS I DON'T THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA NINE NINE NINE NINETY
EIGHT LET'S HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT USING CLASSROOM
DOLLARS FOR THAT PURPOSE. AGAIN
IS TO ME JUST CHASING THE SHINY
OBJECT A SHINY OBJECT TO ME. IS
THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS I WITH THAT AND JUST
OVER TO THE FACILITY SIDE- THAT
CHARTER. SCHOOLS ARE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE AN- AN ANNUAL DAY
. DEDICATE ON DOLLAR FOR. WHERE%
IN OTHER SCHOOLS ARE NOT- SO WE
SHOULD LOOK AT PARITY FOR THAT
AND REALLY A LOT OF THE DOLLAR
SHOULD COME OUT OF NINETY EIGHT
AS WELL. AS THEY DO FOR
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS- BUT
A QUESTION FOR FINANCE IS I DO
HAVE A QUESTION WHY WOULD THE
STATE PROVIDE FUNDS TO RETROFIT
A PRIVATELY OWNED FACILITY- THIS
IS WHAT. IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GROW- GRANT PROGRAM. IS
THAT REALLY A WISE USE OF PUBLIC
MONEY AGAIN TO RETROFIT A
PRIVATELY OWNED. FACILITY NOW
FOR A PUBLIC ONE I THINK AN
ARGUMENT CAN BE MADE. BUT PUT.
BUT AND THIS IS JUST AGAIN
SHOULD SAY DOLLARS GO FOR THIS
PURPOSE THIS IS IN A NINETY
EIGHT CONVERSATION. BUT AGAIN-
COULD COULD- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RESPONDED THAT. HI
JENNIFER TALKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WOULD
JUST KNOW FIRST OFF THAT THIS
INVESTMENT IS NOT EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE THAT
WE'RE JUST PROVIDING FUNDS TO
AUGMENT- SECOND OF ALL- WELL
THIS PROGRAM DOES PROVIDE- LEASE
COSTS IT'S- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO LOCAL
BOND FUNDS TO SUPPORT THEIR
FACILITY NEEDS- AND- THIS. AND
SPEAKING TO PARITY THIS ON
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
WAS INTENDED TO PROVIDE PARITY-
ALONG WITH THE INVESTMENT WE'RE
MAKING TO THE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM. THANK YOU IS ONE OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. DO USE CONDUIT
BONDS. TO SUPPORT THEIR
FACILITIES THEY ALSO ARE. A PART
OF TYPICALLY PART OF THE STATE-
SCHOOL BOND- PROGRAM- BUT AGAIN
WHAT WE ANOTHER QUESTION LONG
THOSE LINES WHAT HAPPENS TO
THESE TO A PRIVATE FACILITY WHEN
A CHARTER SCHOOL SHUTS DOWN
WHERE DID THEY GO. LET'S SEE A
GOOD AMOUNT OF PUBLIC MONEY HAS
BEEN INVESTED OF A SILLY WHAT
THEN HAPPENS OF FACILITY SHOULD
HAVE A CHARTER SCHOOL SHUT DOWN.
AND SHOULD THERE BE A WAY TO
RECOUP THE FUNDS. I'M JENNIFER
**** WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING AND- SO TOTALLY WE'VE
HEARD THAT CHARTER SCHOOL THAT
THESE FACILITIES IF THEY ARE NO
LONGER IN POSSESSION OF THAT
THAT CHARTER SCHOOL NO LONGER IS
RESIDING WITHIN THAT FACILITY.
AT THAT IS THEN PASSED ALONG TO
OTHER CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT FOR
FURTHER COMMENT ON THAT I WOULD.
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY. DOES THE DOES THE
SCHOOL FINANCE AUTHORITY WHICH
TO COMMON. WE HAVE TO PULL
TOGETHER- SOME DATA ON THAT AS
IT RELATES TO PUBLIC VERSUS
PRIVATE FACILITIES- YOU KNOW BUT
I DID WANT TO NOTE THAT
TYPICALLY THE INVESTMENT ON THE
OTHER COST CATEGORIES ABOUT. WAS
IT FORTY TWO THOUSAND RYAN- SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT MASSIVE
RENOVATIONS ARE RETROFITTING-
RYAN STORY OR JEFF MARTIN YOU
HAVE THAT DATA IN FRONT OF YOU.
THE LAST TIME THAT THESE COSTS
WERE PAID OUT IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN- FUNDING ROUND. OKAY
IT'S PUBLIC MONEY SO AGAIN THE
CONCERN BEING WORD IS THIS
PUBLIC MONEY GO AND THEN JUST-
ONE OTHER COMMENT I DON'T REALLY
NEED A RESPONSE TO IT I THINK WE
DID YOU DO NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
ELIGIBILITY WHERE. A SCHOOL
CHARTER SCHOOL. MAY RECEIVE
FUNDS- BASED ON THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SITS IN. NOT THE STUDENTS IT
SERVES THE OAKLAND BEING A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THAT SO I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT THEY'RE BEING
ELIGIBLE THEY WERE THEN IN OTHER
WORDS OUR CHARTER SCHOOL BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING BASED ON
THE NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S A NOT THE
STUDENTS IT SERVES. SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THANK YOU AND SO WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE- THERE- ON THOSE TWO
ISSUES. WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN AND GO TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
. RELATED TO THE PROPOSAL FOR
EARLY LITERACY. ELCHO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- SO I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON BOTH PROPOSALS-
BUT MY COLLEAGUES FOR BRIAN'S
ALSO TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- FIRST THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION- ONE I'M
PROBABLY NINETY GENERAL FUND TO
CREATE THE MULTILINGUAL
CLASSROOM LIBRARY GRANT PROGRAMS
- SCHOOL'S TO ESTABLISH OR
EXPAND SCHOOL OR CLASSROOM
LIBRARIES OFFERING CULTURALLY
RELEVANT TEXTS- FUNDS WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS SERVING
HIGH RATES OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS IN ENGLISH LEARNERS-
AND CAN BE USED TO BUY BOOKS. TO
ESTABLISH SCHOOL OR CLASSROOM
LIBRARIES FOR STUDENTS IN
PRESCHOOL THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR GRANTS TO HIGH
NEED SCHOOLS TO TRAIN AND HIRE
LITERACY COACHES- AND READING
SPECIALISTS. THE MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROPOSAL- FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL BE ALLOCATED. TO
ELIGIBLE SCHOOLS ON A PER
STUDENT RATE- SUCH THAT NO
ELIGIBLE SCHOOL RECEIVES LESS
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE WANT THESE FUNDS TO
GO TO OUR MOST HIGH NEED
STUDENTS WHICH IS WHY ELIGIBLE
SCHOOLS ARE DEFINED AS THOSE
WITH ABOVE AND 95% RATE OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS- ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND USE AND FOSTER CARE
. THE REMAINING SUNDAY IN IN
THIS PROPOSAL- TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS PROVIDED TO
CONTRACT WITH A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. TO DEVELOP
AND PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
LITERACY COACHES AND REGION
SPECIALISTS. WE SEE THESE TWO
PROPOSALS AS BEING BACK WRITING
AND RESEARCH- INCLUDING RESEARCH
SHOWING THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF
STRONG LIBRARY PROGRAMS. AND
MULTILINGUAL BOOKS- AND DATA
SHOWING THAT LITERACY COACHES
MAKE A HUGE IMPACT IN THE LIVES
OF STRUGGLING READERS- SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION- BUT
MY COLLEAGUES FROM FINANCE AND I
ARE AVAILABLE TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU I TO THE L. L. GOOD MORNING
EMILY WITH L. A. L. AGAIN WE
WANTED TO SHARE OUR ASSESSMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON TWO OF
THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY LITERACY
PROPOSALS SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
FOR LITERACY COACHES WHICH
INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
STATEWIDE TRAINING FOR THESE
COACHES. IN TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME FOR CULTURALLY RELEVANT
AND MULTILINGUAL BOOKS OVERALL
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF BOTH PROPOSALS
WHEN I WAS STATE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE EARLY LITERACY COULD BE
WARRANTED WE FIND THAT SCHOOLS
ALREADY HAVE A VARIETY OF
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES THERE%
WHICH THEY CAN FIND ADDITIONAL
LITERACY COACHES AND
MULTILINGUALBOOKS INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME FOR ALL
COVERED RELIEF FUNDS. AND OF
COURSE I'LL SEE IF I HAVE FOR
INSTANCE THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROVIDED A ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR ON GOING
AUGMENTATION TO THE LCF
CONCENTRATION GRANT TO HIRE MORE
STAFF FOR DIRECT STUDENT
SERVICES INCLUDING CLARITY
COACHES IS AUGMENTATION TARGETS
MANY OF THE DISTRICTS I WOULD
RECEIVE FUNDING UNDER BOTH OF
THE GOVERNOR'S K. TWELVE EARLY
LITERACY PROPOSALS. WE CAN GUIDE
MINISTRATIONS APPROACH OF
PROVIDING RESTRICTED FUNDING FOR
STERN EARLY LITERACY ACTIVITIES
IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT
ELOISE LOCALLY DETERMINED AND
FIND I ALREADY IS UNDER LCF
HALF. ON THE LITERACY COACH
PROPOSAL STUDIES SUGGEST THAT
LITERACY COACHING CAN IMPROVE
STUDENT READING TEST SCORES IF
EXPERIENCE COACHES ARE PLACED IN
THE LOWEST PERFORMING SCHOOLS
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS HOWEVER
THE GOVERNOR'S LITERACY COACH
PROPOSAL DOES NOT ALIGN WITH THE
RESEARCH AND THREE KEY ASPECTS.
FIRST THE PROPOSAL IS NOT
TARGETED TO THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS AS INDICATED
UNDER THE SEAT SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM INSIDE THE
PROPOSAL TARGETS FUNDING BASED
ON STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS SECOND
TEMPORARY FUNDING COMPLEMENT THE
PROPOSAL'S IMPACT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ONLY PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THREE YEARS. GIVEN
THE TIME IT TAKES TO HIRE TRAIN
AND PLAN FOR COACHING COACHES
MAY JUST BE STARTING TO BE
EFFECTIVE AROUND THE TIME THAT
FUNDING EXPIRES. ALTHOUGH
SCHOOLS MUST THE MOBILE LONG
TERM FOR FUN BECAUSE- THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT THESE POSITIONS
BE FUNDED IN THE FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE- LET TRILOGY.
WOULD NOT PER SCHOOL FROM YOU
THIS MY- TO SUPPLY EGGS. FUND
FOR CO ALSO LIMITING THE IMPACT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. LASTLY CURRENT
STAFFING. DAYS COULD RESULT IN
MANY AN EXPERIENCED BEING HIRED
WE KNOW THAT MANY DISTRICTS ARE
FACING WIDESPREAD STAFFING
SHORTAGES INCLUDING FOR LITERACY
COACH POSITIONS. EFFECTIVE
LITERACY COACHES TYPICALLY HAVE
SUCCESSFUL EXPERIENCES TEACHING%
READING IN THE CLASSROOM. A
STRONG GRASP OF READING
INSTRUCTION AND INTERVENTION AND
EXPERIENCE WORKING AND COACHING
TEACHERS SUCH QUALIFIED LITERACY
COACHES COULD BE DIFFICULT TO
FIND IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENDS TO ADDRESS THE- STAFFING
LIMITATIONS THROUGH THE PROPOSED
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR STATEWIDE TRAINING IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT SEE WHAT TRAINING
WOULD EFFECTIVE. LEVERAGE THIS
KNOWLEDGE GAP SINCE THIS
TRAINING MIGHT NOT BE TAILORED
TO EACH SCHOOL. ONTHE
MULTILINGUAL BOOKS PROPOSAL TO
DETERMINE VERY LITTLE RESEARCH
ON THE IMPACT OF HAVING MORE
MULTI LINGUAL BOOKS IN SCHOOL
LIBRARIES ON CHILD LITERACY.
MORE RESEARCH IS AVAILABLE ON
THE BENEFITS OF READING TIME
WHICH MAY INCLUDE READING IN
OTHER LANGUAGES CHILDREN CAN
ALSO ACCESS WHICH WHAT'S FROM
THEIR LOCAL PUBLIC LIBRARY
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDING MORE
BOOKS IN SCHOOL AND LIBRARY. AND
OUR CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES WOULD
NOT DIRECTLY IMPROVED OR RESULT
IN INEFFECTIVE INSTRUCTION WHICH
WOULD BENEFIT STUDENTS MOST WE
THINK OTHER STATE INITIATIVES
CAN BETTER SUPPORT ENGLISH
LEARNERS. SUCH AS INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF BILINGUAL TEACHERS AND
PROVIDING MORE TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS TO BETTER SUPPORT
ENGLISH LEARNERS. LASTLY FOR
BOTH PROPOSALS WE FOUND THAT
SOME VERY SMALL SCHOOLS WITH
FEWER THAN TEN STUDENTS IN THE
QUALIFYING GREETS FANS WOULD
QUALIFY FOR SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF FUNDING. GIVEN THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR BOTH PROPOSALS
ARE OVERLAPPING A VERY SMALL
SCHOOL MEETING BOTH CRITERIA
COULD RECEIVE MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BASE
FUNDING FROM THE TWO PROPOSALS
ALONE. BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS
WE WERE I CAN THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE PROPOSED FUNDING
LITERACY COACHES MULTI. BOOK
BRING UP SEVEN HUNDRED FOR OTHER
. PRIORITIES HOWEVER IF LET.
WERE IN. IN FINDING THESE FOR.
WE OFFER SEVERAL MODIFICATIONS
FIRST ON A LITERACY COACH
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EXTEND THE TIMELINE FROM THREE
YEARS TO FIVE YEARS IN
CLARIFYING THAT FUNDS ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT. NOT
SUPPLANT EXISTING FUNDING FOR
BOTH REBELS OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TARGET FUNDING BASED ON
SCHOOLS IDENTIFIED AS LOW
PERFORMING FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT UNDER THE STATE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. AND LIMIT
FUNDING TO SCHOOLS AND WILLING
AT LEAST ELEVEN STUDENTS IN THE
TARGETED EARLY GRADES THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS DURING THE
PERFECT TIME THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SERENATA MORGAN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TO MEET.
WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THESE
PROPOSALS AS THEY RELATE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT STATEWIDE
LITERACY AND BY LITERACY
CAMPAIGN AND MILLION BUCKS
CAMPAIGN TO PROVIDE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WITH ACCESS TO TAX. AS
WELL AS OUR PRE K. TO THIRD
GRADE INITIATIVE. REACHING
LITERACY BY THIRD GRADE HAS LONG
BEEN A GOAL OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS AND KEEP BENCHMARK IN
MEASURING AND PREDICTING STUDENT
SUCCESS. WE MUST TAKE BOLD
ACTION TO HELP STUDENTS MEET
THIS IMPORTANT MILESTONE AND TO
PUT THEM ON THE PATH FOR
LIFELONG LEARNING AND SUCCESS AS
OPPOSED TO A PATH THAT INCREASES
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL
DROP OUT OF SCHOOL OR END UP IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OVER 70% OF INMATES IN AMERICA'S
PRISONS CANNOT READ ABOUT A
FOURTH GRADE LEVEL THAT NEEDS TOSTOP. AND THERE'S NO BETTER TIME
THAN THE PRESENT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON TRANSFORMING. CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. SO STRAW
LETTER ACQUISITION. REQUIRES
BOTH. TO MANY BOOKS AND
THOUGHTFUL. OF LIFE FOR TO BE
MOST. TO THE- CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC AND READABILITY
NEEDS. AND ALSO REQUIRES
EFFECTIVE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
AND SUPPORT. WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH THAT LITERACY COACHING
IS MORE EFFECTIVE AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAININGS OR WORKSHOPS ALONE.
TRULY SUSTAIN TEACHER PRACTICE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING MUST BE
ACTIVE COLLABORATIVE AND PROVIDE
TEACHERS WITH AMPLE TIME TO
LEARN PRACTICE IMPLEMENTED AND
REFLECT ON NEW STRATEGIES. IN
REGARDS TO THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION LITERACY COACHES
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT IS
PLEASED TO SEE A STRONG
INVESTMENT PROPOSED TO EMPLOY
AND TRAIN LITERACY COACHES AND
READING LITERACY SPECIALIST
STATEWIDE. WHICH INCLUDES
DEVELOPING SCHOOL LITERACY
BROWN'S MENTOR TEACHERS AND
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS IN
NEED O TARGETED LITERACY
SUPPORT. WITH THE CURRENT
TEACHER SHORTAGE UP LIFTING NEW
AND EXISTING TEACHER LEADERS IS
IMPORTANT TO RAISING OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. RESEARCH
ALSO SHOWS THAT USE OF COACHES
IS PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE IN
IMPROVING TEACHER PRACTICE AND
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
ESTABLISHING COACHING MODELS ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ONE TIME
WORKSHOPS CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN
TEACHERS AWARENESS OF LITERACY
PRACTICE. BUT ARE INSUFFICIENT
IF THE GOAL IS TO STAINED USE OF
AN EVIDENCE BASED LITERACY
PRACTICE. ALSO COACHING PROVIDES
ONGOING AND SAID FOR TO. THAT
ALLOWS TEACHERS TO PROTECT
SKILLS IN THE- AND RECEIVE
FEEDBACK FROM A COACH. IN
ADDITION TO THE POSITIVE IMPACTS
AND TEACHER INSTRUCTION RESEARCH
HAS FOUND THAT LITERACY COACHING
POSITIVELY INFLUENCES STUDENTS
AND SPECIFICALLY ARE MULTI
LINGUAL LEARNERS ACROSS. WELLS
THE CAPILLARY AND SUBJECT AREA
COMPREHENSION ARE INTEGRATED
INTO THE ARTS. ARE THERE A POINT
MAN CLASSROOM TEACHERS ARE
FEELING THE STRAIN OF
INSTRUCTION ACROSS THE PANDEMIC
AND THE AWARENESS OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
ADULTS HEIGHTENED COACHES ARE
EXPERIENCED EXPERT TEACHERS AND
LITERACY. HOW CAN CAN THEN
PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR OUR
CLASSROOM EDUCATORS ENTER
TEACHER LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUE
TO POSITIVELY INFLUENCE
INSTRUCTION ACROSS SCHOOL
CAMPUSES FOR DIRECT IMPACT TO
STUDENTS. THIS OPPORTUNITY
SUPPORTS THREE PART SHE AREAS
ARE NOT. ONE TEACHERS WHO FEEL
SUPPORTED. AND EMPOWERED BY ARE
MORE LIKELY TO REMAIN ENGAGED IN
THE PROFESSION IMPROVING THOSE
SKILLS AND AFFECT. SECOND
TEACHERS READY TO LEAVE THE
PROFESSION MAY CHOOSE TO STAY IN
EDUCATION AS A COACH KEEP IN
THEIR VALUABLE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE SUPPORTING EDUCATION.
AND THIRD THE MENTORSHIP ASPECT
OF COACHING CAN ALSO HELP
ATTRACT NEW TEACHERS TO THE
PROFESSION WITH A SUPPORTED
SCAFFOLD TREAT THAT COINCIDES
WITH THE EFFORTS TO CREATE A
MORE EFFECTIVE TEACHER PIPELINE
. OUR STATE HAS NEVER LEFT
STABBER LITERACY NOW. WHICH CAN
STEP LOW EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IN
THIS WORK AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ALIGNING THIS INITIATIVE WITH
OUR CURRENT LETTERS THREE
PROJECTS TO INCREASE EXPANDS THE
AND- MOVING TO THE MULTI WILL.
PROPOSAL THIS IS IMPORTANT AS
OUR INCREASE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES CREATE A
SIGNIFICANT NEED TO REFRESH
SCHOOL LIBRARIES. MANY OF WHICH
AVERAGE COPYRIGHT DATE OF TWENTY
YEARS OLD OR OLDER AND ARE NOT
REFLECTIVE OF TODAY'S
DEMOGRAPHICS. POSTED WILL HELP
ENSURE MULTI LINGUAL AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TAX BECOME
ACCESSIBLE TO CHILDREN IN PRE K.
THROUGH THIRD GRADE VS SCHOOL
AND CLASSROOM LIBRARIES PROMOTE
LITERACY AND MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
. MULTI LINGUAL TAX WILL PROMOTE
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION OF
DIVERSE CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
EXPERIENCES AS PART OF LITERACY
IN MULTI LITERACY DEVELOPMENT IN
YOUNG CHILDREN WHEN THE BRAIN IS
MOST RECEPTIVE TO THAT SPENDING
LANGUAGE. THESE RESOURCES ARE
OFTEN THE LEAST ACCESSIBLE AND
HAVE CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS DUE
TO FACTORS SUCH AS HIGH COST.
ACCESS TO THESE TAX WILL PUT
WITHIN REACH CRITICAL LEARNING
RESOURCES FOR EMERGENT
MULTILINGUAL CHILDREN ENJOY
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY ARE LEARNING
ACADEMICS AND DEVELOPING
LANGUAGE IN BOTH ENGLISH AND A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NEARLY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MULTI LINGUAL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
GROWING INTEREST IN EXPANDING
NEEDS WE NEED MORE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY LITERATURE AND
MULTIPLE TAX. MULTILINGUAL
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TAX BENEFIT
LEARNERS AND OTHER WAYS FOR
EXAMPLE SENIOR REPRESENTATION OF
ONESELF IN TAX IS CULTURALLY
AFFIRMING. THEIR HELPING SOCIAL
WELL BEING WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AT A TIME WHEN MENTAL
WELLNESS IS A CRITICAL
CONSIDERATION IN OUR SCHOOLS.
FINALLY SUPPORTING MULTI LINGUAL
LEARNERS DEVELOP STRONGER SKILLS
IN THEIR HOME LANGUAGE IS ALSO
AN EQUITY ISSUE THAT LEADS TO
STRONGER ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION RESEARCH THOSE AT
LITERACY IN A HOME LANGUAGE AN
ONGOING PRACTICE READING AND
WRITING IN THAT LANGUAGE. CAN
MOST READILY FACILITY
ACQUISITION OF LITERACY AND ANY
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE SUCH AS
ENGLISH AS MANY LITERACY SKILLS
CAN BE TRANSFERRED ACROSS
LANGUAGES. IN CLOSING THE
DEPARTMENT GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENT AND LITERACY
COACHES MENTORS AND
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS EAT
UP LITERACY SUPPORT AND ARE
HAPPY TO ALSO SEE THE INVESTMENT
IN MULTI LINGUAL AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT SCHOOL. AND CLASSROOM
LIBRARIES PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. PROCESS MOVES
FORWARD WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON SPECIFIC POINTS RELATED TO
THESE PROPOSALS. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OR EVEN PHONE A
FRIEND TO GET YOU THE
INFORMATION REQUESTED THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM OUR LOCAL SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IF YOU HAD
A DIFFERENT. HEDGE OKAY WITH
HERE IT'S NOT SO WE HAVE TO ONE
FROM CAL FIRST FIVE. STILL LOCAL
. HERE SO THE NOT GETTING MORE-
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M JACK TO HOME
TO DEPUTY FOR FIVE K. AND I'M
THRILLED TO BE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT LETTERS AS SUCH WORKER BY
TRADE SCHOOL WHERE ENOUGH ON
EARLY IN THE SHOW LITERACY IS A
TOP NEAR AND TO MY- AT FIRST
HEALTH UNCLE OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE THAT TO ZERO FIVE. OF THE
SAFEST NURSING RELATIONS AND I'M
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE HEALTHY THE
AND- EARLY LITERACY IS KEY TO
STOP THIS GOAL FROM MY BOOK
READING FROM A CELL SIR CERTAIN
RETURN RESPONSE COMMUNICATE
BETWEEN A YOUNG CHILD AND I.
CREATE AN OPTION NURSING IN AND
WE'RE READING. MEETING CAN A
PART A DAILY ROUTINE THAT
PROVIDE THE BILL FOR EACH. COULD
AN OPTION FOR BOND AND- CALL
SKILLS. TO TRULY PER CHILL FOR
CAL FUTURE AND REDUCE
ACHIEVEMENT. A SOLID FUNDING FOR
EARLY LEADERS SKILLS BUSINESS.
WE SHOWS THAT THE ROOTS OF THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP START LONG
BEFORE. CHILDREN ENTER. A MAJOR
INDICATOR LEADERS. SUCCESS LANG
AND LITERACY TO. DISPARITIES AND
EARLY. BOTH BETWEEN CHILDREN
FROM SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS
HIGHER INCOME FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
SHOWN IN CHILDREN AS EARLY AS
SIXTEEN MONTHS OF AGE. SEVEN
BOOKS IN THE HOME AND BEING
TALKED READ THE SAME TO IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR HER TO
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND FOR
FAMILIES FROM COUNTRIES OUTSIDE
THE UNITED STATES THOSE CHILDREN
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE READ OR
SOME TOO SO IT'S EVEN MORE
CRITICAL TO GET BOOKS AND EARLY
LITERACY TIPS. INTO THE HOME.
READING ALSO WAS THE TYPE OF NO
AND- THAT ARE BENEFICIAL BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS. AS WE KNOW
ALL TOO WELL THE CODE NINETEEN
AND THEN BECAUSE FRONT ISOLATION
AND EXTREME STRESS CHOI CHILDREN
FAMILIES. WE SERVE EARLY
LITERACY AN AND STRETCH TO
AMELIORATE THIS HELPING BOND.
CREATING NURTURING SPACES AND
MOMENTS PARA AND CHILD AND
PROVIDING MEDICAID. AGAINST HAD
CHILD EXPERIENCE. WE ARE. BY THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN EARLIER
STAGE AND THE DISTRIBUTION AND
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. EXCITED TO
BE A PROP PARTNER IN THIS WORK
TO PROVIDE. LINGUAL AND A LIVE
THERE'S A- IN. FOR FAMILIES
YOUNG IN CLASS. WITH OTHER
STATES PROGRAMS. SUCH AS HOME
VISITING CARE AND FOSTER CARE.
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL HAVE THE OP
TO BUILDING A ON INCREASE
INVESTMENTS HOME VISIT AND OTHER
. LIKE THE BLACK INFANT HEALTH
PROGRAM AND CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TO MAXIMIZE IMPACT OUR
YOUNGEST AND MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. BUT WHAT I'LL STOP
THERE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WHEN THE TIME'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU I'M. ALSO HAPPY TO
CALL A FRIEND IF IT'S NOT ME.
OKAY THANK. THANK YOU JACKSON-
YES THE I BRING BACK A SERRA NOW
MORGAN. SO IT WON'T BRING YOU
BACK UNTIL YOU SAY SOMETHING
FIFTY JUST A I'M HERE THEY'RE
NEVER MARKETING DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OKAY WELL I WANT TO
BRING YOU BACK TO GIVE YOU THE
AWARD FOR THE BEST BACKDROP
TODAY NUMBER ONE. YES I WOULD I
JUST WISH THAT MY TEENAGE GIRLS
HAD ROOMS AS ORGANIZED AS YOUR
DAUGHTER SO- GIVE US GIVE ME
SOME TIPS LATER ON BUT I WANT
WANTED TO REALLY ASK YOU- TO
FOCUS ON HOW DOES I KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THE- FBI HAS- SOME
IDEAS AND SUPPORT. AND SUPPORTS-
CALIFORNIA STEPPING UP OUR GAME
FOR EARLY LITERACY AND THERE'S
SOME LEGISLATION BY SUMMER BONTA
. HOW DOES THIS RELATE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND BEFORE
YOU ANSWER THAT. IS THE I'M I'M
ALL IN IN SUPPORT OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TO ADDRESS. EARLY
LITERACY WE ALL KNOW THE
RESEARCH THE JANET TALKED ABOUT-
AT THE AT THE ENTRY LEVEL FOR
KINDERGARTEN KINDERGARTEN
READINESS THE WORD GAP THIS IS
WHY IT'S A BIG SUPPORTER OF
EARLY. EDUCATION I DO HAVE SOME
YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
THIS AND BE SERIOUS ABOUT IT YOU
WOULD WANT TO HAVE ONGOING MONEY
CAN'T HIRE PEOPLE AND- HAVE THIS
IN PERPETUITY WITH ONE TIMES
WITH A DEAL WITH THAT. BUT BUT I
GUESS I BACK TO YOU AS SARAH.
HOW DOES THIS JIVE WITH WHAT THE
S. P. I. IS LOOKING AT WITH OUR
LEGISLATION AND WHAT WE HAVE
HERE IN THE BUDGET FROM THE
GOVERNOR. YES SO I. IN RELATION
TO THAT THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
. REALLY ON THAT WE CANNOT THIRD
GRADE AS WELL. INCLUDING THE
PORTS BURKE FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. SO A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO LET JACQUI WAS SPEAKING TO
YOU. AND NOT ALL CHILDHOOD
FAMILY IS BEING. EXHORT ARE OF
THE EDUCATIONAL. AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE ALIGN THEIR- BUT HE WILL
SAY A LOT OF SENSE AT THE
DIFFERENT PROPOSED REALLY DOES A
WAY. IN THAT EARLY FOLK. AND AS
WELL AS THE FOLK ON. AND
SOMEBODY PRACTICE SAYS SO I
THINK THIS. FOR IN HERE- MAYBE
GO BEYOND STOMACH. BUT WHAT DOES
IT MEAN. IS PREPARED IS COR AND
AS FOUND. SUPPORT IN THEIR. AND
HOW WITH THIS RELATE TO WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA PROPOSING IN
LEGISLATION WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. SO WITHOUT BONTA
ABOUT THOSE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SOME KEY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S HOUSE FORCE
AND NOT THERE WOULD BE SOME
MONEY FOR OUR AND LIAISE TO
SUPPORT A HOME LITERACY PLAN
SEVEN CREATING THOSE CONNECTIONS
BACK AND FORTH WITH HOME AND
STEM HOME VISITOR PIECES WELL.
AND WILL RAISE ON COME UP AT BUT
THERE WAS A VERY CRITICAL IN NOT
CAN ALONG AS EDUCATE. AND THAT
LINK THAT OVER INTO WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN THE WILL BE THERE'S
ALSO SOME WITH THE PROMISE
HORACE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING SO
. OUT WITH THAT AND COMMUNITY
AROUND NOT AND THEN EXTENDED
DAYS WEEKEND FAMILY INSTEAD FOR
SO A LOT FOCUSED ON THE FOR
KNOWING THAT THE BILL OFF OF
THESE AND FAST. INTO USE LIBRARY
AND SCHOOL RESOURCE AS AS WELL
AS THIS FOR. KNOWING NOT TO FOR.
LEARN AND WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
CLASS MEANS WE NEED TO REALLY
FOCUS UP LEFT TEACHER. SO I
WOULD SAY OR THE ENGAGE AND THIS
ENGAGE. OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN
BACK TO- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CAN YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF-
ONE TIME MONEY. FOR THE FOR
THESE INTERVENTIONS AND LITERACY
COACHING THE I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
BUT HOW DO YOU DO THAT. AND HIRE
PEOPLE. IF YOU THE YOU KNOW HE
THE LIMITED TERM HAVE YOU BRING
IN KEEP THEM IN THERE FOR A LONG
RUN. I SAID THIS IS. A SHOW IN
THE ABOUT NOTHING I CAN THIS
QUIZ- SO FOR LITERACY COACH
PROPOSED. SPECIFICALLY ON THE
RANK. OUTLINED THAT THE FOR WILL
BE A THREE. I BECAUSE RIGHT DO
ENVISION THAT AS IT'LL TAKE
MAPPING AND- YOU DO NEED AT I'M
FUNDING FOR. STAFF WE ALL. APART
FROM THE OTHERS YOU CAN FUNDING
. THIS YEAR AS PART OF THE- P.
FUNDING WE ALSO. THAT YOU COULD
AT ELEAZER GOALS USE. THAT I'M
GOING FIND FOR LETTERS COACH AS
AND SO WE DO TO KEEP AN EYE
THAT- YOU KNOW WE WANT THESE
LITERACY CO. TO BE FOR AWAY. AND
TO BE A KIND OF. SUPPORT IN
SCHOOLS IN SO THE FIND. THERE IS
MORE FUN THAT IS ONGOING. OKAY
THANK YOU AYE AYE WE MAY HAVE
SOME OTHER IDEAS ON THAT SPREAD
OUT OVER. A NUMBER OF YEARS
BECAUSE OF IT IS ONLY THREE
YEARS AND YOUR FIRST. PART IS
START AT- WHO'S GOING TO WANT TO
TAKE A JOB. FOR YOURSELF. VIEW
ENDS AND STUFF. I THINK WE'LL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT. THAT
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE SURE TO WE
COORDINATE THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT. AND THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL A BIT MORE WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE. OPEN AND
WE WILL GO TO THE LAST ISSUE.
I'M SORRY MR MEDINA IS NOT HERE
TODAY BECAUSE HE'D BE REALLY
EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF CURRICULA. ESPECIALLY HOW IT
RELATES TO- ETHNIC STUDIES.
IMPLEMENTATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L. A.
O. DEPARTMENT OF IT. YES HELLO
AGAIN MICHELLE LEGAL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE AGENDA
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL SO I WILL GO INTO A BIT
MORE DETAIL. I'M FOR THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO MODEL
CURRICULA THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT TO SUPPORT THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
DEVELOPING THE FORMADA CURRICULA
AS MANDATED BY STATUTE. SO THAT
IS IT MEANS AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE NOT A CURRICULUM THAT
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MODEL
CURRICULUM THE CURRICULUM ONLINE
HISTORY CULTURAL STUDIES AND THE
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM. THIS FUNDING IS TO
BUILD UPON THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT FOR
THE VARIOUS CURRICULA- WE ARE
PROPOSING EVEN FOUR WAY SPLIT A
FUNDING SO A TOTAL OF ABOUT.
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH MODEL
CURRICULUM WE SEE THIS AS BEING
VERY REASONABLE GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT WORK THAT WE ARE
ASKING- COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO DO AND DEVELOPING
THE CURRICULUM INCLUDING
RESOURCES AND LESSON PLANS- AS
WELL AS PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR THESE COMPLICATED SUBJECTS-
AND THEN ALSO A PART OF THAT
AGENDA. OUT FOR THE EXTRA
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS INCLUDES A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND TO COMPLETE THE
MATH CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK AND
NINETY SIX THOUSAND FOR OVERALL
I DO SEE CLASS- AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION MY
COLLEAGUE AMBER ALEXANDER. IS
ALSO ON THE LINE AND WE'LL BOTH
AVAILABLE ANSWER QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE. TIME THANK YOU
. OKAY THANK YOU. L. L. ANYWAY
WITH THE L. A. AGAIN ON THE
GOVERNOR'S FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR- MODEL CURRICULA PROPOSAL
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
APPROVE A REDUCED FUNDING AMOUNT
I NEED THIS CALCULATION OF FORTY
MILLION WAS BASED ON A ASSED
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH INCLUDED
REGIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT- WHICH WOULD BE A
MORE COSTLY ACTIVITY THANK
CONTRAST THE MODEL CURRICULA
ACTIVITIES WOULD NOT REQUIRE
REGIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BUT RATHER TO
DEVELOPMENT OF TRAINING
MATERIALS FOR THIS REASON WE
THINK MODEL CURRICULA
DEVELOPMENT COULD COST LESS THAN
THE PROPOSED FOURTEEN MILLION.
IN AN ALTERNATE ANALYSIS WE
ESTIMATED THE TOTAL COST TO BE
AROUND FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
APPROVING THE PROPOSED AMOUNT
HOWEVER HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND
ADDING A GREATER LEVEL OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT INCLUDING
REQUIRING THE SELECTED SEELEY'S
TO SUBMIT AN ANNUAL EXPENDITURE
PLAN TO FINANCE AND THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WORK SPECIFYING IN TRAILER
LEGISLATION ANY ADDITIONAL
EXPECTATIONS ON THE PROPOSED
FINDING I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE- TIME THANK YOU
OKAY THANK. YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR VERSUS COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHERYL CAUGHT THAT HE- OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION CALIFORNIA.
OF EDUCATION I'M SPEAKING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. WE
ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN MODEL CURRICULA
RELATED TO. THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN REFUGEE EXPERIENCE THE
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE. AMONG
HISTORY AND CULTURAL STUDIES AND
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES. THESE
FUNDS ARE IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS WITH CONTRA COBB I'M
SORRY WITH COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
FEES FOR MODEL CURRICULA. I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE DR MIKE TORRES
DIRECTOR COOKING FRAMEWORKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
AT CD EIGHT. TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON MY TATIAN OF THESE
MODEL CURRICULA MIKE. THANK YOU
DEPUTY SUPER CON. GOOD MORNING
MRCHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY TAURUS. AT THE CD
WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO CREATE A
STREAMLINED PROCESS CALLED A
REQUEST FOR CONSIDERATION OR
RFC. THIS PROCESS PROVIDED THE
EFFICIENCY THAT WAS NECESSARY TO
MEET THE TIGHT TIMELINES FOR
ENTERING INTO THESE FOR
CONTRACTS. THE PROCESS PROVIDED
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT AND
EXPLAIN THEIR PLAN TO INCLUDE
STATEWIDE ENGAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. CURRICULUM
EXPERTS THEY WOULD BRING INTO
THE PROJECT AND THEIR PLANT TO
DEVELOP THESE MODEL CURRICULA.
WHEN REVIEWING THE R. F. C.
SUBMISSION SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
WAS GIVEN TO EACH OF THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ABILITY AND
BANDWIDTH TO FACILITATE THIS
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT STATEWIDE.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER PASSAGE OF AB
ONE SIXTY SEVEN LAST FALL THE CD
CONSULTED WITH THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. AND BEGAN
IMPLEMENTING THE RSC PROCESS IN
OCTOBER AND BEGAN ACCEPTING
SUBMISSIONS IN NOVEMBER.
EVALUATIONS OF THE SUBMISSIONS
TOOK PLACE THEN IN DECEMBER. THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WAS SELECTED TO
DEVELOP THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
REFUGEE EXPERIENCE MODEL
CURRICULUM. THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MODEL CURRICULUM AND
THE MODERN HISTORY AND CULTURAL
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM. SINCE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL BE LEADING THESE
THREE THEY ARE BEING ASKED TO
SUBCONTRACT WITH THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. TO
ENSURE BROADSHEET. RADICAL
REPRESENTATION. DO YOU COUNTY
OFF OF A- WERE SELECT TO ENTER
INTO CONTRACT TO DEVELOP A
SINGLE NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM. KNOWS TO
EDUCATION ARE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THE CITY IS CURRENTLY
WORKING ON FINALIZING THE SCOPES
OF WORK AND BUDGETS TO FINALIZE
EACH OF THESE CONTRACTS. TO
REVIEW AND VET THE WORK OF THE
COUNTY OFFICES AND ENSURE
SUFFICIENT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND THEIR PROCESS IS. A
STATEWIDE MODEL CURRICULUM
COORDINATING COUNCIL WILL BE
ESTABLISHED IN WEST ED WILL BE
CONTRACTED TO CONVENE THIS
GROUP. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ALSO UPDATE YOU ON THE
PROGRESS OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
IMPLEMENTATION. THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INCLUDED TWO
SETS OF FUNDS FOR THE SUPPORT TO
THIS EFFORT. THE FIRST IS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTRACT WITH
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
OR CONSORTIUM OF COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
REGIONAL TRAINING FOR TEACHERS.
ADMINISTRATORS AND PARA
PROFESSIONALS TO SUPPORT
CREATION OR EXPANSION OF ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE OFFERINGS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FORCES THAT USE THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM. FUNDS
WILL ALSO BE USED TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO AN ONLINE REPOSITORY
OF RESOURCES TO SUPPORT ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES. THIS INCLUDES
THE COLLECTION AND REVIEW OF
MATERIALS TO BE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR EDUCATORS TO USE IN
IMPLEMENTING THE ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM. THE SECOND
EFFORT WAS THE APPROPRIATION OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDS TO ELEAZAR TO SUPPORT
THE CREATION OR EXPANSION OF
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE OFFERINGS.
THE CD WILL POST L. A.
ALLOCATIONS BY EARLY MARCH AN
ELDERLY NEEDS WILL RECEIVE THESE
FUNDS BY MID APRIL. I'M HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THAT TESTIMONY THE ONLY
QUESTION I HAVE IS EITHER FOR.
OR ANYBODY DEPARTMENT OF AT THAT
L. A. OR OR- FINANCE. WE ARE
VERY- EXCITED ABOUT LAST YEAR'S-
LEGISLATIVE VICTORY. AND HAVING
ETHNIC STUDIES AS A REQUIREMENT
FOR ALL OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS ARE ONLY DISAPPOINTMENT
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE. TO THE
END OF THE DECADE BEFORE IT'S
REQUIREMENTS BUT- BY MID DECADE
SCHOOLS WILL HAVE TO START
REQUIRING IT. LAST YEAR WE DID
PUT- MONEY IN THE BUDGET FIFTY
ONE FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME. TO
LAUNCH THIS WORK AND DO WE
THINK. THAT THAT'S THE ADEQUATE
AMOUNT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL. ETHNIC
STUDIES- REQUIREMENT FOR HIGH
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
IS- CONTINGENT ON AN
APPROPRIATION- TO DATE AND
APPROPRIATIONS SPECIFIC TO THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT HAS HAS NOT BEEN
MADE THEY- THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT. I'M THAT ARE
REFERENCED IN THE AGENDA AND
THAT YOU REFERENCED IN YOUR
COMMENT- AGAIN WAS ONE TIME
FUNDING AND THAT FUNDING WAS
SPECIFIC TO THE CREATION OR
EXPANSION OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
COURSES IT WAS NOT TIED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GRADUATION
MANDATE ITSELF NOR DOES FINANCE
BELIEVE THAT FIFTY MILLION WOULD
BE SUFFICIENT SHOULD THAT
MANDATE I'M PROGRESS. OKAY
DEPARTMENT OF ED DO WE THINK I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE SOME DEBATE
ABOUT THAT AND I'M NOT SURE WHY
YOU NEED. AND APPROPRIATION
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THAT
CLASS TAUGHT IN THE HIGH SCHOOL
ANYWAY. YOU HAVE A TEACHER
TEACHING THAT CLASS AS OPPOSED
TO ANOTHER CLASS. AND STILL JUST
YOU KNOW SIMPLE MATHEMATICS I
DON'T QUITE GET IT BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. DO WE THINK THAT WE
NEED AND ANY OTHER RESOURCES- ON
THE LEAD UP TO. THE ETHNIC
STUDIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT MY TAURUS- SO YES
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
IMPLEMENTING THE COURSES UNTIL
ONE MORNING CURRENT- TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIXTEEN GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. AND DOESN'T TAKE
EFFECT UNTIL THE TWENTY NINE
THIRTY HI THIS SCHOOL YEAR-
HEARING OUT FOR THIS REQUIREMENT
IS LIKELY TO BE A MULTI YEAR
PROCESS WITH COSTS- EXCEEDING.
EXCEEDING FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
STATEWIDE FOR AT LEAST TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. OKAY.
WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN AS
WELL- NOTRE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE HERE RIGHT NOW TO ENGAGE-
WITH US SO WITH THAT THAT THAT
THE THAT'S THE CONCLUSION OF THE
AGENDA AS ITEMS NOW WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT. GIVE NO ONE HERE
IN THE AUDIENCE- WE DO HAVE THE
OPTION OF PEOPLE TO CALL IN
AGAIN IF YOU ANOTHER NUMBER IT'S
ON THE AGENDA IT'S.
1-877-692-8957. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE TREE
ONE. FIFTY ONE TWENTY SIX. YES
AND THIS KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS ONE MINUTE
OR LESS. WOULD YOU HAVE ONE
PERSON HERE IN PERSON GO AHEAD
SIR. MARK ABSTAINED CALIFORNIAN
FUNDAMENTAL TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
NETWORK- AS FAR AS ON THE
CURRICULUM NEW CURRICULA LOCKED
WHAT I HEAR FROM A LOT OF
TEACHERS IS THAT THERE'S MORE OF
ANY NOT SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CURRICULUM. BUT HELP IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND AS
FAR AS IN DELIVERY PARTICULARLY
USING A MERGING DIGITAL TOOLS
THE LAST MEETING THAT I WAS OUT
FOR THIS COMMITTEE THAT THERE
WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION OF
ENGAGEMENT AND- DEALING WITH
ATTENDANCE. AND THERE'S BEEN
SOME STUDIES AS FAR AS DEALING
WITH HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
THEIR THEIR PERCEPTIONS. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE COME OUT
FROM THE DATA THAT- HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE INCREASINGLY GET
HAVING PERCEPTION THAT WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING IN HIGH SCHOOL
IS NOT RELEVANT TO MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THEIR SPOTS FUTURE. AND
WHEN YOU DO GET A LITTLE BIT ON
THAT WITH A LITTLE BIT OF FOLLOW
UP IN QUESTIONS A LOT OF IT
RELATES TO. THE LACK OF DIGITAL
SKILL SETS OF THEIR TEACHERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- NOW WILL
GO TO COMMENTS ON THE PHONE DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE
OPERATOR. YES WE DO OUR AND
GENTLEMEN THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
DO WISH TO I MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. EIGHTEEN T. T. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR OF MIND NUMBER
OFFLINE QUICKLY AND THEN PLACE
IT BACK IN THE QUEUE SO AGAIN
FOR OUR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND MISTER
ARCHER WILL BEGIN APPLYING
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO. AS CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE APP OF
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION- WOULD FIRST NOTE
THAT WE AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF DONALD CONCERNS AROUND
THE L. O. P. PROPOSAL BUT- WOULD
LIKE TO DIRECT MY COMMENTS
CLOSELY TOWARDS THE- COMMENTS
MADE ABOUT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM- FIRST ON
LIKE SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT GUARANTEED
PUBLIC FACILITIES WHICH RESULT
IN THE NEED TO LEAST PRIVATELY
ON SPACES. THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAMS THE
LEAST REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION AT TRI
VALLEYTHAT WAS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WAS RELATED TO BOND
ISSUANCE AND WAS NOT PART OF THE
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM- THIS
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY RATHER WAS
RELATED TO A CLOSE CHARTER
SCHOOL THE DEFAULTED ON
PRIVATELY ISSUED BONDS- THE
ISSUES RAISED ALTHOUGH IT NOR
THE FACT THAT EXAMPLES LIKE TRI
VALLEY TRIGGERED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN STATE CHARTER SCHOOL
LAW IN TWENTY NINETEEN UNDER SB
ONE TWENTY SIX AND EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH FIVE. WHICH PERFORM
TECHNICAL GOVERNANCE AND
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LAWS TO
PREVENT THAT WHAT OCCURRED AT
TRI VALLEY THE ADMINISTRATION
ALSO ADOPTED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
THE BUDGET TO FURTHER STRENGTHEN
THE OVERSIGHT OF THIS IMPORTANT
CHARTER- FACILITY PROGRAM-
THERE'S NO PARITY WHEN IT COMES
TO ADEQUATE FACILITIES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS. CONTINUE TO BE ONE OF
OUR LARGE CHALLENGES THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
SIXTY SECONDS REMAINING THE
FIRST ONE GO OVER WAS IT-
PREPARING EVERYBODY FOR THE
RULES. SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS
PLEASE THANK YOU. I'LL WE WILL
TO MY NINETEEN GOING. EIGHTEEN
HELLO YEAH MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
BRITNEY MARC ON BEHALF YET HERE
YOU KNOW AND AT AND CLASSIFY
BURKE. IF YOU COMMITTED
PROMOTING QUALITY AND TO THE
CONDITIONS YEAH TO PUT THE
SERVICE TO HELP GETTING IN THE
ENDEAVOR WE WANT TO ABLE
WORKFORCE AS OF NECESSITY FOR
OUR AT. AND TO DO SO WE LIKE TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
COULD FUNDING FOR CAN SURE
COMPENSATION FOR THIS WORKFORCE
CAN BE. RECRUITED RETAINED AND
CREATE A STABLE WORK. SAFETY OF
SUPPORT CARRILLO BUSES TO ENSURE
THE CONDITION ARE NOT THE TO
PROVIDE YOUR- FOR. THE WILL
CREATE STABLE FUTURE AND- THE
OUTCOME LINKED HIGHER AND YOU.
OUTCOMES THANK YOU SO. MEMBERS
THANK YOU. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
TWENTY YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU
DOWNLOAD WITH A CALIFORNIANS
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE
HAPPY IS EATING AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
ELECTRIC BUSES. ALTHOUGH BRING
ARQUEBUS THE IT'S AND WE ALSO
MORNING STATE THAT WE HAVE TO
LONG AT A LONGSTANDING UNDEFINED
PROBLEM OUR SCHOOLS. PROGRAM WE
NEED A SOLUTION THAT WORKS.
REFORM THE PROGRAM BY ADEQUATELY
FOR DIDN'T TRANSFER NEEDS AND AT
. APPORTION FUNDS TO SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NECK BAKER
. WE WILL LINE TWENTY SO YOU ARE
ALL. THANK YOU KIMBERLY REMEMBER
WHAT SEIU- WHEN THEY COME TO
EITHER AFTERSCHOOL WITH WANT
LINER CA THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
AND MCCARTY WE DO THAT THIS WILL
BECOME MADE LAST YEAR'S AND VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE CAN WITH-
THE BILL THE FOR SCHOOL GALOPIN
AND MEANING WAY AND WE WOULD ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
THE NAME SO THAT WE CAN MAKE.
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENT IN IN
HOUSE STAFFING IN EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM BUT IT'S A SAID IN DO IN
A WAY THAT IS- A RELIABLE COUPLE
PARENTS AND- THE SCHOOL THEM. SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO MAYBE TINKER
WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN MY LIFE
YEAR WALLICH WE ALSO WANT
EXPRESS OUR- IN THE COOLEY TRASH
INVEST AND ADD THE CLEANING BUT
WE WOULD- URGE OTHER ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERING. FOR MAKING SURE
THAT ALL OF THE STAFF AS PART OF
TO A PROPER NEED THAT THEY CAN
RETAIN THEIR- EXISTING AND WORK
ON THE NEED- OTHER THAN THAT WE
ALARMCOM TO THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS THAT HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED FOR WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION IMPACT. THANK YOU
BAKER PLEASE. WE WERE LYING TO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HARD
OF WHAT THE HELL T. THAT THAT.
PTA THE LEARNING AND RICK FOR
HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE
GOING. TO IN A LEARNING IS
LARGER THAN INCREASE IN THE L.
FAST AND YOU CAN'T BELIEVE THE
STATE SHOULD PRIORITIZE ONGOING
FUNDING TO FULLY BY OUR-
PROGRAMMATIC NEED THE FOR.
SIGNIFICANT EXPAND NEW PROBE AND
SPECIAL IF WILL EIGHTEEN
STAFFING SHORTAGE AND EMPLOYMENT
TO- AND DETAILS WITH THE
MAINTAINING THE CAN TO PUT A-
SCHOOL MEALS AND SUPPORT THEM IN
KITCHEN AND FISHER- AND ALSO
THERE THANK. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THIRTY THREE
PLEASE AHEAD MISS CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PLAN TOOK A AFTER ENVOY
WE HAVE A LEADING AND CAL. OUR
MORE THAN 50% OF STUDENTS NOT AT
PROFESSION AND SOME OF THE
LARGEST READING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
. HE'S READING SCORES AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE NAY AND HOW BEEN
FOR YOU. THE LAST MATCH DATA
COULD SHUTTLE PAGE DID RAN FOR
THE FIRST READING AND NINE. HI
ON. TO DISCUSS AND THAT'S WHAT.
IN OUR SCHOOL. HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS OF CAL STUDENTS ON THE
DISLIKES SPECTRUM STRUGGLE EVERY
DAY WITH MEETING AT GRADE LEVEL
OFTEN WITHOUT PROPER
IDENTIFICATION AND SUPPORT. AND
THE BUDGET INCLUDESFUNDING FOR
THE UCSF DYSLEXIA CENTER WHICH
IS DEVELOPING A SCREENING OUT
FOR DYSLEXIA THAT'S YET TO BE
VALIDATED. NOW THIS POT WHILE
THIS IS POSITIVE AND KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY LOCAL I.
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL INCH
INSTRUMENTS AVAILABLE NOW. OTHER
STATES HAVE USING FOR YEARS. SO
FOR SERIOUS ABOUT IT. THE
READING FOR. WE SHOULD BE
MANDATE UNITS OR SCREENING RISK
THIS I. THIS A STATEWIDE POTS.
OF UNIVERSE SCREENING IN PORT
STEP. ELIMINATING INEQUITIES OF
. AND CAN PUBLIC SCHOOL. WITHOUT
SCREEN MANY STUDENTS TRACKING.
WILL NOT BE A- AS BEING AT RISK
OF RECEIVED APPROPRIATE ANSWER.
IN SUPPORTING TO REACH THEIR
FULL FOCUS. SUCH A LOCAL AND
THAT THAT WILL SIGNAL. REDUCE
COSTS TO SCHOOLS AND FROM AFTER
FROM. IN SUPPORT SERVER OF YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. OF. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. BOOMING
ONLINE VOTER THIRD SEVEN YOU ARE
ALL. MISTER CHAIR SPEAK. ARE
GEARING. ONE OF SURE YOU CAN
HEAR ME- DOES NOT FEATURE
SUBPOENA WHAT WE HAVE TO CALL
THE FOR OTHER SCHOOL WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE SUPPORT LA
OVER WORKERS TO TRY TO FOCUS ON
ON UNIVERSAL NIELSEN REVISITS
SCRATCH COULD LATER- TO FOCUS
FUNDING ON AT LEAST DO NOT HAVE
LOW FREED REDUCED PRICE MEAL CAL
. COUNTER INTUITIVE THEY HAVE
HIGHER NEED FOR PERSONAL
ANDERSON WE ASK THAT YOU TO
REDUCE THE APPROACH FOR
NUTRITION THE MANDATE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANT. THERE IS AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF NEED AND AUGMENT OF
THE C. TO NAME MEANINGFUL
COMMITTEE OF THE B. R. CHOIR IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME WILL DIRECT
YOU TO BUDGET THAT WE LAW WEEK
WITH HER FOR OUR CALL ON TRY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. I LIKE TO EIGHT GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING THIS ETCETERA CAL
TOGETHER ALSO BEHALF THE K.
ASSOCIATION COMBINING I DO-
AGAIN YEAR THE A. L. BUT NEVER
PROGRAMS EDUCATION BILL DO NOT
HAVE AN RESOURCES TO ACHIEVE
THAT THE GOAL. INCLUDED IT THANK
A LACK OF TRANSLATION OF ANIMAL
BY WILL BE THE ARE SOME
IMPORTANT THAT FLOW AND LOW
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ISSUE.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR REGARDING
THAT REGARD AN INCH ENGLISH
LEARNERS EDIBLE ACT DURING.
LEARNING PER OF ALL OF THAT
DISCUSS REGARDING THE MOST
LINGUAL LIBRARY. IN ORDER TO
CONSIDER A THE MORE TELL TECH
ALL BE AVAILABLE AND OTHER THAN
ENGLISH PROVIDE YOU THREE OF NOT
. TO ALL TO HAVE TO COME IS NOT
ENGLISH. FINALLY WE ASK THAT
THAT THE BY LITERACY COURSE
ISN'T ARE INCLUDED AND
INCORPORATED AS A MANDATORY AND
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE EARLY
LITERACY BLOCK. WHICH WOULD BE
TREMENDOUS RESOURCES BURKE
FAMILY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. AND FORTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WOULD
SPEND TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF CAT TAYLOR TOM CAT
RANCH AND THE SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL COALITION ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND HAPPINESS SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL PROGRAM LAST YEAR.
WE SUPPORT THIS YEAR'S CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET PROPONENT
TUITION INCLUDING FULLY FUNDING
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO STRENGTHEN
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA FARMERS
WHILE PROVIDING SCHOOL NUTRITION
STAFF THE TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED TO SERVE MEALS THAT
ARE THE BEST THEY CAN BE FOR OUR
STUDENTS OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
pTHIS ITEM OPEN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THE HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOLS FOOD SERVICE
PROGRAMS HAVE PROPER STAFFING
TRAINING AND RESOURCES TO SERVE
MORE FRESHLY PREPARED NUTRITIOUS
MEALS TO HUNGRY STUDENTS ALL OF
THE CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
DIFFICULT TIME TO CONTINUE
SERVING FOR MAIL TO ALL SERVICE
YOU CAN PERMANENTLY BUT IS ALSO
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT. TIME
TO DO THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURDEN
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CAITLYN FILE ITEM NUMBER
ALR KADAM THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WHICH IS THE CHARTER SCHOOL
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SB SEVEN FORTY.
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM SB SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
SCHOOL BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED WHICH IS HAD VERY
REAL IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS. ON
THE PROGRAM FALL SHORT ALL
SCHOOLS GET THEIR FUNDING CUTS
AND WE MUST DIVERT FUNDING FROM
CORPORATE GRANTS TO COVER THE
FACILITY SCOTT. ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE FACILITIES CONTINUES TO
BE A PRIMARY CHALLENGE FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS. SB SEVEN FORTY
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
SUPPORTING SCHOOLS LIKE OURS AND
HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS PROPOSED AN INCREASE TO
ADDRESS. CHRONIC FUNDING
SHORTFALLS IN THIS PROGRAM AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANKS BAKER PLEASE.
PINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE RETURN OF THE TEAM THAT I
NEEDED NOT TO- ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW ISSUE NUMBER ONE
NOW WE SUPPORT THE L. A. OTRA
COMMUNICATION TO ALLOW
FLEXIBILITY FOR ONE TIME FUNDS
PROPOSED THE BEST MEET LOCAL
NEEDS WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
EXPANDED LEARNING AND
STRENGTHENING DISTRICT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WE'D LIKE TO LINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF CAL
POLY IN CALIFORNIA CURRENT. AND
COPY WE APPRECIATE THE L. A. AS
ASSESSMENT ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS
THE L. AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
GREATEST NEED HAVE TO CREATE A
TAX TO THE PROGRAM ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR ON THE LEADER PROPOSALS
SUPPORTED. COMMITMENT TO WHAT
HAILING WILL LEVERAGE AND EARLY
. WE WOULD LIKE INSURE- THAT WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH ALEJO
COMMENTS- THAT WE NEED EDUCATORS
PROPERLY TRAINED WITH SUFFICIENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN PROPERLY
SUPPORT OUR ENGLISH LEARNER INTO
A LANGUAGE LIKE OUR STUDENTS WE
AGREE THAT REPRESENTATION
MATTERS BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UPDATE OUR LIBRARIES THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR AND
WE DO WORK ON WORKFORCE. REPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WEEK PLEASE
THANK YOU. WE WILL RELY THIRTY
YOU OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNA
LOVE ARE AND I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SIGNATURE SHOULD
SERVE FOR SEPARATE YOU KNOW
SCHOOL. AND THE PUBLIC POLICY
AND LEGISLATIVE CULTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL MATURE SHARED
DESCRIPTION ASSOCIATION I'VE HAD
THE HONOR OF WORKING IN THE
FIELDS TO NUTRITION FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. EACH DAY OUR
DEDICATED TEAM IN SAN FRANCISCO
PROVIDES OVER FORTY THOUSAND
MEALS TO HUNGRY STUDENTS WE
STRIVE TO PROVIDE FOOD THAT IS
HEALTHY CULTURALLY DIVERSE
AFFORDABLE CARE SUSTAINABLE AND
BY BY STUDENT OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
KITCHEN FACILITIES TO STORE
PREPARE AND SERVE THE FRESHEST
LOCAL HIGH QUALITY NUTRITIOUS
FOOD BUT OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OFFERS. THE TIME IS NOW FOR THE
STATE TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
GRADUATION PROFESSIONAL AND THE
SCHOOL CRIMINAL FRAUD PROGRAM IN
NURSING STUDENTS WITH FRESH
LOCAL SCHOOL MEALS PLEASE PUT
SUPPORTERS IN PROVIDING THE BEST
POSSIBLE MELTED FUEL OUR
STUDENTS GROWTH AND. LEARNING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PUT. THANKS TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE AND I'M A SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF THE SO FOR THE
OAKLEY UNIFIED DISTRICT AND
PREVIOUSLY I WAS A NEW SERVICE
DIRECTOR FOR PALM SPRINGS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT MY
TWENTY THREE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN SCHOOL NUTRITION HAS SHOWN ME
THAT SCHOOLS ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO NOURISH HUNGRY CHILDREN WITH
FRESH LOCAL SCHOOL MEALS THE
MISSING INGREDIENT IS FUNDING
OUR AGING AND OFTENTIMES AN
ADEQUATE SCHOOL KITCHENS. BY
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL FARMERS MY DISTRICT CAN
BRING IN LOCAL CALIFORNIA FOOD
PREPARE NOURISHING MEALS AND BE
MORE RESILIENT TO SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES SUPPORT FOR KIDS KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING AND THE
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL PROGRAM
WILL ENSURE OUR NEXT GENERATION
OF STUDENTS ARE THRIVING AND
SUCCESSFUL NOW IS THE TIME FOR
THE STATE TO SUPPORT THESE
CONNECTIONS AND I ALSO CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUES JENNIFER
LEBAR IN SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. THAT WILL BE LINE FORTY
TWO YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREA BALL ON
THE HALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS COUNTY
OFFICES IN SIX COUNTIES OVER
HUNDRED ELEAZAR SERVING FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS.
SPEAKING TODAY ON ISSUE THREE
SPECIFICALLY TRANSPORTATION BUT
THE CRITICAL ISSUE FOR THIS PART
OF THE STATE WHERE OFTEN HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION IS THE
ONLY OPTION FOR STUDENTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO GET A WORK GROUP
TOGETHER TO LOOK AT AND IMPROVE
THE PROCESS FOR LICENSING SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS. THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAS HAD AN ACUTE SHORTAGE OF BUS
DRIVERS AND THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL IN THAT PART OF THE
STATE PARTICULARLY. FUNDING FOR
HOME TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION IS
ALSO A CRITICAL PRIORITY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING IT FURTHER
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. THANK FORTY FIVE EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE CRITICAL TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER WE-
SHARE ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL'S
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST
PRESSURES WITH THE LOCK WILL
ALSO NOTE OR GET TO USE THAT BAD
AKRAM WILL ALSO NOTE THAT IT'S A
GREGIS UNFAIR THAT THIS PROGRAM
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
MANY OF WHOSE FAMILIES WORK
SCHEDULES DO NOT FOLLOW THE
TYPICAL EIGHT TO FIVE SCHEDULE.
THE FAMILIES NEED FLEXIBILITY TO
ALLOW THEM TO PARTICIPATE- WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON THE FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM
AND NOTE THAT EVEN WITH THE
AUGMENTATION THE PROGRAM WILL
STILL BE ABOUT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS SHORT SO WE'D URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER EVEN LARGER
AUGMENTATION FINALLY WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE UNIVERSAL
MEAL FUNDING RATES THAT ARE
PROPOSED WILL BE AN ADEQUATE
GIVEN. THE LARGE DEFICITS THAT
MANY ELEAZAR ALREADY AND KERR
AND THEIR CURRENT MEAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND THAT THIS
ENCOURAGEMENT ASSISTANT NICK AND
CONTRIBUTORS TO FISCAL DISTRESS
ESPECIALLY IN SMALL AND RURAL
ELEAZAR WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
A NEED FOR AUGMENTED FUNDING
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE SMALLER.
WORLD WORKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. THANKS FORTY
SIX PLEASE CONTACT. HEY CAN YOU
CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND THE CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE HE
EIGHT THREE REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER ONE I HAVE FOR YEARS
EXPANDED LEARNING AFTERSCHOOL
AND SUMMER LEARNING PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO IMPROVE
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE AND ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS. BUT
CAN SURE THAT STUDENTS WITH THE
HIGHEST NEED TO RECEIVE THE
QUALITY PROGRAMMING THAT THEY
DESERVE AND CAN MAKE THE BAD
TEETH STATE RESOURCES
RESPECTFULLY CALL FOR INCREASED
PER PUPIL FUNDING FOR YELLOW P.
EIGHT AND TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
PROGRAMS AT LIAISON NOT BE ABLE
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING
THAT MEETS THE QUALITY
STANDARDS. AND TO PROVIDE
EDUCATORS THOSE DISTRICT
EMPLOYED OR COMMUNITY BASED
STAFF LIVABLE WAGES UNDER THE
PROPOSED THREE AND STUDENTS NEED
THAT QUALIFIED AND STABLE STAFF
TO BUILD CRITICAL RELATIONSHIPS
THAT HELP BRING GAUGE STUDENTS
AND SUPPORT THEIR LEARNING AND
WELLBEING SECONDLY- WE WANTED TO
HIGH AT HIGHLIGHTED TODAY
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT MORE NEED FOR
A STATE DISCUSSION AND PLANNING
TO ENSURE PROPER ALIGNMENT WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS SUSTAINABLE
PLANNING AND TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND LASTLY WE
WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE YOUTH AGES TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN THAT ALSO ACCESS TO
THESE PROGRAMS TO GET CONNECTED
TO SCHOOL AND ON TRACK FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREER BUT ARE NOT
PRIORITIZED WITH THE ELO KEY
FINDING AND SO WE CALL FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR THOSE MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO
NEED TO FAX FESCUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. MORE DISCUSSION ON
THAT AND WAIT WE CAN STRENGTHEN
AND LEVERAGE THESE PROPOSALS FOR
AFTER SCHOOL AN EXPANDED
LEARNING. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY SEVEN
GOING. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
CARE. THANK YOU CAN GO AHEAD.
GREAT I'M MY NAME IS ALLOWED
SOME CALLING FOR MOM'S
IMPRESSIVE HERE NANCY CANNOT
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ALTHOUGH I
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY THE STATE SHOULD
BE PRIORITIZING EDUCATION AND
SENATE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON A LARGER SCHOOL BUSES
AT THIS TIME WE ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN RIGHT NOW.
WITH EDUCATION ACCESS TO
NUTRITIONAL-THIRD. THE
EMOTIONAL MENTAL. AND OF COURSE.
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO BE
DIRECTING ON THESE ISSUES WE DO
NOT HAVE ADEQUATE RESOURCES.
RIGHT NOW THE COMMON OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR SCHOOLS WE'RE
LACKING AND- IF PEOPLE. AND
EDUCATORS AND BUS DRIVERS I
THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
HIRING VERSUS SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON ELECTRIC BUSES- PLEASE
DON'T CLICK THE FUNDING
APPROPRIATELY AND- HELLO CLEAN
ENERGY BUSES UNTIL WE HAVE
ADDRESSES ISSUES. I POSTED THE
ISSUE AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KATIE HART AND I AM THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER AND THE
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOLS LOCATED IN
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY I
LOVE WORKING WITH YOU TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR SB SEVEN
FORTY. I'VE BEEN MENTIONED
ALREADY BUT ONE UNDER FUNDED IT
DOES HAVE VERY REAL IMPACTS TO
OUR STUDENTS SH AND WE MUST FIND
A VERY. FUNDING FARMING AIR
CORPS ECONOMIC PROGRAMS TO TALK
EDITION FACILITY ARE. THE
VEHICLE ACTIVE SO THESE ARE
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR AND MODEL.
SIR FIRST BECAUSE STUDENT OR NOT
ONLY PAYING FOR COLLEGE ALSO
DISCUSS IN INTEREST PAST OF THE
UNDER CALL OF THE SENSE OF. FOR
THE TO USE THE BECAUSE RECRUITER
TO GET BACK TO THEIR QUEUE. OUR
FACILITY ARE AND KIND THE BY
AND- RENDON THE WITH THE CALL
PREPARATION COLLABORATION AND
PROJECT BASED WORK ALONG WITH.
YOUR IN YOUR MORE PLAYER SHOKI
THAT THEIR WORK WHICH BE FROM
FORTY ALLOWS US TO FOR INSTANCE
THE USED TO SELL NOT THE
RESEARCH THE NEXT. NEED TO
DISCUSS NOT ONLY IN HIGH SCHOOL
BUT ALSO YOUR NECK. ACCESS TO
THE AT THE SO DISCONTINUED BE A
PRIMER CHALLENGE CHARTERS WELSH.
PROGRAMS SIX. SPORTING SCHOOLS
LIKE I. IN HIGH EACH YEAR TO
WORK. ALL THE COMPANY CANNOT
PROPOSED. YOUR OFFICE OF FUNDING
SHORTFALL PROGRAM WILL HELP YOU
CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. FORTY NINE YOUR
- HI MY NAME IF THE MEMBER THE
CAL ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBER AND WE
ALL A PRE THAT DEPARTMENT OF A
WORK AND IMPLEMENTING SCHOOL NOW
FOR ALL IN WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET
GROUP FOR SCHOOL COULD UPGRADE
TRAIN FIRST COLLEGE STAFF AND
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM EVEN
BETTER ARE TO HELPING. CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL CALL ME FOR
ALL STUDENTS AND NOR SHINO SIX
POINT TWO MILLION PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS FRESH PREPARED CAL GROW
WILL MAIL US AT THANK YOU AGAIN
AND PLEASE THE PROPOSED. THANK
NEXT WEEK PLEASE. ONE THIRTY YOU
ARE ALL. HER I WANNA DROP THE
CALL OF ISSUE- I THINK. ISSUE
WITH I BELIEVE WITH A LOT ISSUE
AND THEN ALSO THIS SORT OF A
THEME OF THAT ISSUES- IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME THAT. HE FIRED
THE HE DIDN'T WANT TO SHOP. AND
THE OTHER THING THAT SO FAST TO
IS YOUR- THIS SHORTAGE IN TERMS
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES. WILL YOU
BE. CURRICULA ABOUT THE J. OF
THE TOLD THAT YOU LAWMAKER ARE
CA WITH THE SKY CHAU. BECAUSE
THE PARENTS WON'T FOR. AND JUST
ONE UP. SO WE CAN FROM NAP
MCCALL WE'RE COMING FOR YOUR JOB. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE
FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. MEMBERS
OF THE CHURCH CALL WITH NOURISH
CALIFORNIA COME AT THE END ITEM
TO SCHOOL NUTRITION PERSON THANK
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
PRETTIER INCREDIBLE HISTORIC
COMMITMENT TO FUNDING STATEWIDE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS WE REALLY
APPRECIATED APARTMENT IN LA-
COMMENT TODAY AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE A
GUARANTEED LEVEL STATE FUNDING
BY STRUCTURING THE STATE
UNIVERSAL MEAL REIMBURSEMENT AS
AN ENTITLEMENT RATHER THAN A CAP
THE PROCREATION. OTHERWISE WHEN
THE REGIS SCHOOL MEALS IS
GREATER THAN ANTICIPATED COOL TO
BE AT RISK OF GETTING JUST A
FRACTION OF THE PER MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT THE EXPECTED WE
ALSO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EQUIPMENT AND TRAINING AT
SCHOOLS RAMP UP THE LEVEL OF
YOUR SERVICE ANY TYPE OF FUNDING
INSTABILITY IS OBVIOUSLY HARD ON
SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS AND
ULTIMATELY HARD ON IT. TO GIVE
KIDS THE ACT THAT THEY DESERVE
WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
PER MEAL REIMBURSEMENT BE
GUARANTEED AND NOT AFFECT THE
CHANGE THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. PLEASE MIKE FIFTY SO
EUROPE. HAPPENING AND CAN MANY
IS CODY MAY REST MY MANAGER
FISCAL AT THE ELEMENTARY CHARTER
AND WORLD CLARKSBURG I YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THE SB SEVEN FORTY BARTER
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM THAT'S
FORTY PROGRAM IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR SCHOOLS NOT
ONLY HAVE UNDER FUNDING OF THE
PROGRAM WIPED OUT A 100% OF THE
EXPENSES WE PREVIOUSLY GOT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR. BUT ALSO
WOULD NOT BE DIFFICULT WE
REDUCING THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
LEAST COST REIMBURSEMENT BOTH OF
WHICH REDUCE THE FINES TO
DIRECTLY BENEFIT THE STUDENT
EDUCATION WE ARE THANKFUL THAT
GOVERNOR NEWTON BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES AN INCREASE IN SB FROM
FORTY FUNDING TO HELP CLOSE THE
PROGRAM UNDERFUNDED GAS AND
THEREBY. ENABLE US TO HAVE A
GREATER EMPHASIS ON THE CORE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM. BENEFITING
THE STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. WELL
LINE FIFTY FIVE EUROPE AND- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PETER STONE AND I AM THE CHIEF
BUSINESS OFFICER AT LIGHTHOUSE
CHARTER SCHOOL IN THE LOWEST
SOCIOECONOMIC SECTION OF WEST
SACRAMENTO. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
SB SEVEN FORTY CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM. THE SB
SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
SCHOOL IS WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO LOCAL SCHOOL BOND FUNDS SO WE
HAVE HAD TO FINANCE OUR
FACILITIES USING OUR EIGHTY
EIGHT BASED GENERAL FUND
INTENDED FOR THE STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM. SB SEVEN
FORTY PROGRAM HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED FOR
YEARS WHICH LOWERS DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR THE DIRECT COSTS
OF EDUCATING. THE STUDENTS
ENTRUSTED TO US WE ARE THANKFUL
GOVERNOR NUISANCE BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN INCREASE IN
SB SEVEN FORTY FUNDING. THAT
HELPS CLOSE THE PROGRAMS
UNDERFUNDED GAP IN THEIR BODY
ENABLES US TO HAVE A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON CORE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS BENEFITING STUDENTS.
THANKS SO MUCH BYE BYE. THANK
YOU. THANKS BAKER PLEASE. PINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR OPENED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JENNIFER
BAKER AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION HAVING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER ARE
REQUESTING AN APPROPRIATION
DISAGGREGATE DATA IN ORDER TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA GUIDANCE
AND RESOURCES TO ENSURE LONG
TERM ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS
ARE CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED AND
PROVIDED WITH TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS THAT BEST MEET
THEIR NEEDS WHILE WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO REPEAT CONCEPT
MEANT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. AND I REQUEST WILL
NOT BE AVAILABLE ON THEIR
EXISTING WEBSITE THE PANDEMIC IS
TRULY INCREASE THE NEED FOR MORE
WILL ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS
IN WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
HELP MAKE SURE. THE INTERFERE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. AND FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRENDA TELL
THEM ON BEHALF OF INACTION
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND SECURING FREE SCHOOL MEALS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS NEXT
AND STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
YEAR'S CRITICAL INVESTMENTS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR SCHOOL NUTRITION INCLUDING
FULLY FUNDING SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL WHILE ALSO PROVIDING THE
FULL AMOUNT REQUESTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
SCHOOL NUTRITION STAFF TRAINING
AND EQUIPMENT. WHICH WILL HELP
ENSURE WE ARE PROVIDING HEALTHY
MEALS FOR STUDENTS WE URGE YOU
TO PLEASE KEEP. THIS ITEM OPEN
TO COLLECT MORE DATA AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THE HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
PROGRAM. FOR PROPER STAFFING
TRAINING RESOURCES AND EQUIPMENT
TO THIRD MORTGAGE RICHEST MALES
ALL HUNGRY IT AND ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THAT DOES- EXHAUSTS ARE TO
TODAY. OKAY THANK THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN A WAY THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN